Hello everybody!
I am back yet again.
Did you guys enjoy your, uh, your, what was it, 12 hour intermission for more rivals?
It's like you guys went to sleep, wake up, and wow, she's back.
I'm back.
I'm back with more rivals.
Yes, I know I said like, oh, maybe I'll do a stream on YouTube.
Like, do me a Zatsudan or Silk Song?
But you know what?
I decided to give in to my cravings because I was like, wait, it's the final count.
countdown.
There's almost 24 hours left of rank.
People are desperate now.
They want to get in.
And I, I will be the gatekeeper.
I, dawn of the final day, I will be the gatekeeper.
I am here to crush some dreams tonight.
all these people with hope that maybe they can secure top 500 i will be the eo mm terrorist today i was terrorized for a week and now it's my turn i put on the mask it only takes one bad it was several bad days it actually several days.
And now I've become the thing I most hated.
An E-O-M-M demon.
The two McHugh final boss.
Fully the hopeful.
So they've become the hopeless.
They gotta stop hoping.
It's pathetic.
Hope.
Hope is a lie.
I'm here to teach them
I mean it bring them to the real world Also for those who were watching For those who were watching last stream Or like you know the portion that where we got like this asshole on my team I reported him to the devs Okay it's so funny I sent them a message to my contacts Yeah,
of course, just shoot over the name.
An FBI will take action.
He was just like, don't worry.
The FBI is here.
He didn't get banned.
He got, like, muted.
I don't know for how long.
Because, you know, I don't...
I'm not sure if, though, he'll get banned.
Like, he'll get, like, suspended, like, a timeout for throwing the game.
Um, so I got the I got this message.
He has been muted.
Thank you for helping us maintain a positive community environment.
No, thank you, Marvel Rivals.
I the fuck boy investigator.
Yeah.
It's crazy.
Positive community environment.
And my stream title is top 500 gatekeeper.
guys see you guys i am maintaining a positive community environment for all
i'm such i'm a positive influence to the marvel rivals community yeah there can only be one elo terrorist and it's gonna be me i'm not throwing though i'm not I'm just very unlucky That's the thing I'm tech.
I'm not throw I haven't throw I make mistakes.
Yes, I make mistakes, but I'm not actually through I'm just very unlucky in my games
I just I just games just don't go for me.
Okay, I just get very unlucky RNG I never throw on purpose.
It's all an accident.
Also If I get any invitations from any new any players My only requirement is that you are trying to get top 500 You're close to top 500 or you're almost out You're you are top 500
Those are and it has to be on account Can't be on an alt account That's like I don't know GM or some fucking shit your main or an alt account that is on the leaderboards or almost on the leaderboards or like you know like g or celestia because uh i i won't i'm here i'm here to free up some space on the leaderboards i'm i'm here i'm here to free up so to mad no no it's all about sending a message right now i'm here to clean up the leaderboards i and we're like okay this is like um old overwatch lore but for those who remember aimbot calvin he had like 10 accounts in top 500 and people were like stop hogging up all the spots in top 500 with your alt account and he was just like just get good and then i'm like don't worry i will fix the problem by getting all these alt accounts off of top i'm gonna fix the i'm gonna fix this problem by taking them all down and out of the leaderboard by making them play with me.
I'm doing a service.
I'm a hero.
But yeah, it's because of what he said that Blizzard had to implement the phone number.
So that's why your account is now linked to your phone number to qualify for a top 500 leaderboard because he was like, like just get good then like people were complaining about why he had so many all accounts for top 500 and that he should free up some space for people who were trying to get it on their main accounts and he was like bro then just get better just get good like it's a skill issue right yeah and then he went and got all of his family members phone numbers implemented onto his accounts so he still continued to take up space on the leaderboard It's like,
well, you're going to add phone numbers?
I got 10 family members who I can borrow phone numbers from.
Yeah, that's why.
That's why your accounts are have to be linked to a number.
I hate to get it.
I hate to get him on the other team.
All that just to rage made people.
It fucking worked anyway.
Anyway, it's time.
I didn't warm up at all.
I took a little nap for those who were wondering.
I actually did take a tiny nap.
So I'm not going to be streaming 10 hours like last time, chat.
With the power.
Yeah, he is like advanced level gatekeeping.
With the power of family, I will become the gatekeeper.
I didn't warm up, so it's time.
I think this is the perfect time to queue more rain.
But yes, I did take a little nap.
And I woke up, walked, dad ate some food, and I was like, it's time.
It's time to put on the robe.
It's time to gatekeep, crush all these people who are trying to get top 500 on the final day.
No, I didn't sleep.
I didn't sleep.
I think I took like a three hour nap.
I think I think it's I but like I didn't set up alarm I just woke up naturally so um but yeah tomorrow there's a sponsor stream on YouTube it's with uh chibi doki so it's with mini me uh my child um and it's only gonna be an hour long though I'm just gonna give you to you guys straight so if you guys are like oh my god it's so short um but after that we won't do because it's like sponsored but after that we will do longer playthroughs of um of little nightmares three um um after like after that week uh so don't worry you're just like oh it's just an hour you guys are gonna keep going but we will keep going it's just uh for the sponsor portion it's just an hour to for tomorrow i'm just gonna i'm just letting you guys know early just in case people like why is it just an hour um is this live or one of the things where they do a pre-recorded video as a stream hard to tell since i've seen that ai thing um yes it is pre-recorded and i'm sorry this is actually pre-recorded i have a i use
chat gpt to generate my chat for me to be GPT.
I would be streaming Marvel Rivals.
What would my chat be like?
And this answer was also in the chat GPT prompt, like answer as well.
So yes, this is all AI generated.
What you see on the screen, with the power of AI, we can predict the future.
This is a pre-recorded chat.
Beep, boop, pop.
Oh, damn.
No more AI slides.
Gordon, thank you for the thousand bitties.
Thank you.
Why the fuck are you live?
I did go to bed.
But I want to ruin some dreams today.
Okay, well, I did ruin some dreams last night.
But I want to keep going.
It gave me so much pleasure.
Out of... I was so sad until I realized, wait, I can make other people sad too.
And then that made me a little happier.
But it's okay.
Look what this letter said.
Thank you for helping us maintain a positive community environment.
Is that happiness from other people's misery?
You know what's up, Tempo.
You know what's up.
You're great at doing that.
What do you want to be today?
all right I want to play Matt not a match invisible woman see that agrees with me too grab my top drop real quick pop pop pop he's I don't know why he's barking right now oh you see the gooner skin yeah I think this is my favorite invisible woman skin but like i have i have standards for the gooners skin because i hate the luna one i don't like the luna swimsuit i don't know why he's barking though i think he wants to be on my bed i
think but i'm not allowing him he's so spoiled do you like any luna skin no
don't like i just don't like the color combination and i think the colors they pick for is like pretty bad for her skins all right give me a sec let me check him out real quick oh my god we didn't ban a second kit oh my god that's okay as long as no one's getting top five
okay i gave him my bed it's not like i'm I'm sleeping on it anyway Alright
Why didn't I say Because I was talking to you
I'll be there in 8 I won't be streaming for 8 hours Riggsie More likely You will find me deranged But it's okay If I deranged it means others suffer the same fate Because we lose as a team The battle starts in five, four, three, two, one.
Zirasha, thank you for Twitch Prime.
Thank you, thank you.
All right, I swear to God, if I see three supports, I swear to God.
I swear to fucking God, if I see three supports on my team, I will be so angry.
I will be...
All right.
Okay, it's not three supports.
Okay.
I don't even know how I died there.
This sucks because I'm...
I don't hate doing duo support with Mantis.
It's...
Oh my god.
I hate it.
It's fine.
It's just not fun.
At least, like, they don't have any clothes for Angelus for now.
Alright, this is actually...
Okay, I'm gonna try to focus up a little bit because, like I said, I didn't warm up at all.
So it's not as...
as usual.
Where are you, Mantis?
What the fuck, Matt?
Please.
Okay.
That's fine.
It's fine.
Oh my god, the amplifier died so fast.
That's... Oh my god, okay.
I don't know, can we get rid of this mag?
That's just...
here no that's fine that's that's fine absolutely fuck me i guess all right that's okay you do not have portal that's okay we don't we don't you yeah i'm like just me all right That's okay.
Oh my god.
There we go.
We're losing.
Let's play triple support.
We're losing now.
There we go.
I mean, we have Mantis all.
Like, we're not...
Are we really not gonna use it?
I have to continue this melee because...
Oh, that's unlucky.
up i don't have oh oh i don't think he's gonna victory him honestly this sucks only because like
like i don't know what else they want me to do but i'm gonna save my punish all for my my elf yeah there's it's there's no reason to pop that we were down three anyway
Oh my god, why can't their team be stubborn like my team?
It's not fair.
I wish my team was as stubborn as their team, where they refuse to...
Oh my god.
There you go.
This is a lot of...
Woo!
Where am I?
There you go.
We used three of us for that, but that's fine.
We won the point.
The Elo should be gated.
Locked in.
All right, time to push.
Time to push this card because no one else wants to push it, which is fine.
Bye.
Oh, now.
Just keep pushing the card.
Time to keep pushing.
There you go.
Did my job.
Why would you not play Sue?
Like, I don't understand.
Like, why would you not play Sue?
Like, That is the...
You play it.
Cloak?
Just...
That's the easiest count.
Okay, I shouldn't say that.
They're gonna swap this to the moment I say that.
They're gonna do it.
I know it.
I feel it in my bones.
I say it and they're gonna do it.
The reason why I have to melee is I don't melee, I'll be invisible.
And like, I don't want to waste my bullets shooting my gun to not be invisible.
Oh, here she is.
Where does she go?
There she go.
There she is.
Okay.
I'm worried I would waste ammo if I accidentally melee too much.
Holy shit!
That's a lot of damage!
Oh
Hey guys, hey guys, hey guys, um There's literally just one guy
One oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, that's so unlucky Wow, if only we killed the mag Was on the point If only...
If only we did the one thing.
Oh my god.
It's like...
If we did that, maybe we could have capped that point.
Is that crazy concept?
Honestly, a fucking...
A whole leash.
I don't know how you live that long, though.
Not gonna lie.
Please don't push him to me.
Target priority is crazy crazy concept I would love to heal I should went high ground with our Punisher because we don't really have front line oh well I want to heal my tank there you go hey hey guys there you go I just heal into that all right there you go there There we go.
And we just gotta destroy this.
We just gotta destroy this.
And we did it.
The current score is 3, 2, 0.
Camping point is illegal.
People just rather, people go for kills instead of going for objective.
I'm the type who fades quietly into the background.
The right heroes could make all the difference.
I think your entire team is so fun to shoot.
Not only here!
Oh geez.
That's crazy.
What BM?
No, the enemy team is a little dumb.
But maybe they'll surrender.
This is a good warm-up game though.
Because I'm definitely not warmed up.
I feel...
Oh.
I'm definitely not warmed up right now why win when you can over extend true just winners queue right now so it's a working wait I'll add I'm gonna add him
winners queue you say and then if he accepts and then we lose our first game I'll Be like welcome to losers cute and then and then leave the duo and then I doki can fix that Is that fucked up?
Is that fucked up?
Guess how that fucked up, right?
It can't be that much It's not that bad of me to do Oh nice and then I just oh goodbye I leave No.
I leave.
Just drop.
Okay.
It's all so fucked up.
Okay, but is it, though?
That's subjective.
How fucked up is it, though?
Like, is this...
just like you know it's just a little tiki fun times just some little fun times you know just just be a little pesky rascal yeah boys will be boys
what if like he tries to eat me no okay that's okay um i i i think he was to do the bug where the you can oh where am i oh i keep forgetting where tps go sometimes i don't use i should use the tps more because i normally forget where the tps go thank god they're really bad at they're really bad at triple support thank fucking god that's what i meet in life
are they okay oh he's okay this guy is right now on strange and our angela too to be fair all right goodbye oh they didn't touch point oh they surrendered all right let's check let's check this man's winner queue yeah free game that was easy i was gonna say what how are they like not and a good and a coded rocket i got edsy and a golden golden rocket player that dies on cooldown what did he play oh To be fair,
I have legit five dogs.
Oh, wait, this guy.
I was flanking and shooting your rocket literally all day.
All right.
That's crazy.
Yo, RXX.
Punisher 1V1.
Bro.
we're not gonna we're not gonna add him through this guy is glazing himself too fucking much one v one me never mind bro got 29 at bro what this guy this guy is i hate it one v one v bro bro this guy said no wait what was it this guy said nothing talked at all it's just it's like it's just a random free fire just shot a random bystander punish your only no items final destination bro's on a massive eco trip right now from one game all right that is not winners cute bro that is not winners cute oh this guy has oh my god fucking delusional is actually delusional right now like he is actually all he has bro what the fuck i expected a golden car i did too oh my god fate is not doing so well right now
that's my that's my one Oh,
that is...
Oh.
Alright, let's go.
And again.
We go again.
Yeah, at least he won his scrims or tournament games.
He is in Winner's queue.
Two games.
Two people are winning two in a row.
is honestly very inspirational.
Bro, remember that guy?
This guy that added me yesterday?
Bro, look at this.
Look at this.
This is a golden...
This is like...
This makes me angry.
I should have dragged him down when I had the chance.
I...
When did I show up?
I knew I showed up somewhere.
I should have added this man when I had the chance to bring him down.
I'm angry.
I could have stopped this.
So happy for you.
I could have stopped this when I had the chance.
I should have asked him for a duel.
So, so happy for him.
I don't even know when I should have.
showed up.
Because I added this guy.
He added me yesterday.
Wait, does he, yeah, he secures it too.
That's the worst part.
Leave Apollo alone.
Was it the fourth game?
One, two, three, four?
No, it wasn't.
Oh, one, two, three, four here.
Oh my God, when he fired me, he fucking added me here.
Do you think?
Yeah, when he fired me, he added me.
How dare he?
Makes me angry.
And this is why I'm online right now.
This is why I'm streaming right now to prevent this from happening again.
Rank 68?
Hmm.
Which hero do you think you have me today?
We can fix that.
Oh yeah, that guy's a...
That guy's was a Hulk one trick, wasn't he?
Um, Hulk one trick on enemy team.
Should we ban Hulk?
Y'all boy is a pretty decent Hulk player.
Should we ban...
Hulk in case of team up.
Yeah, we can ban Hulk too.
Hulk or Jeff, IMO.
Not Mag, I can play Mag.
Alright, we'll do Jeff.
I'll do Jeff.
It's your boy.
Yeah.
I just remember him playing Hulk because we were like, can you swap off Hulk and then No reply That's all I remember because everyone was like get off Hulk get off and just Zero response.
Yes man just has this man just has his air pods on.
No, he doesn't even say no He didn't even say no.
He just was just fucking playing Hulk with his air pods on.
He didn't fucking care
Oh, if he's playing I don't have to play Luna for the team up because team up is actually pretty decent type who fades quite oh never mind i'm not the type i'm luna snow like the moon fucky phoenix no more pun um you can talk about you should be fine all right you can play the punisher is that what you're telling me to see something here we go where oh i could play rocket number five go away number two what do you want to play oh no i i play pun i'm the punisher Wait,
what?
Oh, I am the Punisher.
Okay.
I thought you were like...
I like Ultra.
I want him to play Punisher in practice range in 1v1.
I want to play Punisher.
Wait, oh my God.
Is this the rifle guy again?
Oh my God.
It's him again.
He's like, I want it to 1v1.
Oh my God.
I have to play.
I have to play too.
And I have the best aim in Marble Rivals.
That's unlucky.
Like that guy?
I know the Mantis proved that.
Mantis, I know you heard all those headshots, right?
Jesus.
Club is one, club is one.
In the back.
Luna one as well.
Luna one, Luna one.
Both heroes are one.
I'm flaking them.
Oh my god.
Luna one.
That Namor is half up there, by the way.
Hey, guys.
Anyone
All right, all right, this is not great for me All right It's time for me to play It's time to play this guy I don't know I did too.
I knew I knew we should have been I knew we should have been fucking Bruce All right, I didn't even get healed
All right, here we go All right, here we go I'm doing this my way What the fuck?
Where is he?
I got you a shield Bro, our mantis left me Two of my supports left me Bro What?
I don't give up so easily.
They both let me get you!
I thought I should have done that a little earlier.
That's actually...
That's crazy.
Both my supports left me there.
Like, I don't...
Did you guys see that?
That's...
That makes me so sad.
I'm losing now because I didn't get all two.
That's really annoying.
9 more 1 please please hold that's all i want damage boost me damage boost me your team's capture progress has passed the halfway game that's all i want in the please
bro stop do you really i have a point please please stop can we burn this Oh my god, it saves me this!
Headshot, headshot, headshot.
Oh my god, stop!
It's actually so good.
We're still on point here.
Oh my god.
Okay, thank god we didn't do a Q.
Thank god, we didn't do a Q, we didn't add him.
This guy is actually so fucking cringe.
So fucking cringe.
He's like, bro, this is so cringe, bro.
It's just like, bro, so fucking cringe.
This Q is, the Doom Q give-up and the Doom Q take it.
There you go.
You're fucking welcome.
My support isn't feeling.
She's just damage boosting, which is very unfortunate.
magic behind she's looking there you go this is the only thing i can do oh my god why are you so far why are you so far oh my god
oh thank god thank god they swapped thank god I don't think maybe we might actually have time yet.
I can jump through.
I don't think so.
Don't get up for it.
I'm gonna take care of it some more.
Okay.
Jesus Christ, it was blocking me.
Oh my god!
Are you...
I hate this one-hit combo.
I was trying to leave because I knew she had...
Okay.
Oh yeah, first time ever on stream.
She, the, the thing, the...
Magic can do a one-hit combo, so I was trying to leave as much as I can.
I was literally trying to get my, get the shit out of here.
But I couldn't, sadly.
I don't know how to use the primary on the Shiro.
I sadly could not leave.
It did not let me leave.
And it made me very, very sad.
All right.
I'm trying my best to heal.
Hey guys, we're gonna be funny if we banned Bruce back.
Oh my god, wow.
If only we banned the team up.
Oh man.
I sure wish we banned the fucking team up.
And just set him jack.
I knew it.
I was like, most likely they're gonna play it.
Even more.
Trip support.
Boom, boom, boom.
Win.
I feel like if he goes Ultron and I'm on Thor, you're on...
It feels good to step outside.
They want him to have bad.
Yeah.
Also mixed in.
Yeah, this works too.
Oh, I can't play Luna.
They have a fucking Angela.
Oh, the fuck.
You have a Lord Ultron?
30 seconds.
Just keep Punisher drone.
Get ready.
That was a Doom Q.
It's going great.
It's going great, guys.
It's actually going amazing.
My support left me to die, like, three times in a row.
It was great.
I literally watched my mantis walk away from me, like, three times.
So much fun.
I did let her die one time, but that was to teach her a lesson.
And be like, it's not so fun, is it?
Being left alone.
It's not that fun, right?
Yeah.
You have as you have even less mobility than me.
Angela coming behind us right here.
Focus Angela, Angela, Angela, Angela.
She is not one.
That was a fucking lie.
Now she's one.
All right.
All right, drop down.
Just don't drop though.
Don't drop yet.
Oh.
Stay up.
The whole team needs to stay up here and save lives.
I thought I could stall Goodbye, this is where I leave This is where I leave Oh my god, I couldn't fucking push her because a group wall fucking mispositioned me Come Please where are we going?
We have five six us pick a place to go holy shit where are we oh my god like i i'm so confused with my team use your ult use your ult your mantis use your oh my god oh my god no cloak in the back
Oh my god.
Jesus Christ.
This is not a team.
This is six people that found themselves in quick play.
Six people in quick play.
This is absolutely not a team.
I do not believe.
Hello.
Oh my god.
I live.
I'm bold.
I'm gonna push her out.
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
Can we find up here?
I have a little corner.
Jesus Christ.
So much damage.
Oh the fuck did he die?
I need it.
I don't want to push now.
I had to push.
I'm dead.
I am so dead.
I am, oh my, I did everything I could.
Bro, I got you!
I was trying to stall as much as Akko.
I'm going to kill everyone on the wall.
That's fine.
He got XL.
That was such a good XL too.
All right, here we go.
They don't need me.
Okay, they might need me.
We should just walk in with Mantis.
Go, go.
Why did you go so?
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
That's fine.
i'm more dead too it's okay it's okay we don't wipe but whatever okay i this is okay matic's still behind us somewhere i think he's not i have it right here i got close okay nice the tp on point taking it with them go strange oh yeah
Please tell me she doesn't see me.
I have one second until I can go disappear.
I'm low, I'm low, I'm low.
Bro, this is not a team.
I swear to God, I am...
I am not playing with a team because where are we?
We, where are we?
So they don't interrupt it.
Actually, where the fuck are we?
We are not a team.
Oh.
Oh, it's an all coming up.
Oh my god.
Oh, cool.
Magic behind.
Oh, you should have jumped through.
uh keep everyone up keep everyone wait train one train one train one oh no way no way like where are we as a team like actually where are we
it's okay i'm helping i'm helping i'm helping i'm helping i'm helping i'm helping i'm helping i'm actually helping he's so stupid he's so they're all so stupid oh my god they're this oh my this both teams are so fucking dumb like some
teams are fucking stupid i no shot no i'm surrounded by morons i'm we're in some battle of the clouds right now it really is It's the crazy part.
This is one round, one round, but one ring below top 500.
That's the crazy part.
This is one ring below top 500.
Steve, welcome to Celestia lobbies.
This map's a lot better for me, so should be chilling.
Everyone's in the same state of mind.
I'm supposed to be the Elo Terrorist, not them.
Oh my god, I forgot to split this up.
Now I'm the Elo Terrorist.
I forgot to put my shields up.
The most important part.
I'm staying as Rocket, so because I have all of them anyway.
And they don't have...
They don't really have anything for it.
They don't have Phoenix, so...
I'm not gonna engage with this.
I don't have to, but I expand.
Oh, they don't have Anja.
Jesus.
How many ults would you guys like to use, everybody?
How many?
at how many alts would you like to use
yes yeah try to try to capture someone i'll give you a good angle for your threat all right now i can put it in a because they're not on oh actually i'll split them off yeah that gives
thanks for the shield where they armed and dangerous Where the arm is dangerous right now?
No more else, no more else for this.
Can I get back?
Please,
thank you.
Come on, rocket.
Thank you.
Yo, shoot the rocket.
I was gonna say where though?
How did they get so many?
All right.
i'm good to go yeah they're in trouble now oh my god they wanna win keep our keep our punisher alive you guys can help me for all charge i'm playing out for the only bro bro we don't need more health i'm gonna give it to him
that's going mac got res behind us mac res behind us
I'm a little scared.
I'm blocking his heels.
It's going.
All right.
I have all here.
We're just going to kill him.
All right.
It's so stressful.
I'm actually hard focusing right now.
This is a dumbass game.
This game was so stressful.
stupid this game is so stupid oh it's okay I I didn't need my it's okay oh my god fuck he didn't get his reset is that what you wanted oh at least he didn't get his reset you know at least he didn't get is reset oh my god it's what you wanted he didn't i'm still stalling they should both support are they there you go you're fucking good i wish i didn't use mago but it's fine we got for 99.
i saw a free kill in the monkey sleeping but i didn't Did you see the Ultron and the Mantis both ignored me for...
For years?
It was...
It was great.
It was really great.
I'm behind you, yeah.
I have it in 4%.
It was... it was truly great.
I had to use clap.
I love clapping.
I'll take advantage of what we're doing.
Hi, bubble me, bubble.
Oh my god.
I got you bubble now.
All right, look at this.
How can we get a quick Q?
All right.
I'm walking the kills.
Come back.
Goodbye.
Oh my god, he missed.
Oh my god, he actually didn't have level play.
What are you guys?
Kill him, kill him, kill him.
Oh my god, he actually missed.
He actually missed.
Thank god.
God is real.
Nice.
You win these Yo, good job rank one.
Thanks, bro.
Honey Good job.
I love number one Punisher
I should not be winning these games.
I need okay.
I need to watch the replay Both teams are fucking stupid like I I I think the fact that like both teams were like Elo Terrace.
I told you he was gone.
His ego is astronomical.
Sub to your barber on YouTube for insane punishing gameplay.
He is his own number one fan.
I mean, power to you.
Me too.
I have my own shrine of myself.
Okay, I need to watch this.
this specific playthrough uh and you see what how like how close was i to the enemy team
okay what was it was here right here here i am now i positioned myself perfectly
I positioned myself perfectly.
Wait, where's my crosshair?
Where the fuck?
Okay, there we go.
Oh, whoops.
There we go.
Right here.
Oh.
Wait.
Wait, actually.
All right.
How do I rewind?
My God, I'm so stupid with this.
All right.
Bro, my crosshair is gone.
I can't...
Okay, we gotta redo the replay.
I can't even move my replay.
All right.
Now, I was like, what happened to my fucking crosshair?
There it is.
Jesus.
I was like, bro, what the fuck happened to it?
All right.
Here it is.
A moment of truth.
Recap.
Here it is.
We get the POV right here.
Where am I?
Oh, I'm just here.
There I go.
Setting up.
Here I am.
Just chilling.
They don't know.
Gamers just don't look up.
There I go.
Killing everyone.
here oh there's the hog I'm very oh hey hey stay oh there's two of them with me up top goodbye riveting gameplay right now actual insane gameplay
and he still didn't see me the fact that the string still didn't see me when I when he blew up this should not be happening Happening in Celeste Gamer's don't look up.
That's crazy the fact that like this guy still What a freaking circus none of us deserved Elo in that game none None of us the perfect spy look look what the
The vision is based on movement and then he flew up a second time look at this look at this he's like hmm he didn't notice me until i shot him he actually didn't even know nothing to see here all right we gotta see you're right you're right guys
wait that's crazy wait that's crazy Where is he?
Wait, that's actually an insane hiding spot.
I'm over here.
I'm already not thinking where the heals coming from.
Where the fuck are the rocket bullets coming from?
He's like, where is he?
Wait, where is he?
I think he flew up because he knew I was there, but he was like, where's he going?
Where did he go?
Like, yeah.
Because I was in, like, I was in, like, the corridor.
He saw the orbs and he was so confused.
He knew what he didn't knew at the same time.
All right.
And then, oh, he said it!
See me!
He saw!
Wait, what's my tail peeking through?
That was crazy.
I boozled the guy by standing still in the corner.
Did you see his movements?
Holy shit, a rat.
Where does this rat come from?
Okay, where's the tail?
Oh shit, where's the tail?
I need to know.
Apparently my tail was peeking through.
He's probably watching the replay too.
He's like, where was the raccoon?
There I have it's true and I was like wait this one I didn't this wall did this wall always have a tail weird looking rock yeah that's a weird weird fucking rock over there this was this was kind of furry He's just like where did the raccoon go I thought he was up here It's like an easter egg It really is If you blink you'll miss it You know That's great This should not The fact that This is one tier Below This guy is checking if he's top 500 secure There's no way I'm pretty sure I'm pretty sure he's checking Every He's like Every hour to see if he's secure top 500.
He's scared.
He's fucking scared.
He doesn't know.
He doesn't know if he's secure or not.
He's checking every hour.
By the hour.
Celestial one?
I think it'll be high Celestial two.
I think it'll just be like just high Celestial two.
I'm pretty sure.
I could be wrong.
Because last season was...
Last time it was Celestia 1.
Alright.
Let's go into Doom matches.
Standing still.
No one's...
See, I learned, guys.
I learned from...
Oh my god.
These are actual killers in my lobby.
I learned from Apex.
My ability to rat.
the raccoon.
That's where the rat comes from.
Oh, wait.
No, they're not.
Hello.
Whoa!
Oh, she's just sitting with him.
Okay, she's just sitting with him.
Okay, that's...
Oh, that's cute.
Look, they're e-dating.
Oh.
Hello, ma'am.
We are undating.
No one's judging.
This is a judge-free snow.
Guys, sniff us.
Don't mess with the amazing Spider-Man!
I'm just sniffing.
Wait, what else?
Oh, and you have this.
The cup of...
Yeah, I'm the dog.
Wolf, wolf.
Hello.
Tease good girl.
Wait.
T's a good girl.
Oh my gosh, who's T?
That's not T.
That's caught.
Wait a minute.
This guy's name's not T.
Drama.
She's cheating.
Oh my god.
Poor T.
She ain't...
No.
Guys, I don't think she's a good girl.
Oh!
Oh, I'm sorry!
I won't go!
I won't stitch!
I'm the candid camera girl.
She kicked the dot.
She knew I wanted to expose her.
And she taught me a lesson.
No witnesses.
Oh, sorry.
Sorry.
I was just spitting.
Latino bean boy.
Oh, God, T.
How many other girls does she...
How many other guys is she talking to?
Bro!
She belongs in the street!
The final thing I do before I kill.
The last thing I do before I leave is a little...
Not one last chance for the ride.
What, Chiro, do you think you want to be today?
I'm not the type who fades quietly just a little nibble I can't spell street without tea I know I might have had a below standard performance last game it was a fluke it was a fluke what does he mean by that guys I think tea's good girl might be tea's a bad girl then my bucky we're chilling I'm here all night,
guys.
Uh...
What?
Pick your hero.
This is a pre-lord shit that I was not aware of.
What is this pre-lord shit?
Fine.
Fine!
Stupid cloak player.
Do we want a triple or do we want two tanks?
God damn fucking yeah.
Fucking yeah.
Cloket player.
Cham, sham, get on hella.
Get on hella.
I'm sad.
I just wanted to play Invis.
That's all I wanted to do.
30 seconds before you attack.
Back to Luna Gel, I go.
I mean, if he plays Ultron, then I'll say Luna.
Okay, he's not.
Okay.
I ain't playing Luna.
I don't think I need to play.
We have double tanks.
I can build all super fast with these two.
Yay.
No Luna Gel.
Let's go.
Yiffy.
Happiness, joy.
For a little longer.
all right off we go
i've been winning too much it's time for the eom agents to click in i don't like it it feels sus doesn't feel right
has to be the thing is there has to be a catch
oh my god there's always a catch
oh my god the focus everybody's taking so much damage jesus christ everyone's taking too much damage i don't like it I have a Holy shit, I built all so fast
Oh my god, please Please, please Oh my, I have to counter that I got scared He has all two Nice Oh, not nice now Not nice Nice
Oh nice, okay, still nice
What's going on?
What are these fights?
Holy shit, bro, okay, these guys try Why do these guys try even harder on the last day versus yesterday?
I think it's just the last 24 hours.
More of a risk factor.
I'm getting some pretty fucking crazy games right now.
I am not ready for this.
I thought I was gonna get some more clowns.
Oh, actually no, I did get clowns yesterday, like last game.
But you know what I mean.
You know what I mean.
These guys are like...
They might be clowns, but they're also like...
I got... I was just like ring around the rosy.
Holy shit.
Okay, we got 99.
We got 99.
I don't know where I was.
I felt like I was so lost.
Life was a highway.
Life was truly... It feels like the games are more intense, but also they are very unorganized.
That's how it feels like now that I think about it.
Like everybody is not... I feel like I'm playing Quitsay, but with more risk.
involved like this is gamer quick play oh my god i didn't think i didn't think he would walk up um i should have ulted i didn't want to oh because it felt like a useless uh like this does not feel like a team game right now it really does not what Bro,
are we going in with...
Okay, guys, we're just getting picked one by one, guys.
Hello?
Can we not get picked one by one?
Can I walk with Emma here?
Oh, my God.
Okay, that's good.
I literally needed a little bit of heals.
That's so unlucky.
One point.
I got...
I don't give up so easily.
I got knocked out of my ult by the Thor.
Oh, no.
Oh, teleport.
Might not have time, though.
We just kept feeding.
That's unlucky.
All of us just kept feeding non-stop.
I'm still reporting.
I'm opening a portal.
I'm coming over.
Oh, my God.
I wish we weren't feeding, though.
oh my god oh my god
why did we get picked three times in a row I had to say something I just did I had to say something went downhill you can count on me i gotta play no starlord a course i had to say something and then everything just went downhill it's always like that i was i was like this feels too easy and then the game was like bet oh wow you saw enough of a challenge all right like oh my martine fucking went and died like three times in a row each person got picked one by one that's so unlucky we could have easily we could have easily uh had three fights there
which sucked like we were doing so well and then they all were like but what if i just walk up by myself team this is what i'm saying it feels like i'm just playing quick play with six people or five people.
It doesn't feel like I'm playing a real fucking match.
Like, this game
and...
Okay.
I got both before this.
Yeah, they're dying on top.
Alright, that's fine.
That's fine.
Like, we win through aim, but we don't win the alt battle.
That's the issue.
Like, when they have better alt rotation, we just don't win.
If alts didn't exist in this game, we win.
I want a hero shooter where we don't have alts.
It's just pure aim and abilities.
Where are those games?
No util.
Is he at?
No util!
I can all first.
We love Thud.
No, man, he's dead.
Alright, I said I can all first.
So if they don't listen, that's on them.
Look at that.
I'm so nice in game.
As long as you don't open my bye.
Wow, I was like trash talking my team.
As long as they...
He's like, wow, she sounds so nice.
I have my positive.
Oh, never mind.
Okay.
Good luck.
That was not a damage boost.
Oh my gosh, she's so...
She's so alive.
But not me, though.
Not me.
She was so alive until she wasn't.
I should not have fucking...
Oh my god, why did she ult that?
She was so scared.
That's unlucky.
If she didn't ult that, we would have had...
I need to heal.
That was such a weird ult.
That was a very unnecessary ult too.
Oh my god, yeah.
I'm a little scared.
Well, at least...
At least the Hella did something.
Aw, but the Hella died.
What?
Let's just...
Just give.
Please, let's not get picked, guys.
That's how we lost last time, guys.
That's how guys that's how we lost last time That's that's That's the fourth man
Okay Luna you can all first I am ready to put on a show Rehoves the god of thunder All right Oh please no he didn't he didn't block me why
why did he why did he what am i doing i'm
meg i'm big
that's crazy
avoid for Jay's life.
Oh my God.
I should have just alted first.
And they're going to do that combo.
I didn't want to alt first because last time I was like, oh, I'll alt first.
And then my Luna alted.
And I was like, Luna?
Okay, I'll let you alt.
I'll let you alt.
You know what?
I'm just going to avoid the Luna.
them too i don't think they're a support player oh yeah no they are 100 not a support player yeah i had a feeling i had it all right oh you got this what a surprise i oh maybe i should i i think if i ulted first they wouldn't have the combo but then that would mean i have to be like away from the combo i have to be like make sure away from the combo and also my team would have died to the combo too so like my team couldn't play in the alt because of the combo only the tanks i think only the tanks can survive it i'm pretty sure yeah my team at zero team up i told you if my team what if my team play by pure just skill and aim we win but Our team,
my team was so bad with alts.
They were so, they were fucking so bad with alt rotation.
Like, like, I can't fix that.
We had no team in my team play.
Team used loosely.
I swear to God, I am not.
They actually win because of the fact that their team actually worked together.
their team is hard my last two games felt like i was playing quickly for real i don't know what emotes oh wait i have this one oh it is oh my god how long has dog boys been in this lobby this guy has definitely been here for do people just hang out and do match just for fun is that a thing that people do sorry for your loss lost my mom chat jesus christ is this free therapy what is going on hey guys did i hear someone's wedding night my top 500 friends i didn't care holy shit hey buddy i care oh my from getting trauma dumped
that's because they're top 500 oh
shit yeah i'm just a girl yeah also because they have no souls that's my final thing to say to them before uh i go get in the match oh my god i'm the only celestian match is over and i'm the only celestial player it's like over my parting words yeah before i leave they have no soul i'm not the type who fades quietly into the background yeah but if they're a top if there are celestial um dps or tank player it's over for me what all what can i do i just go until they're,
until they're like, you know, they're dead, I guess.
I can only heal so much, chat.
I can only do so much.
The game giveth and the game taketh away from me.
I'm batting torch.
I don't care.
I refuse to have any torch players in my game.
I don't care about the double bat.
Bum, bum, put it on them.
Oh,
we have no front line.
You'll need a top-notch team to win this one.
Okay, maybe...
Okay, guys, maybe they don't have any dives characters.
Maybe.
There could be a little hope where I'm not playing against any...
dive players just just a maybe there
is hope let's pray maybe I can survive longer than the moment I see any dive I'm out I'm swapping the rocket I we're doing animal crossing but those who don't know Jeff rat Jeff raccoon Jeff rocket is uh comp is called animal crossing because you're playing two animals that's literally what it's actually like a pro term it's fucking dumb i don't know why it's fucking stupid was good i swear if i see a spider-man i swear to god okay nice okay hello cap yeah they're on top don't talk about the cap on top
it's time for me to go animal crossing soon we're gonna go in cap flow cap flow cap flow that is not low fucking live set up for a dive i'm gonna set up follow the top jasmine
okay we're trying we're trying we're trying we're trying so hard we're trying oh my god i'm trying so hard to do the heals it's just me and my little shark buddy right here holy shit this guy is trying so this guy is open mic that's when you know he's actually in it this guy wants to hit celestio for the first time all right it's fine i'll use clap it might be a little stupid to use clap but like it's fine oh my god please bro bro i'll probably save her luna I'll save the lunar arsenal.
That's early invis?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, look for it, look for it.
Alright, here we go.
Here we go.
Follow that, follow that.
Follow it, look, follow it.
Yeah, I just watched the kill game, that was tough.
Just give him.
We just gave him a goddamn montage clip.
I I'm oh my god.
I'm so sad
This guy has got got a montage clip from us.
I didn't even consent to it.
That's the worst part I didn't even I need a mute.
I need a mute this Jeff though I need a mute this Jeff this guy I see him like tip-tapping It's literally just him tip-tapping it too.
Whoever is playing, uh, oh my god.
You're gonna have...
Go crazy, go crazy.
101, 101.
Nice, nice, nice.
Look out.
Please kill him.
She lives, she lives.
I'm dead here, I think.
Oh my god, the Star Lord's gonna all up.
The Star Lord's gonna all up.
Everyone cap, everyone cap, everyone cap.
I didn't see that.
Wait, where's the Star Lord?
oh the star there's god okay that's it wait i can't i can't he's like he's like playing uh he's like tap tapping away he's playing like project set guy or some on the side i swear to god his mic i swear to god his mic is like fucking attached to his keyboard that's all i hear do you want to agree too they're like football he was he is absolutely not giving me any good intel right now he's just playing tap tap i'm back lying three one one one oh one oh one oh one go crazy he's going crazy go crazy go stupid go crazy go stupid that was one in his image got you wait guys guys oh god oh god we got again guys Why did we okay guys?
Why did we all let them push the car?
Oh Everyone everyone Everyone this is a team effort now Sadly, we can stabilize.
We don't lose stabilize.
Yeah, really good.
I'm still gonna grab but I'm gonna go All right, here you go.
I'm staying away from my I swear.
Yeah, I'm gonna get the high ground a little bit All right, it's gonna break it but I got him.
I got him.
Oh I'mma slime.
OK.
I'm ready to push off.
I'm ready.
I dance.
I was like not alting in me.
Bye.
The bubble is like for me.
Bro, okay.
What is going on?
in my team.
Guys, what is going on here?
We need to have a talk!
I don't know how I'm alive.
I was barely alive.
The Starlight was actually waiting for us.
Like, the thing is, we have no defensive ult.
I mean, we don't have enough, actually, we have...
We don't have enough defensive ult, which is...
Oh my god, he was right here.
They're like an extended.
I'm just gonna switch up a little bit.
He's still up top.
That's the worst part.
Jesus, we're literally...
Oh, I got my best.
Please!
Whoa, we're getting staggered, everyone!
It's one guy!
Bro, why are you getting staggered?
Give me a second.
I'll be there.
All right.
Out of mirror.
Oh my god, I didn't put this on him.
Oh my, oh my god.
That was actually clutch right there
Oh, this sucks.
We just don't have enough support ult Literally, I can't do anything
We just need we literally just need like another support
I need backup lags back up someone said a portal someone said a portal I can be touched as venom yep I got touch I got a point I got a point I can't I can't live I can't live I can't live oh my god We all got- I'm not...
Jeff is not fine.
It's not fine.
Can we have another defensive up?
I'm Luna Snow.
Like the moon.
Or triple.
Alright, here we go.
There we go.
I'm not the type who fades quietly into the background.
Here we go.
This is fine now.
What the...
Okay, this is...
Oh, okay.
We'll do this.
Mantis, Cloak, and...
And Jeff.
Oh, my God.
No, I'm asking for the Jeff to swap off Jeff.
Because, like...
They have Star World.
They have...
Hello.
all they have emma all they have uh mag all and i'm like we have nothing to counter and i i have one defense uh that can save us and we also we only use jeff up twice we we only use jeff up twice oh my god we went from one iron man player to the next i i I hope the two Iron Man players are avoiding each other.
In my full build, let's see.
Yeah, yeah.
Dragon.
Oh my god, that wall was very tired.
Come back, buddy.
Come back.
Wait.
We are not really...
Okay, I have to swap.
Okay.
I should have to swap.
We're not getting enough healings.
I'll probably just like front lane more since we're at least taking like damage.
Walking?
Yep.
Wait, wait.
Alright.
I'm trying to like...
Bro, what?
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I'm good, I'm good, I'm good, I'm good.
Emma, Emma, Emma, Emma.
Alright.
Oh my god, what?
Please, I'm so close.
Okay, we'll do that first.
Follow, follow, follow.
Damage.
There you go.
I am not dying to him.
I am.
I don't care.
I don't fucking care.
We have crew.
You sorry, y'all have hello old.
You get a good eye.
It's fine.
We have another defensive!
I felt like he would have killed me though.
I definitely would have been so dead.
I know for a fact that I would have died.
Oh my god.
Yep, back on.
Oh my god, please.
Please use all.
Oh my god.
Can you use this so far?
I was gonna be a slightly bit longer.
I was gonna be slightly bit longer.
I'm on my nivies.
I'm trying to farm as much as I can.
You got a skirmish?
Okay, this is bad.
Okay, I got it.
Cite out, Cite out, Cite out.
Huge eye, he's eye!
I'm on nivies!
Look at him, look at him!
Okay, it's okay.
It's okay, it's not okay.
It's okay, but it's actually not okay.
It's fine, that's fine, that's fine, that's fine.
I'm part, I'm part.
I have all I have all No, he was looking at me Okay, we have TP wait, what?
What?
Where's our TP?
Oh my god
I swear why oh my god fuck this i'm just gonna we have to sell where the fuck was our tv oh my god i'm so
you cannot be for real you cannot what happened to our tv
i should have altered that but i was just so mad at that point that I was like okay we're gonna TP at least we fucking you know if we're gonna oh my god bro and we at least we commit to it you know
that's actually what a fuck this is like I told you this is a clown game this is a goddamn clown game I'm playing right now i swear this is a clown game like he walked he fucking walked all outside of this i'm crashing out i'm crashing i i did fuck up by ulting that but like at that point i was like oh my god and we're gonna do this we commit okay we're gonna commit
come over here i got It's fine.
I literally killed Luna.
I killed Luna
Bro, oh my god Everyone's a healer terrorist.
I'm I'm going in I was like I'm contributing to the terrorism too It's is I don't think we deserve and a win this team i sold by mantis ulting there but at that point i was so tilted i was like we're just committing you fucking did this we're committing i got up terrorized i'm fucking avoiding this guy holy that was the most fucking stupid thing he could have done holy shit
no it's fine no you saw him he fucking walked walk back I swear to God did they were like we don't need TP someone must have said that because like why did he do that why why why did he walk back and like walk forward then back I will say I did throw after I did fuck up by a mantis ulting through that but also because I was like well They can't they don't have much to push.
So why don't we just get an early fight in right now?
Just get it over with make them use ults Because there was no point at that point we have the TP.
I mean we could have re like they were just so close They were so close.
We might as well just force a fight It makes sense if like yeah, and you know we needed to commit it
It was just doomed
That TP was actually a game losing.
It really was.
I was not expecting that.
Yeah.
I wish I had lose 21.
It's fine.
I gained like...
Oh my god.
I was at one game.
I was in a GM match.
He's not secure.
He got scared.
He wasn't secure.
He sensed it.
I think he's secure, though.
3-3-5 in 24 hours.
Invite him now.
Bro, am I gonna ruin his games?
Do I have that enough spite in me to do that?
Hmm.
What kind of question?
Am I?
Is that?
Of course I do.
You'll be like, who are you?
I don't know what...
They added me.
Chat, they added me, by the way.
I can ask that.
Who are you?
They're the ones that added me!
I don't know who this guy is.
I'm just asking important questions.
No, I can't just be like, do you want to do...
It's not a carry.
We're going...
It's the opposite direction of carrying.
Bro, I don't even know this guy.
He added me.
Chat.
I could ask the Kendrick guy, who are you?
Technically, I sort of seen his name around.
But like...
Like, he's like a magic player or something.
And he also added me.
Which hero do you think you want to be today?
I'm not the type who fades quietly into the background.
Stop responding.
I know you're online.
I see you feeling.
Now, who am I going to banish from this match?
I know you're queuing.
I know you see my message, buddy.
I asked who you are.
Please respond.
Oh, do I still have the...
Oh, do I?
I didn't even realize I still have those tags on.
Let me fix that.
My staff added that when I had that sponsor.
Oh, my God, it does.
It says Ethereum RPG RTA ad.
Guys, there's no ads.
It's so cute.
It's not an ad.
I mean, technically the stream is an ad.
There we go.
I didn't even realize.
Just rap.
I'm no one special.
Just Apollo.
Oh.
Why did you add me?
Alright, here you go.
You guys want me to run an ad?
Watch me run an ad and lose 500.
Oh, you're good!
Whoa!
Yay!
Validation.
Let's hope he doesn't watch what happened last game.
I was heavily...
I was low-key throwing.
But I didn't throw first, chat.
I will say, I didn't throw first.
Rumor has it you're a pop star.
Any songs on my note?
Big chatter, yeah, I mean, I added someone in my chat to glaze me.
Oh, yeah, I should.
Nice.
I think he's just a regular guy.
I don't even think he knows who I am.
I think he's just a regular man.
Yeah, bro, we had a perfect comp.
Then you went Rafa at Raku.
I don't mind Rafa.
Team up's kind of nice.
Alright.
Alright, man.
Got the free headshot!
Let's go!
Oh, what?
Alright, let's go.
Oh, my star.
Oh, a few damage boosted is not fair.
Like, what is Mantis?
is this okay what i'm giving you damage what he said that and then i gave him damage boost what do you i gave him damage boost after oh my before he said that too that's crazy that's actually crazy and you all saw me give him damage boost too that's the wildest part
Oh my god, it's this guy!
Teleported.
The Bucky on the right.
You sure I'll just interrupt here?
I'm dead.
Okay.
That's actually crazy.
Okay, that's too many of us, though.
That's too many of us.
that's way too many odds
it has to be 24 7 or it doesn't count that's at oh i'm sorry oh sorry sir would you would you like some more damage boost oh i'm sorry oh i forgot to damage you to boost you for one second Would you like more?
Oh my god, I'm such a fool!
Oh, I'm sorry, I forgot another damage!
Oh, I'm goodbye, I'm dead.
I'm dead.
I'm stalling on point.
Goodbye.
I know.
What the fuck is my team did?
What do you mean, wise?
We got Eden!
Maybe Iron Man ult to shuffle.
Hello.
I Iron Man ulted.
Their whole squad.
Yeah, their whole squad got Eden.
What's the portal?
Oh, that's on you.
Oh, CC of Doom, bro.
Holy fuck.
You can handle Salta first.
All right, let's go.
Give me some give me some of that.
Okay.
All right.
Oh, this is oh my god.
Oh my god, I swear to him.
I'm running.
shoot the mag shoot the mag okay oh my god oh my god i feel like i knew he was gonna kill me oh my god that sleep actually helped that sleep was crazy he didn't get me couldn't get me i'm fast as boy oh they're teleporting check teleporter i have jeff for sure.
Oh my god, he didn't get us.
He didn't get us!
I tried so hard!
We have one fight left.
I knew he had JFL too.
All right, here I go.
Here I go.
I'm coming in.
It's so much harder to farm up to a Mantis win.
When there's like so many shields going in.
Here you go, sir.
Is that what you need?
Here's two more damage boosts.
Oh my god, here's more.
Oh my god, bro, I got bounced away.
I killed both, oh my god.
Go, Styler, go!
Styler, go!
Fucking carry us!
You know what, he deserves the damage boost.
What the fuck am I doing?
What the fuck?
wow i like ignored my starlord and my starlord with zero damage boost literally clutched that fight for us
this peter has an actual plan he actually knows what he's doing i'm not doing a lot of damage it's so hard to farm there the supports are also like to take off angles but I'm worried about my supports if I take off it um I'm gonna try and take more off angles here I'm sort of worried about my supports as I play PL more than dps because I am not farming damage I'm literally just being I'm nearly being like a fucking damage bot wait wait I'm gonna try to alt and bait something out actually no I'm holding for fucking search I'm like literally ult baiting.
I'm literally like, damage botting right now.
Alright, let's go.
Are y'all ready?
Oh my god, oh yes, boost.
We are undefeatable!
You already had damage boost!
Holy shit!
What do you...
You already had damage boost and he's like, Where's my damage boost?
Where is it?
What do you mean?
Oh my god.
Where's that rocket?
That's the thing.
Rocket dead.
Okay.
Oh my god.
I'm just stalling as long Oh, wait, he ults it.
Wait, when did we rocket ults it?
I didn't even realize.
He wants, he wants more.
Bro, I don't think he realized that damage boost only goes up twice.
The hell's on the right.
I don't think he really stacks up twice.
How do you want more?
I can't even give you more.
flow stronger feeling sharp oh no oh you are by yourself that is true
hey you want more i did good last round but i told you i told you about like this didn't i shit like what man i froze her hello on the right they're showing off stuff oh i thought we were going in the magic thing we couldn't yeah i know i just mistimed it And I just got shit on.
Oh my.
This is bad.
That's fine.
I used a lot.
Goodbye.
Oh, we're staggered as hell.
Oh my god.
It's all the supports too.
He's not in BC.
All right, here you go.
fucking damage booster the one that actually matters all right are we ready
oh goodbye okay i don't know we needed that but that's okay oh no okay it's okay
Jesus Christ.
What did I hit?
Jesus.
Okay, it's fine.
Starlord, you go.
You're next.
You're next, Starlord.
Oh, my gosh.
This is why I don't play Luna.
This is absolutely why I don't.
No!
Goodbye!
See, this is why I don't play Luna.
That would have been me.
Yes, but have you tried more damage boost?
I'm sorry, it was my bad.
I should have damage boost.
Why is the horse here?
Why is it?
Oh my god, this guy.
Is this why we haven't had a single friend?
quick oh my oh my god oh hey i did it i'm actually close enough i'm actually not nice i'm actually close enough now i'm like glitched out or stuff or something um i'm here with you guys you're freaks okay oh my god What the?
I'm playing like we have mag, bro.
TP.
Oh, that's my bad.
Oh, my God.
I can't see.
I'm back at spawn.
Jesus Christ.
Number one strange.
Oh, my God.
What's going on?
Oh, I was so confused.
What's happening?
portals there's too many portals around me you're one i was like i went to i think i accidentally went to the enemy portal too many cooks i actually went to the enemy portal and then i was like wait where am i because they showed up behind me like they they kidnapped me on the wrong side Oh my god.
I was like, whoa.
I guess I'm here now.
Thank god.
They didn't kill me.
Yurk.
Nice.
I got complimented, guys.
I love getting.
Alright, did he win?
You know what?
Oh, I can't spectate him.
He has it locked.
I want to know if he wins or not.
I'll be like...
Oh.
Oh, man, is that fucked up?
If we start losing and I get him out of top 500, how fucked up would that be?
This is a regular guy.
Because if it's a pro player, at least I can say, hey, at least you get paid professionally to play, right?
But this guy is a regular man who's literally playing this as a hobby and it's all he has.
Like, this is like his happy time after work.
So I'm like, I feel like that's more fucked up than getting a...
he's playing this after work like this is like his joy after a day at work
don't you're bringing him to an air layer of hell
no joy for him but there's joy for me
all right let's do it hey you want to do it you are just you're just a menace not that i'm not that bad of a person oh i'll get in here i'll check if he won or lost if he lost i'm like i could be the devil on the shoulder and be like oh i can maybe if you play with someone else you'll have more wins you know just maybe i'm not the type who fits quietly into the background do i have teammates with skulls and their brains in their skulls or am i afk off the rip i don't care at this point what now who am i gonna vanish from this match that's a great way to start the game the fucking clanker tired of clanker whoa i think this guy had a day of playing.
I don't think this guy had a good day of rink, guys.
Guys, I think his games have been pretty rough.
I'm pretty sure he has not had a good time.
I'm manning Adam.
I'm tired of fucking Solvon 2.
Bro, what do you like?
What do you like?
Wait, what about Tori?
If...
Oh, wait.
They banned...
Oh.
Like, I don't think you should, like, have much...
Have any standards if you're a penny one trick.
He's definitely crashing out.
Like, I'm like, how do you have standards?
You're a penny player.
You're...
Bro.
You should have the lowest...
They have garbantua.
Then why didn't you ban Jeff?
What?
Oh, by the way, they have a Jeff 1 trick.
Forgot to tell you about this.
Anyway, I'm banning Adam.
I ban Adam.
If they have a Jeff 1 trick, then why didn't you ban Jeff?
Alright, let's run this.
People...
Oh my gosh.
We let him control the bans.
Somehow he still fucked up the bans He's grieving he's grieving his own game and he's like do I have actual teammates in my team on my team?
I don't know.
Are you an actual teammate?
Like you are your own demise You're barely fit the definition of a teammate right now Clearly we win in this game Kai.
Oh, by the way, Kai The people on our team last game were a three stack of GM's yeah made sense afterwards What is what is going on?
He's actually going to shoot a penny nest if their life depended on it.
Oh my god.
I have Jeff.
Yeah, no shit they have Jeff.
We used it in fucking bad Jeff.
Come on, we have a thing.
Yep.
I want to play on that.
Phoenix is not in the top side.
Okay.
We're not.
all right we gotta give him jesus christ my tanks are so hungry they're so hungry for heals um yum yum yum yum okay why are they giving us so much free space these guys are fucking stupid
Oh, yeah.
A multiness?
Push up?
Smack, smack, smack.
Okay, that's fine.
Oh, where am I?
Where did I go?
How did I- You're the Beyblade.
You're the Beyblade.
How did I- Gosh, it's not binding, bro.
There we go.
Alright.
You gotta bind this here.
Abuse it for the last 24 hours.
Awesome, Mona.
Thank you for the raid.
Thank you.
I hope you have a good stream.
Oh no.
No, I was.
I actually was.
I literally clicked the button this time.
Uh, but hello everybody.
I am, um, I am Elo terrorizing right now.
I'm trying to keep top 500 from everyone.
Because if I can't keep top 500, no one can.
Oh, no, I'm not throwing.
I'm not throwing, by the way.
I've just been having very unlucky games, so I'm granting my...
I'm granting my negative aura to the rest of my team.
Focus cap.
I'm all up.
I'll keep them from running around.
Get that cap, Etono.
I missed grab.
It's fine.
Uh...
I'm...
Okay, it's fine.
We don't need all anything.
Holy shit!
Wait, this...
The enemy team is so passive.
They're so passive.
I'm holding W.
I want to eat them.
Om yum yum yum yum!
Eat these guys!
Om yum!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, there's...
There's a lot of people now Let's just play up here and die here They should be able to touch Bro, I don't even think you can die I don't they're doom cute Hello, hey Hey, you try to run away?
Oh no running away donkeys here I'm gonna take your illo Oh, you thought you could get top 500 in 24 hours?
Think again.
Nobody's getting top 500 in my lobbies.
I'm so far away from top 500.
I technically need a win.
Five, six games in a row.
And that's a fucking sad dream.
I almost have my own.
Yeah.
Let's just push up.
And let's prevent.
Oh
He didn't even get in Yeah Where's my goddamn combo?
I didn't put any stacks on them Where the fuck I was not to?
Where's my combo?
What the fuck was that all?
That was a fucking fast asshole.
Yeah, that was a fast ass that push Wasn't your fault bro that portal was like low-key questionable I'm your brother you saw the support it was right there if we were on triple support and had a casual DPS we would have killed them this guy's coping how long I'm gonna check how long he's been playing for a specific comp it has to be cloak Adam 2 DPS bar none the strat works if you do that if you do anything other than that it fails 90% of the time if you do exactly that it works 90% of the time I got checkers he has to be on the 16th hour mark right This guy looks like he's been through it.
Like, you know, like, penny mines are there.
They'll be coming.
Yes, that's what the soul bond is for.
We live through that.
There's not enough mines to kill us.
But we didn't look.
We didn't die to the penny mines.
We died because we didn't have enough damage.
We died at, like, five, like...
He is not okay.
Kill them or kill us.
He is not having a good day, guys.
Look, he's been...
I bet you he was, like, maybe, like, one game off of top 500.
Securement?
You know, sometimes the best defense is a good offense.
And then he lost seven games in a row.
Just like me.
Oh my god!
Guys, I don't think there was a way for me to save anyone.
They're pushing top.
Oh my god, there is a pushing top.
Oh my god.
Okay, don't worry.
We can...
Oh, we only did that three minutes?
No, that's not fast at all.
Don't give up so easy.
All right, we've fucked up a little bit guys just a little
All right, I should have just dropped down I got scared I was like oh my god, what if I just what maybe he won't run after me, you know
Okay, all right, let's go all right nice.
Hello, man.
Don't worry.
I'm here I'm here, Mag.
Oh my god.
Please.
Okay, there you go.
I felt like I was living by one HP right there.
This is so scary.
I don't know if you can hear me just clicking my mouse spamming it right now.
I'm just like, oh my god, please don't let me die.
Please don't let me die, please.
I'm so scared.
Oh.
Goodbye, everyone.
Goodbye.
Goodbye, everybody.
Oh, it's me.
God damn it, it was me!
Why is it always me?
Oh, no, we that used to end this.
No, she got swallowed.
I have to go all the way up.
I got swallowed.
It's different.
I think we make four.
I'll be down.
Oh, my God.
We don't.
All right.
That wasn't me.
I got eaten.
That's just bad luck.
What did I?
I didn't do anything wrong.
I was eaten.
Someone had to get eaten.
It was me or Luna.
That's why I couldn't go in.
invisible too because I I like debated I should have just let my Phoenix die he was gonna die regardless I was like oh I could let's move up cake space I could like um um stay invisible and not get eaten but that was like no I should I should try and save I'm all in three two one I was too good of a person.
They did.
They thought that so early.
Yeah, they did.
Wait.
Ah, so sorry.
Kill this guy.
Okay.
That's fine.
I had to push, pull them back though.
We have to kill something.
Come on.
Kill some guys.
Kill something.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Nobody.
Don't shot it.
Yes.
Nice.
No.
I caught it.
No, the Jeff!
Oh no, they're pushing just as fast as us.
Do you need to go like triple support?
They're pushing it just as fast!
This is bad guys.
This is bad.
We gotta take an early fight.
I could go C&D and just play like a Wanda when I'm not healing.
No, I think I'm just gonna play Poke on their back.
all right this is bad
i'm trying to make sure i'm like fucking making sure my team is okay but i don't think they're okay that's the thing
that's the scary part i don't know if they're okay they're not okay i don't know i'll go triple
dude i i cannot play the game like there's like buggy then molem i don't care yes he's not okay guys please help her help her help her help her oh no i knew it i made phoenix
knew it oh
my god he was right behind me such a joke i didn't realize he was right behind me i don't give up so easily why are we not running triple i don't know i actually get off i don't get my off i mean bro we're getting picked bro our dps are getting picked every Just play with the fucking team.
We don't need to off angle.
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god.
We need to contest it though.
And we don't contest it.
And then they just get free picks.
It's all falling apart.
I thought we were a team.
What happened?
Because everything's falling apart.
We were so...
There's going to be a button on your monitor.
We were so happy.
I'm going to need you to click that and turn your fucking screen on.
Jesus Christ.
We were so happy.
What happened?
Like do we want to go goats and just fucking triple support triple tank fucking stall it out Everybody was so happy What happened?
All right, hi, please stop getting fucking picked with love a fucking guy I'll play with my hold up put the fucking snowflake on him.
He needs to He doesn't need it bro.
He clicks a button and he gets 50 shields, bro What are they doing?
He's been dying.
I think she needs it.
Whoa!
The battle starts in five.
Guys, what happened to us?
We were doing so well.
Why didn't the NAP just give up?
The Guardians of the Galaxy are misfits.
It pleases me to be helpful.
Compromised.
Yeah.
There you go.
I'll just pocket him.
We'll just...
There you go.
Okay, I can't.
Oh my god, I can't.
Oh my god, I try to drop down.
Oh, I'm dropping down.
That's unlucky.
Fantastic, absolute.
I should have dropped down straight away.
But I was like, I would eagled it too much.
That was fun, though.
Playing with my hella.
And I used myself as bait.
I either die or run.
Die or run.
It's TP.
Oh, no, that's the whole point.
If we lose this point, even with TP, then we're fucked.
We need to just regroup.
That's what we need.
Oh, he's TP.
Okay.
TP!
I'm gonna go TP, I guess.
Okay.
Oh.
What?
Um, I don't know.
That's just my luck.
Oh my god.
And that is why we don't TP.
What's going on?
We had time to walk.
We GG's now because it's a fucking hour to walk back.
Like I said, we wasted TP.
What's going on?
We had time to walk.
We did not need to do that.
What's going on?
And now we're playing Rocket into fucking Phoenix.
Even more GG's.
This fucking lock...
Oh my god, I can't...
oh yeah talking talking here am i and maybe we win this here you don't need to talk
okay oh my god he was so low too
all right that's fine
focus your job please
there's a bad tp just come on all right we're did it oh jesus christ my team's so sad i say do not tp next time do not fucking tp it says the team's so sad especially if you're not a tank man and you don't understand the concept no my team stop fighting stop fighting
guy is also mad too he sounds okay if he's okay wait i can i know marvel tracker let's see if he is if he has hidden his name if he's private in his profile or not okay crimson crimson ix oh it's hidden level 100 wow damn Damn.
Guys, we can't check, guys.
He has hidden his profile.
This guy has not been happy for a long time.
It's okay, buddy.
Just be like me.
Stream it all out.
Wait, he's doing with Kai.
So, like, maybe his profile is public.
Four, three, two, one.
The only issue is that I'm not building my ult fast enough.
Okay.
All right.
Oh, I can't do anything.
Oh no!
I can't do anything about it.
Let's hope that Hella wins this fight.
Hella, you got this Hella!
You got this!
I'm coming back!
to help you oh he don't you don't need my help what the fuck you're so fine
i feel like we should have double tank there we go i'm just pocketing this hell up
oh my god oh there we go
i'm not getting all charged though by doing this pocket
you got nothing
I think he's dead.
Oh, you said...
No.
Oh my god.
it's fine i had no leaves okay boom boom boom oh my god they teleported oh my god no there we go i'm here i didn't think there'd be a tp
He ain't so much.
Oh, it's me.
It's just me.
That's fine.
I guess they're in probably close to all You ready here.
No heals.
They have no heals.
Please don't Please please please hello, please.
I'm trying to help you
Okay, there you go.
Oh my god.
There we go Yeah,
I'm keeping three on cards so we can move this Jesus I just got here Yeah, cloak alt, please do not die too mad.
Yeah, yeah, and heal again.
Yeah, just don't do it.
Like, just do it into a fucking cave or- I don't think there's no way he has all again.
He swapped the shield.
Okay.
I'm just mad at him.
CND rip that shit.
I got all.
CND rip it.
Just kill him.
Kill- kill- kill- fantastic on point.
Kill fantastic on point.
We won again.
Nice.
Rookie on top Shoot shoot it shoot it shoot it shoot it shoot it.
Okay kill his bitch Oh my god, what the fuck is this game?
I wanna die too.
What is this game?
Bro all I did was just follow I bro These guys don't know that our biggest carry was literally the hella a Sorry for being mad.
These guys, all they had to do was literally pocket Arhella.
Arhella did everything.
Like, I was literally following him around for the longest time.
He actually did everything.
And these two fuckers were just gapping away.
I'm just like, hello, hello.
Would you like some water?
I'm just like, it's as little as a system.
Like, ego, hello, do you want this damage boost?
There you go, sir.
Are you happy?
Are you...
Are you hungry, sir?
Let me grab a napkin for you.
No, it got and committed.
Fucking, the rest of my team were just fucking fighting away.
I'm like, hello, are you hungry?
Here's some cookies.
Bro, I don't think... Oh, oh.
Oh, he won.
Wait, he won.
Wait, why did he...
Hide his history!
Why did he...
What did he want?
Why did you hide?
What are you hiding?
Did he know I was stalking his profile?
Why is he hiding?
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Oh, yeah.
No, things were not okay for it.
Oh, now.
Oh.
Now.
I understand.
There it is.
Oh, bro.
Bro, this guy was Celestia 1, bro.
Why did you keep playing?
Oh, that is a reasonable crashout.
No, that's reasonable.
This guy was Celestia.
Why did you keep playing?
You locked it.
You actually secured it.
What's wrong with you?
You had it in the bag.
No, this guy was the one that says, sorry, he's in his profile.
This guy.
He, um, I don't know why he fucking kept going.
He is, he should have, he was Celestia 1.
He fucked up.
I was not secure.
I kept going because I wasn't secure, though.
That's the thing.
What if...
Wait, okay, where is this guy?
Oh, he...
Wait, is he a peer offline?
Or was he like, this is it?
I'm done.
I'm fucking done.
Oh, no, he's a peer offline.
Oh, he's crashing, crashing out.
He went from Celestial 1 to Celestial.
That's understandable.
That's...
Where is the other guy?
This guy.
This guy is...
Oh.
Alright.
He's secure.
He wasn't.
He's not gonna keep going.
I mean, that's a lot of points.
I'm gonna go pee real quick.
I'll be right back.
Don't worry.
I got you guys.
While I use the bathroom.
Alright, I'm back.
I had to grab some water too.
Let me take some.
Let me hydrate real fast, guys.
Bump, bump, bump, bump, bump.
BAM BAM BAM BAM
BADAM BADAM Wait Fates back
Wait do I do it?
He's a pro player he won he won MRC he does not he won MRI he doesn't need top 500
Yeah Guys, he does a Nita 500.
That's all I'm going to say.
He literally won.
Oh, wait.
Never mind.
He's playing with someone.
JK, I can't.
There we go.
Never mind.
He's already duode.
that's okay we don't we don't they have been saved they've been saved i'm just saying yeah i'm just saying he already won m ignite he doesn't need top 500 this season like why would he need it when he already has everything he wants
lot of people's lives in game in game guys in game that's the goal for life i said in game
i hope i ruined their day winning or losing i hope i mean i definitely ruined crimson's day Just by existing on his team.
Like, my...
Oh, hey.
I heard you one.
Oh, wait.
Hey, hello.
Don't worry.
Here's two mantis dances.
I'm here to go!
Oh, shit!
No kuning allowed.
Please don't clip.
Please don't clip out of context, chat.
The content...
There is context behind it.
I meant, I hope today, a lot of people do not get top 500 today.
I want them to all suffer my grief.
I want them to all be sad with me.
Oh, is it because you won your own prize?
Whoa!
I didn't do nothing.
Oh, shit.
Hey, guys.
Hey.
Whoa.
Oh, wait.
Is this a knee couple?
Dude, I'm a...
Hey there.
Yeah, I know you're married and everything.
Oh, wait.
Your wife's gone.
Where did your wife go?
Oh, wait.
Your wife is right here.
She's like, Get away from me!
I'm a married man!
Get...
Get away from me!
He's like, Get away from me!
Jesus.
He's loyal.
He is loyal.
Look at him, he's like, Hey, leave me alone!
I have a wife!
Come on, get over here.
Be gone, tempt us!
To the island.
They're the ones chasing me.
It's not what it looks like.
Be gone, thought.
You have to admire his loyalty.
Alright, where is he?
Where did he go?
He actually just disappeared.
wait he's gone oh my god a couple of stays to get it for another day just to get away yeah you got chased by me and Luna like come on are you serious bro their team looks so stacked who the fuck is on my team like I have low tier God.
I'm against fate, Gail, and Shab.
Now, who am I going to banish this match?
You don't worry.
You got Raw Lovers 69.
Everything is going to change.
Yeah, you're cooked in this game.
They have Gail, Shab, and...
I don't know who Shab is.
but like he had a top 500 badge so clearly he's a decent player but and fate and i have low tier guide and raw lover 69.
you wanna please do not jeff it's horrid it's tachala chala's all right any like dodgers in chat pick your hero or villain I'm not judging
Bro, they banned Jeff They banned They banned Ultron I don't like Jeff Play Adam
Bro Bro
We haven't even...
Oh, yippee!
Yippee!
Oh, he's gonna be back!
No!
Okay, I'll let you show me.
Your situation is unproductive.
Oh...
Just shut up and play Star Lord.
Jesus Christ.
Oh.
If it doesn't work, I'll swap.
Just play your main fucking character.
No, shut your dumbass up, you one-trick fuck.
Play your one-trick.
Oh.
Please don't come back.
Why would you say that?
I don't want you on my team.
Why would you say?
I don't... Why?
Oh, my god.
I'm sad.
I'm so sad.
Please don't come back.
back please don't come back I beg of you please they give it and they take it away I'm I'm just looking hoping that I live in a world where he never comes back that's your name where he starts oh what avoid me I've been winning all day what's your name I can't none of your business your buddy was coming back.
Oh, I'm going to try to lose another 20, you know, though.
Oh, he's actually dodging.
Wait, that's the reportable.
If you admit it.
Oh, he doesn't.
Yay!
He doesn't know!
But we don't know his name.
That's the worst part.
What did we do?
It was, like, Vortex, right?
Why did he admit that?
Why did he kind of fork it?
That's his name, right?
No, I don't...
Guys, I can't spell it.
Hold on, a Vortik Kek.
Vort...
Vortik Kek.
Okay.
Bro.
Alright, who is he playing with?
Okay, bro, he got loads here.
Vortik Kek.
Oh, is it Crafty?
Oh, it was Crafty.
This guy was dodging.
Wait, is it an alt account?
K-A-R-A-F-T-T-Y.
what?
K-R-A-F-F-T-T-Y.
Wait, did I spell it?
T-T-Y-Y-Y?
Oh, bro, this man is... God on an off- alt account.
It's fucking... Oh, that guy was actually like on an alt account to help his buddy.
Yeah.
It's level 37.
There's no way.
it's level 37 this guy was actually dodging for his hope honestly for his homie no not win trading basically um if it's an unwinnable game so it was it's basically the overwatch um um it's the overwatch strat that was the issue um people did this all the time in overwatch and that's the problem and that's the problem in current marvel rivals if you do with someone who is on an alt account or like who's on an account that they don't care about they would just leave the game the their part the duo partner will just leave the game and the match will cancel and then nobody loses anything and uh everyone would use to do that in overwatch and back then in overwatch there was a thing where you can just disconnect and reconnect so fast that you yourself don't even lose anything um but they patch that so people will just do the alt account thing where they'll just do it with an alt account but then if the match is unwinnable they just leave in the first minute that you don't lose anything like
the match just cancels and people just do that uh in in rank so it's like a unwinnable game to get top 500 in overwatch and i think in marvel rivals too um don't do that i'm not endorsing that i'm not i guess me giving you guys this tactic is not endorsing it i'm just sharing the not don't do that because you heard it from me if you do it Don't say you heard it from me.
Say you heard it from like, uh, what's his name?
Vortikek.
Oh, if anyone asks, you heard it from this guy.
This guy taught you about the dodge.
This guy, this guy told you about the dodge strat.
Not me.
If anyone asks, it's him.
yeah vortikek made me do it not toky i'm just i'm just being informed i'm just being informative i'm sharing the knowledge at least like please dodge me i've been winning all day i swear to you don't want to risk it again and see if how do you should i risk it again and see if i get all they got in game i was gonna say do i risk it again and see if i play against that team like are the odds in my favor today i feel like they're not i i don't know all right let's queue up
yippee a one above all there i used to be one above all yeah that's my highest This is so sad.
It's almost 200 hours.
It's so sad.
I used to be...
And like, current top 500 is cut off is Celestial 2.
I'm Celestial 3 right now.
And I'll forever be in Celestial 3, I think.
I love...
We ain't leaving Celestial 3.
Unless I do rank the GM.
Unless I...
It could happen.
The knight is still young.
It's still there.
Still a possibility.
The night is still young.
I can still fuck up my life a little bit more.
Let's see.
Let's go back to road feeling.
Do I have the Spider-Man dance?
I think I do.
It's up to us to help the people who can't help themselves.
Yay!
Hello.
Where are the ladies?
where are the women I'm here to hang out with my fellow women oh my god hey women hi oh I forgot to god damn it
okay I need to get guys I need to get in the perfect angle right here oh shit no no my perfect Oh, wait.
Maybe, like, oh, this is better.
This is better, actually.
Oh, shit.
They know I'm watching.
I'm sorry.
Creep.
Peter, creepy woman.
I'm just a journalist.
I'm fucking right.
I'm just a journalist, guys.
I'm a photographer and a journalist.
I'm reporting the news right now.
Not a freak.
I'm just doing my journalistic integrity.
Where did it go?
Where did the women go?
Women!
Oh, my spotty sense.
This is the second time I've ever played Spider-Man, by the way.
I'm like, whoa, what are these?
Oh, yeah.
There are the bros.
Hello, fellow bros.
Whoa!
See, that's how you greet your fellow bros.
Your fellow homies.
oh my god they're all beating him up oh my god whoa what did mag do to you that's also look at this skin
I thought the skin was like when I first saw this skin I was like that skin's not too bad and then and then like you look in the back and you're like oh whoa
Akavina thank you for the tier one sub thank you thank you why is there why do they get all celestials and you got frosty the snowman
there's a mod I thought my aren't mods like technically bannable though who am I gonna vanish from this match oh my god
okay so I just got an update for a project and it's
I'll just say I have something special planned for Halloween something very special I just got an update for it it's a very special Halloween Halloween thing I have planned
You're never gonna expect it.
I'm cooking.
As long as I get to play Invis.
Adding 90% of our team.
Oh, that's the enemy team.
Thank God.
Ah, I guess I'll play Luna.
It's good.
You guys would love it.
You guys are gonna love it.
Our DPS is Hawkeye and then Moon Knight.
I have very high hopes.
We had five Jeffs and a Phoenix.
Four Jeffs.
What the fuck are they talking about?
Are they talking about the band phase?
Who do I...
I guess I'll do Moon Knight.
I'm like, who do I even snowflake?
This is a stupid fucking English snowflake.
I need to use my seed more.
Yay!
Yippee!
Five, four, three, two, one!
Let's go.
All you need to do is capture the mission area.
Got it?
It's winnable.
Where are they?
Oh, there they are.
I was like, how can I make it winnable if I don't even see them?
How the fuck did he take so much?
How the fuck did he take so much damage?
Like, do you have to put this on our Emma?
Oh, I missed the freeze.
That's my bad.
I haven't played Emma.
Oh.
Guys, I'm a little concerned here.
Guys, I don't think it's winnable anymore.
I don't think it's winnable anymore.
I- Hey, guys.
Guys, I-
Guys, I- I don't think it's winnable anymore, guys.
This- This, that team...
Bro, we just used Every U-tail possible for this guy.
Alright, it's fine.
Oh, okay, that's bad.
Oh my god, that sucks.
It's fine, it's fine.
It's fine.
It's okay.
I actually double support up
I messed up that I didn't I tabbed and I didn't see our mantis have a I didn't see it and then um and he built it so fast I pressed tabbed and he was like 70 I didn't know it was my bad I fucked that up now are all you you kind of I mean, it's pretty fucked right now.
I made sure, too.
I was gonna be like, I gotta check.
Oh my god.
What the?
What the fuck?
Oh, our guy died so fast.
I wish I didn't do that.
This thing is like, oh, I have up before a Mantis.
I guess I'll up first.
But yeah, they built it so fucking fast, it threw me off.
That's okay.
I will redeem myself in this game.
It's okay, we'll fight, we'll be five.
Look, I just made one mistake.
It's just one mistake, guys, it's five.
I meant to kill you, only made the fucking weapon.
It's okay, we don't have anything else anyway.
why is he not okay i mean i'll take it i'll take it i'll take that point that is why did they not drop down did you just saw that oh it's because they're getting it to 99 and then reset oh that's smart actually that's actually smart wow oh they're running triple support now too for the item risk their ult's out right there
going oh okay goodbye goodbye
oh wait that hits me stay on point stay on point i'm dying on point okay we're resting resting don't move that don't move Okay, I'm still alive.
I'm still alive.
Porn again.
Oh my god.
Are you serious?
I am ready to put on a show.
i died on point i actually died oh my god he has all straight up out 23 straight above top one straight up by one three one three three three okay okay okay that is man i broke your bro okay that is scary he's gonna touch his boy my boy my boy my buddy touch oh my god that was scary that was so scary i had to like focus that that team up saved my life that team up actually saved my fucking life holy shit all i ever wanted to do was sing really So that Adam Rose was so fucked up.
I saw what you did.
We did.
They didn't see.
But I saw what you did.
I know you fucked up.
They don't know that.
But I saw what you did.
I.
You made me look bad.
Because they were like.
Where's the Luna up.
But you fuck it.
You fucked me over.
You.
I know your little secret.
You fuck it.
He made me look bad in front of everyone.
But I know he fucked up, but I can't prove it.
I know what, oh my god, why are we on Loki?
No, my C was doing so much.
My C was actually doing so much too.
It's crazy that we're running Loki in 2025.
But we ain't fucking killing that guy.
Oh, we're not even going.
Oh, big.
Keep her up, keep her up.
Oh, we're trying.
What do we keep her up?
What else can we do?
All right.
Let's just play.
Oh, no.
Okay.
I'm not.
I mean, they can't- it's winnable!
I'm making a comeback!
I mean, 3v5!
Alright?
On your toes, here they come!
This is real!
Oh, I can't do anything.
I wish I had my C.
I wish I had my C right now.
Can you just rock it at least?
Okay, I'm getting this.
You can go first.
Okay, me first.
Alright.
That's unlucky.
If I had my, I couldn't build all because we went low key.
So it's even harder to build all now.
That's the worst part.
I don't care.
I don't care about him, Rose.
He's waiting.
Come on, ma, ma, ma, ma.
I am ready to put on a shield.
Okay, we gotta save our Emma.
Oh my god, are you...
I can't do anything.
They damage boosted it.
They just did that damage boost strat.
I need the fucking...
I need the C.
Their team's capture progress has passed the halfway point.
I feel like I should just give it to this guy.
Our Emma?
Our Emma is...
He's tanking so much right now.
Oh, nice.
He said she belongs to me.
Oh, he wants to raise.
Born again!
I'm gonna mantis first, okay?
Oh my god, oh my god, goodbye.
Goodbye, everybody.
Goodbye.
They're both rocking and breaking.
Break it.
I'm trying my best.
I'm trying.
They shielded.
I couldn't break it.
You told me.
You said to break it.
I looked back.
I looked back to break it.
Why did...
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
Oh my god, thank you.
Oh, they're poorly?
Oh, poorly.
We're too ping, we're too ping, come back.
Oh my god.
I can't do anything.
The Star Lord saw me.
This sucks.
I didn't think he saw me.
That's so unlucky.
Yeah, the rocket is getting so much value.
The Star Lord saw me.
One of them dies.
You just get resed and then they have Adam res and then...
Yep.
No, no, it's cancer.
That's unlucky.
That's so unlucky.
I'm tempted.
to just go right i'm gonna go i'm gonna go i'm gonna go through here and then oh wait then we'll have a lot of let's just go you know what you're not talking let's just go what honey what humans yeah plenty i mean get on the mag all right let's do it i mean i can just pre-swap mag yeah i'm going yeah yeah yeah yeah
i go at him let's do this fuck it this will work this will work guys trust me trust me this will work believe believe they have solar to think i don't have this will work just believe in if it
If it doesn't my bad.
Okay, my bad
Okay, we have rocket next touch point touch point touch point don't let them have the free Oh, they're shooting at it.
Oh Nice Like how why did we use everything what okay it's okay it's okay it's okay it's okay it's okay it's okay it's okay it's okay it's not okay anymore it's not okay it's not okay it's not okay oh my god how my homie out wait why did you leave my boy it's not like me i can't put it there they're just gonna destroy it there it's no longer okay guys but this guy is like active he's like actively looking for my nice all right all right it's fine okay
things are fine for now it's okay it's okay but why can our adam do that like you know what why is this adam allowed to just walk whenever he wants i don't understand it's not fair like my adam i literally saw my adam get follow to the ends of the earth and it's not fair jesus christ
okay it's okay it's still okay they're just gonna warn again i swear to god i i feel it i was like i swear to Oh my god, Mac.
Oh, no, Mac.
You're too far from my wrist, Mac.
Why can't my item do that?
Oh my god, I'm gonna let Arloon that build all that, actually.
I'm gonna let...
It's fine.
It's no longer fine.
I'm so scared.
It's okay.
It's fine.
again it's still fine it's still okay and then she'll be like friends oh they see
guys see see I told you guys I told you I knew this was the play okay this guy was actually fucking insane on Mantis.
I'll pot up.
I told you guys.
Ha!
A non-lord raccoon won against... Oh my god.
Plus 17.
It's like I might as well just not even play the game.
Like, might as well just not even play it.
Barely barely anything.
Only 17 while I was fighting for my life.
But that's okay.
Who cares?
Who cares about what I wouldn't like, you know, who cares about that?
Alright, yay, at least, and I swear, I bet you, if I lost that game, it would have been, like, minus 25 or some shit.
I could feel it in my bones.
Alright, I'm thinking, like, how much do I want to stream today?
Hmm.
I love energy at the more.
I do need to sleep before my sponsor tomorrow.
Oh yeah, I forgot to provide my new emotes that I have.
Hello.
Whoa.
That's not it.
Hello, everybody.
I'm coming over, guys.
I'm so sad.
I never got the Emma money.
Did I get the...
Yeah, I never got the Emma.
The Emma money emote.
I've lost potential content.
Hello, women.
I am also a fellow woman.
Hello.
Do you guys have to dance?
Come on.
I got the money.
Oh.
Yes.
Oh my god.
There we go.
Get away, fellow women.
That's right.
Make it rain.
Make it rain for my...
Oh my god.
She knows what she wants.
Oh, shit!
Panther was like, no.
You didn't pay for the extra service.
I love role-playing and rap.
The moment they add custom lobbies, like the custom customization for lobbies, it's over.
No gooning allowed.
Not in my Christian server.
no women allowed he's the horny police he really is yeah get out of here you don't need you to police us we know what we women want come on oh mantis come on I know you got it come on mantis yeah that she saw the money she gotta pay for a college tuition She's a self-made woman.
Oh, shit.
It became a I bet you have custom lobbies or a thing.
That would be the first thing that's programmed.
Get over here.
I'm coming after you.
You can't hop from us.
Wait, where did she go?
Wait, she hit from us.
Wait, she got a way.
way she actually got away how did she do it she got jealous yeah the Christian mods found us oh there she is whoa whoa I saw a picture of that once we need up it's because I feel like I feel like Marvel would not actually I don't know Marvel has let a lot of stuff happen in this game.
Celestial 1.
Oh shit, they have the really good Mantis player.
Like, gee, that Mantis player was scary.
I don't think I can fucking do the scene.
Oh, I don't know.
Look to your God, he's back.
They have a torch and a Phoenix player.
All right.
Torch time.
Bro, everybody's duode.
Everyone I know is duode right now.
It's not fair.
Why do they have friends?
It's not...
I don't like it.
You know, when you're that person, you're like, the last choice.
I hate it.
I hate these people.
You know, like, when you're in the friend group and you're, like, the last choice, last like you're like plan c or plan d but it's okay i'm i have you guys i don't need them i have you guys no rixies rixies at work right now i know it's crazy that people don't just like have lives outside of rivals pick your hero i know what a wild concept friends
i'm a little scared because like the scarlet guy was really good at building
building mantis all you build mantis all so fast i'm a little afraid
all right here we go at least i have um who do i oh yes just in case I'm gonna have to put on the Groot, though.
Because Groot is a fuck.
Groot in general is a fucking feeder of a tank.
He's always so hungry for heals.
He's like, like, you give him a little bit of food, and he's like, that's it.
We're second dessert.
Oh, they have Penny?
How the fuck do they have Penny?
Oh, that's a bug.
That's a...
Oh, he's doing...
Oh, my God.
That's so cheeky.
He's doing the exploit.
Nerd, you fucking nerd.
He was trying to do the goddamn Pennyman exploit.
And he failed.
That's how much he they wanted their healing.
Where?
Like, oh my god.
I'm scared so.
I had to use clap because I was afraid for my fucking lie.
Jesus, that's so much That's so much damage That is so much damage Holy shit What the fuck?
Okay, we need a star lord That was too much damage He might need to go strange into the group Yeah, because he just built that old so fast Oh my god Guys, remember when our gauntlet i remember when i got wait we're not gonna kill that wall that's all right we don't need that wall jesus you know what counters a moon knight literally it's we all we need how is he still alive
oh my god then we're gonna get eaten aren't we goodbye oh he bubbled himself i what you did.
I see you buffle yourself, you fucker, you low tiered guy.
I saw... I know what you did.
I know what you did.
I...
No, Moon Knight is very easily counterable if we literally have one thing and it's Starlord.
Like, that's all we need.
We just need Starlord.
Fuckers.
They don't die.
They just don't die.
That's so true.
They really don't.
They don't die.
Like, that's crazy.
It's like triple support is actual help.
Like, how many...
Oh my god.
How many hooks do we need to do?
Guys, this might be it.
Guys, I- oh my god.
Again!
Hey guys, what about this one guy?
There you go.
Let us break this.
Hey guys, I can't wait to get Moon Knight out of it.
Again!
Who has my snowflake?
Okay, Bucky.
It's okay guys.
We got the point.
I can't wait to get Moon Knight ulted.
Or like...
We just can't be grouped up to get there.
I think that's really it.
Oh, I thought that was...
And also that it doesn't help.
Oh my god, he's so dead.
He's so dead.
He's...
Oh my...
It's 5 for 5.
I think the Adam ulted...
The Adam hook is also building ult so fast for him.
Nice.
please I really need all right now I really I'm so desperate I'm so hungry right now please please we I'm at 82 I'm so very hungry give me a please I'm so hungry 87 92 we're almost there I'm so hungry I'm so hungry we're so dead oh we have oh we don't have link wait you have link now okay he had link now that's so sad get ready to defend he had link now oh no good luck oh we goodbye all right It's time.
No, that's just a...
That's just a strat.
It's a strat for...
Man.
It just sucks because I went out first.
So I have to run back.
I ran...
I was running back to the...
To the point.
And then I got Eden.
I knew he was going to do it too.
But I didn't think...
I didn't think that...
He was gonna do it that soon.
I didn't think he was that close to us.
Alright, I'm just gonna give shield, and then I'll swap off to Luna.
Samurai, thank you for the hundred biddies.
Thank you, thank you.
Keep booking.
They go to tier one, so they can thank you.
I'm gonna give shields for everybody before I go.
or you come the battle starts in five four three two one all right you know if our um if our cloak went in this I think it'd be easier too because um she can build out so fucking fast I'm not even gonna fucking get close to people I don't trust my team a nice deep freeze the life force wants to kill you Oh my god,
yeah, I mispositioned myself too.
You hear these guys?
Oh my god.
I think he sees me?
Okay.
Ow, okay, I'm gonna stay out.
That's okay.
Again!
again okay this is fine this is fine is he still playing moon night yes he is I mean to be fair he was doing fucking absolutely crazy oh my god oh my god oh my god I was playing with fire I needed the extra heals okay the extra ultra I'm like I'm so close
Okay.
He definitely had Jeff eat.
There it is.
Oh.
Oh my god.
I thought he was gonna eat us.
That was my bad.
I fucked that up.
I legitimately thought he was gonna eat us there.
So I was like, why should I live?
He's just gonna go, I'm yum yum.
Like, if he just eats my entire team, there was no point.
But he didn't.
Like, I...
He was playing mine games with me.
He actually was playing fucking...
Oh my god.
Okay, it's fine.
We live.
We live there.
What?
Our fucking cloak altered?
I didn't even notice.
Oh my god.
Everyone thinks going wrong in this game.
Everything that could go wrong is going wrong in this game.
Goodbye.
No, the Jeff ate someone else.
He didn't eat the...
Oh my god, everything is going wrong.
We're double support all thing.
We're...
Everything that could go wrong is going wrong, guys.
I don't know what to do.
This team and me is so uncoordinated.
We're so uncoordinated.
I don't know.
We just...
Goodbye.
This team...
I think this team gave up.
They just have too many combos.
Okay,
here we go.
I'm ready to put on a show.
Here I go.
Oh.
Why didn't we ban Jeff?
Why didn't we...
It was cooked.
I truly am the gatekeeper of top 500.
Yeah, I truly am.
No, it was cooked from the beginning.
The thing is, I was trying to play...
I have to play mine games.
I have to play mind games with their fucking group combo.
That's the thing.
Like, because if I use Luna ult, I have to worry about...
I have to worry about the Jeff Eat that can eat my entire team and then make my ult useless.
Or the Moon Knight ult, if we're in the group ult, which also makes my ult useless.
didn't do either of that when we got Groot Ulton.
So my team died because I'm like, I'm like, what?
Because they did the combo every other time.
You guys saw that, right?
They did the E combo.
They did the, they did the Moonlight combo.
And then the one time I was like, I might as well just dive my L because you're going to do the combo.
They didn't do the combo.
They actually, They're fucking playing with my mind.
They're playing with me.
I was like, my adventure is gonna die anyway.
Are they a cloak player?
Oh, yeah, they are.
All right, I'm sorry.
I cannot have a cloak player on my team.
I'm sorry.
I'm gonna avoid low tier God.
I think this is a side.
He wasn't.
I think that's a side.
I have to avoid low tier God.
and because i knew that i know if i use it and then i get all combo they're gonna yell at me and but they're gonna yell at me regardless if i don't use up i don't win i never win and that's why we're here today that's why i'm streaming right now because i know i fucking know i like i'm honest i don't my sponsor stream is at 3 p.m tomorrow for the oh it was really nice band i reached out to me to because i the thing is i was Nightmares 3,
regardless.
If I was sponsored or not.
So it was really nice that they reached out to me to be like, hey, can we sponsor you to play this game?
I was like, oh, a fucking course, yeah?
I was going to play it regardless.
Like, yeah.
And then they were, like, asking me, like, oh, yeah, they made the third game is co-op.
It's co-op.
And then they were asking me if I, if there's anyone I want to do it with.
And I suggested Shibidoki as well.
Because, you know, we were I wanted to know the collab someday soon.
And I was just like, oh, okay.
Yeah, you know, I'll drop Lin Chibi-Doki for the spot.
I recommend Chibi-Doki for the sponsor.
And that's how it came to be.
Really.
It's just that easy.
Mm-hmm.
I'm not even worried about it.
I'm just gonna chill out a little bit.
I want to chill out a little bit.
Wow.
I think it's the only issue about...
Um, oh, but like, I feel like if it's end of season queues, queues should be a lot fucking faster, but it's not.
It's still slow as hell in this Elo, which is, which doesn't really make much sense because some people are trying to get the font.
I mean, there's also a lot of people camping it right now, too, I guess.
All people are, um, camping the rankings.
Which hero do you think you want to be today?
So that's why nobody's playing.
Because if none of the good players are playing.
Then like, you know.
If none of the good players are playing.
Then there's nothing to worry about.
No, I queue up for all servers.
For East End, West and Central Coast.
Yeah, it's pretty easy to camp it.
Because you don't decay.
You only decay eternity.
Now I keep getting the same mag.
guy this guy was hella last time he was doing so much on hella
all right let's go emma or bruce banner yes the central coast pick your hero or villain i'm not judging
all right here we go i'm not the type who fades quietly i went from one cloak to another cloak That's okay.
Oh, okay, that's fine.
Okay, that's fine.
If you're not playing Ultron, I'm not playing.
I'm not playing Luna.
You can't do this to me.
I left Luna jail.
I found the key and I broke out.
You can't put me back in.
I'm too tired.
I'm too tired for that shit.
Who wants to see something fantastic?
That's a late night session.
I'm not struggling at all.
I've been having a great time
You know if I really want to win I would play Luna and then snowflake my magic The battle starts in five
But also, if Cloak and Dagger really wants to win, she would play Luna and do that so I can stay invisible and win.
How about Cloak and Dagger?
Oh my god.
Are we running triple or are they just playing Jeff?
Let's fight up.
I swear to God, if they're on...
If they are on Cloak and Dagger for their Moon Knight, their Moon Knight does not need their Moon Knight does not need Cloak and Dagger.
He is fine.
Oh my god they're bay blading.
Oh they're running triple.
A fucking Corsair.
I can't believe this Cloak is playing, playing Cloak for a Moon Knight.
They have no tank.
Oh.
they don't oh my god oh my god oh my god oh no they got it never mind they oh never mind never mind I'm sad again never mind I have been I'm sad again why Why did I have hope?
What?
Why did I have hope?
Why did our mag push up?
I had hope for...
I hope for like three seconds and it was a mistake.
Never hope.
Never believe in anything.
God, do I actually have to...
Do I actually have to play?
Our magic is getting, like, destroyed with a...
Don't mess with the amazing Spider-Man!
Okay, please.
I'm trying to...
Alright, just swap.
Niagara alone?
I can't heal anymore.
Bro, I can't heal anymore.
I legitimately, I can't.
I I can't keep peeling my my buddy I really can't like you can't keep making me peel for this I literally can't it's so much come on let's just let's just kill them let's just kill it I'm tracking the spider-man so hard please I I can't keep peeling you
oh my god please i can't keep turning around i have a life outside
i have a life outside of this i can't keep turning around for you
okay thank you guys
yeah i'm so scared i'm so scared for my team i'm so scared for my team it's okay it's okay everything is okay oh my god he's coming back he's coming back for us we almost have to close okay i'm trying my best to keeping you a lot i really have She's coming back.
He's coming back.
I don't know what you want me to do.
Oh my god.
Please, please, please.
I can't do anything.
do anything!
They all watch me!
I can't do anything!
Don't even use it.
I'm coming back.
I'm coming.
Okay, never mind.
You get TP in these areas.
That's notes.
Okay.
I did my best.
Okay, I did my best.
No, I'm good.
Come on.
Yeah.
Wait, oh he's feeding.
They're down.
It's just a hard walk.
Good stuff.
We just got to walk.
Just turn them a walk.
Hard walk.
Help support.
These enemies have nothing.
Okay.
Please, please, please, please, please.
Please!
Okay, now we don't have any more.
Yeah.
Gotta fucking protect the support, bro.
Let's walk.
We're gonna touch.
I literally everyone just walked our cloak has it use them just first thing I'm coming over here holy shit all right that's fine I'm swear I swear to get
Oh my god.
Ah!
No one cares.
No one cares about the infest.
I think they make the hero.
No one cares!
I...
I swear you guys all see my entire team at the peel for myself and my teammate I the amount of times I'm like whoa is she okay whoa is she okay when she when does she do that to me when when did she do that for me when I'm literally the I'm not playing Luna play Luna against that is fucking stupid like I think if I was Luna,
I'd get even less pure.
Like, the fact that I'm trying my best to slowly walk up to point, and then my diet team actually left me.
And they're like, this is all.
Just live.
I'm like, will you help me live?
Will you help me stay alive?
Like, I just barely...
Fairly not!
You could say it's helping this survive, but you gotta do it too!
Are you hoping I'm playing?
Oh man.
Just go for it.
I'll go for the area.
No, we can't go playing.
Good.
oh my god oh my god there's nothing we can do bro the cloak and i are fighting for my our lives right now oh we we really are we're fighting for our fucking lives did you use anything other than add up
Oh my god.
Oh
my god.
I'm trying my best.
I really am.
I'm on me and her.
We are a lot.
Get out of here.
Up on point.
Stop bleeding point.
I'm going I want my cloak to go rocket like we can live if we run rocket we need to go animal crossing it's the only way it truly is we might have to go animal crossing I don't know what else to do she's got she can't hurt you he can't hurt you no more
You can't hurt you no more.
You are nothing.
I'm going.
I can't.
It's time.
Spider-Man.
It's the only way.
I'm so sorry, Cloak.
It's time.
Just go Animal Crossing.
It's the only way.
It really is.
We have to go.
It's the only way.
He has to go, Jeff.
That's right.
If he wants to live, he has to go.
He has to go, Jeff.
It's actually the only way to live in this world.
Okay.
I'll get you next time.
See, it's the only way.
It's the only...
You're ready.
We're just staring at it.
Spider-Man is the only problem though.
But supports can't walk.
Spider-Man's kicking on him.
That's why I said how supports.
Okay.
Yeah, but we're saying that, but who's turning?
I turn.
my god our venom got touched so does our mag let's just go when science failed me magic was there all right here we go we have touched it's fine it might not be fine it's fine
it might not be fine
this is winnable it could be winnable let's go this is real fireborn again
Okay, never mind.
You need to.
Never mind.
Oh my god.
Just go Adam.
We just...
Just go Jeff.
Cook so we won't get spied.
Maybe.
I don't know.
That's a good idea.
Actually.
I don't know.
Are you serious?
Oh my god, he actually is just He's just following me everywhere Why the fuck did he play Spider-Man when I?
Oh my god, actual Elytheris There we go Look, the thing is If he doesn't leave me alone If he leaves me alone, he doesn't Just put it here I don't know where else to put it
I'm sorry are you serious are you serious oh my god I can't go anywhere how does he know oh my god the timing that's actually so fucked for me I can't I can't do anything I'm literally getting timed
I'm just getting time.
This is horrible.
This is miserable.
I'm having a miserable time right now.
Oh my god.
I did not deserve this Elo.
I mean, that cloak was getting touched 24-7.
And we both were just our only help.
I don't even know.
I don't even know how we went.
I did not deserve that Elo.
I swear I was dying like 80%.
percent of time and i couldn't do anything about it i i couldn't do i felt like i had no backup at all i did not get helped at all that entire time i literally went raccoon so at least like at least my cloak had a better chance of surviving i there was zero feel i swear to god We had zero feel for the backline.
It was me and Cloak.
And the moment I swapped off from Invis, like, the body was just like, you.
I kill you now.
He's like, I don't care about the Cloak.
You're the problem now.
And I'm like, what did I do?
You're already getting...
That's it.
I need to know how close are you to top 500.
on you.
That's right.
The curse of Ra.
You're not getting top 500 tonight in this 24-hour grind.
As long as I'm queuing.
As long as I'm queuing, you're not making it in 24 hours.
TikTok, you have 22 hours left.
Evil.
The longer I queue, the longer less likely you're gonna get it.
That's fucking right.
You've been playing the whole night.
I've seen you.
I've bumped into this person so many times in the late night queues.
You ain't getting it, buddy.
It was the last thing I do before I go this trip it's denying your joy
that's the one thing i will do before before i leave
all right
whoa well if they if they what if they what if they what If they...
Bro.
If they what?
We'll never know.
Oh my god, we have two penny players.
How did life...
How did life get this way?
How do we get two penny players?
Yo, what's up with Shiko?
What's up, man?
How's your day then?
Uh, you know what?
Pretty bad.
I'm sorry about that.
That's good.
We're making our way back up.
I just have the craziest game ever.
It was wild.
I just had a game of crimson.
Um, Ben Thor, if they're going to bend 20, we're going to bend 20.
I'm sorry about that.
Well, never, they got him.
The ELO assassins got him.
So if they're going to ban our, they're going to bend Penny as well, but...
Surely we don't leave like Torch over.
I mean...
You could play Torch.
I could play BP.
Oh.
You really should have read through his doors.
Like he's really bad.
Guys, what happened to our Torch fan, guys?
I mean, he's worse on everything else.
Guys, what happened to our Torch fan, everybody?
I thought we had...
I thought we...
Okay.
I thought we had an agreement No apparently There's Red Thills on the enemy team And he's like the most He is like a notorious Thor one trick That everyone hates I've also had my share of Red Thills was the Is he OG Evo terrorist He's been terrorizing even Like whenever he started playing Rival But yeah,
because he does not swap.
I think he has learned to recently swap to Thor.
Swap off of Thor.
But he was like a hardcore Thor one trick for the longest fucking time.
And I was not happy.
Whenever I get him on my team, when he would not never swap, it made me very, very depressed.
What about second?
Two, one.
It's like he's on Neckros, bro.
What about that?
Nope, just like you're dealing with that guy.
Alright.
The fight is not even close to the club.
Where is Nat?
Guys, did we just...
Wait, where did the... What?
Wow, our mag is already good.
Ah.
Okay.
I missed.
Not bad.
Alright, that's fine.
Alright, get ready.
Bubble, bubble.
holy oh my god that is a lot of damage don't die oh goodbye everybody you don't need me just chilling i'm just making so much space for you guys oh my god it's fine i literally can't die oh my god there it is i'm scared
Goodbye.
It was nice knowing you.
It was nice knowing you guys.
I have to use my healer sprint.
What the fuck is going on?
Oh my god.
We gotta go.
Alright, here we go.
Jesus, what's going on?
What the fuck is going on in my team?
I'm losing track of everything.
character i mean they banned the worst character wait red thrills knows how to play back why where was this red thrills when i used to play top
where was this you know what let's go let's go up here you guys want to go in with it what do you mean we're already going in that's huge we pushed all the time there you go ha ha look how smart that was I'm on Luna.
Oh my god.
I needed that.
I need my own heal.
That's fine.
It's okay.
I canceled the door.
I killed him.
That's cool.
Wait, oh.
Oh, goodbye.
Don't worry, would you want double damage boost?
Just a deathly die.
Double damage boost more damage boost.
Did you save even more damage boost?
Let's sleep in Where is he over shield?
Oh my god, that's too much.
That's too much.
We fucked up.
We fucked up We messed up there's a mag on point we messed up I live to fight another day.
Alright, it's fine.
It's not fine.
I'm coming back now though.
You have no healers.
Try ultes or not.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's go, let's go!
More damage!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, there he goes.
There he fucking, there he goes.
I just thought they had to lift all of them really low.
I'm on carpet though.
That's a good buddy.
Thank you.
You know what?
I think...
I got Emma?
Oh, I...
Alright, let's go.
Nice job.
Yeah, alright.
We can kill it.
Let's go!
I've been- I pumped so many leaves.
I don't even know how- who doesn't have leaves.
I pumped so many leaves, I don't- Oh shit!
That's alright.
It was a good push.
It was a good effort.
I'm on point.
I don't know what's going.
Whenever I play Mantis, I swear to God.
I feel like everything is just, like I don't even know what's going on.
I pull Emma and she has no diamond for him?
Emma, can I?
Oh my god.
Wait, I slept something?
What did I do?
Oh, I slept her.
It didn't matter.
I still died.
It didn't matter They're like nice leave.
I don't know what was going on.
I don't know what's going on.
That's They're like well, that must have been planned wasn't it?
I'm like Yeah
He got that one.
I'm somebody.
Give me my shooter armor, bro.
No, we're in one.
We're in one.
We're in one, please.
I'm a one.
I'm somebody.
I'm just one.
Damage boost.
What do you mean?
I'm someone.
They got nobody.
I think I deserve to be acknowledged.
It's because I'm anime, isn't it?
I'm going to farm out.
This is your big chance!
No!
I just made it!
Better Moon Knight alting.
It's because I'm adamant, isn't it?
I got three, I got three!
I'm on Moon Knight, Moon Knight, can I?
Moon Knight solo, Moon Knight solo, nice.
Mag on point, Mag on point in our back line.
Oh my god.
Mag's one, Mag's one!
Mag's solo, Mag's solo!
Oh my!
Okay.
There you go.
How are we...
How are we stuck?
Oh my god, I even ulted!
Backing all of those over there.
We were fucking beating the shit out of their healers for so long!
I don't know.
Oh, they wasted it.
That's huge.
He's like, I'm armor distracting them.
I got them.
Me and I first are just, like, in their back.
Oh my god.
I literally I shouldn't have why did I come back?
I don't know why I don't know why I say try to save my mag.
I wanted that extra ult charge It just looked so juicy and it's just it was just so tempting
Wow, I pull em in she got bubble.
I might die here Oh
Goodbye Oh my god, what do I do?
What do we do here?
I'll just play with my Luna Alright, if we move up with Argus and Mantis damage we're gonna have to kill this before I'm on this one Oh, no, I can't Mantis damage this is I'm walking himself Not bad I'm bad
your ult on me i have all their support is blocked though we are undefeated that's nice i pull moon knight first i can't see you again i'm using my ult right after this whole time get ready oh my god there was a arm there getting ready for it i got you i got you in this one that's fine it's time yo it's okay it's okay i'm coming over don't worry Don't worry,
the raccoon is...
Oh, I did it.
I did it.
20 and 0.
We did it, guys.
Very much like this.
Keep it up.
And that's when you're doing amazing, like actually phenomenal.
I am mad because Witch Thrills finally finally decided to learn how to flex.
He finally did it.
not not very good but like look I'm proud of him I'm proud of it before he would ref he would fucking refuse to the only reason he'll ever get target bad is if people just like stream snipin because he streams like every fucking day
what happened to um rocket is getting buffed next is getting buffed next season so like every like he's actually pretty decent now right now but only situationally like you use him for lat like the free res like people have found out that his res is so like just um game changing during overtime um because loki got nerfed so everyone started using rocket because his lamps are not as like uh his lamps are too easy to get to destroy the people would just like uh just like rocket for overtime push
well i'm playing breath realton mags in did you do it they use so many resources to get them out
we're gone there you go jesus please please please i got their i got their oh my god you gotta break Bro, I'm getting hard bullied by the Oggs.
Oh my god.
He has better end escaping dive too.
Oh, shit.
That's why he's very...
If they're having hard dive, you play him for to escape dive as well.
I might just...
Oh my god.
I might actually go Jeff and just...
I try not to give him too much space to...
Oh, that's round one.
Thank you.
I'm...
Two...
I'm gonna kill you.
I'm opening it.
Get him.
Ultra one, ultra one.
Oh my god, I got the off.
Let's go.
I'm a one man.
Jesus Christ.
Please, please get him out of here.
I need to get my ult charge.
Oh, he's solo.
Nice, nice.
Please give me my upcharge!
Oh no, no.
Oh no.
There you go.
Use your...
Oh
no, I got hit.
I got hit.
He got three.
Oh no.
He got all of us.
Wait, two.
I can stall for you.
That was so unlucky.
I'm falling as long as I can.
I mean if someone wants to TP go out right now.
Oh, no, I'll I have mantis up.
I think we make it.
We make it for sure It's down.
It's down Oh my god
Jesus Christ Oh my god, I need this them we're all one we're all i can't i can't play mantis into this i literally can't i literally can't play mantis into this oh my god like i i get armed i get ran at okay i'll do one more life i'm like feeding way too hard like
these augs are me up i need i'm a position I'm positioning myself as if I can front line.
I'm just going to position further away.
Yeah, it's clear we got you.
Because I want to fight.
I'll try and force Simon for him early.
I can force here.
I'm just going further away.
I don't want to play too far because you're not supposed to play far.
But, like, I'm literally getting farmed so hard right now.
I thought I had drones on me.
Jesus Christ.
Oh, okay.
Oh.
Hello, goodbye.
Goodbye.
Are you serious?
What can I do?
Emma all got me down to the ground.
I'm fine point though.
We're challenged.
What can I do?
We got another fight here.
I have my ult for this next fight as well.
We can combo me and you, Swinny, or me and Fu.
It's up to you guys.
Yeah, I've got both.
I'll use my ult.
Okay.
I don't know what to do.
All right, let me know if you guys are ready.
I'm ready.
All right, I'm going in there very on point, on point.
I got two.
Okay.
Dude, this moon knight is just getting so much value because the knight is going to break out.
What?
Oh, no.
Please, please, please, please, man.
Like, I'm pretending I'm fucking fighting for so long.
Oh my god.
I'm on Moonay.
I'm bringing Moonay and Invis in.
Moonay and Invis out of there.
Holy shit.
I'm trying so hard.
I am.
come on this way i died jesus christ we have two and a half minutes here we just regroup get back and back don't no i still oh my i'm not playing mantis fuck this this is our best point here we got this i think i'm with the bugger uh you get this ultra one with me i'm not playing i can't play mantis here bro fuck this not what i'm about to right now forget it
They used that so early.
I can't.
I cannot do this anymore.
I'm pulling back in.
Everyone folks nice.
Nice and nice.
I'll block it though.
Kind of.
I blocked, I blocked it.
Okay.
I'll try one, I'll try one.
Try mobs best.
They're gonna hear my chase.
Let me out first.
Walk them out.
I'm walking.
Don't get young about that, please.
Gonna who is he gonna?
Are you serious?
Are you he got not just Luna.
It's not just Luna.
Alright, alright.
Oh wait, that was an English song.
It's okay, it's okay, we're telling.
Just call targets, call targets.
Oh my god, are you fucking- I can't do anything!
Max one, max one!
He's stuck, max one, I'm stuck!
Okay, it's five, it's five.
Give me that one!
It's fine.
It's not fine, but let's...
Oh my god, it's not fine.
Jesus Christ.
I'm trying so hard to peel.
I...
I really am I'm trying so hard to peel for him Oh my god I really am I swear I'm trying so hard to peel I swear to god Oh my, I feel like it's just I get bullied I really just get bullied I'm like, fuck me I guess Who gives a fuck about But what I want is life!
Jesus Christ.
Who cares what I want?
Can I go back here now?
What if I just heal here?
It's bad.
It's okay.
I still have this.
I still...
It's okay.
I still have this.
I... I still have this.
Oh my god.
Okay.
This game also sucked.
This game also fucking sucked.
I swear I'm getting pummeled to the ground and being like...
Are you enjoying this?
I'm like, no.
They're like, come on.
Aren't you having fun?
Oh, hey.
This is rough.
Wait, this is the Korean guy.
Oh, isn't this the...
I'm this player?
Hello.
I'm like, I'm not...
Sorry.
And I get plus, bro.
No, I get plus 17 because of the fact that, um, because of the fact that, uh, uh, I died 14 times.
I, I fucking died 14 times in a row.
Yeah, this is the Korean Iron Fist player.
Yeah, is it Rocky OTP?
Isn't he like, he's on Red Esports too, right?
i'm like i'm not not having that much fun but it's okay i know i know i was in the wrong who cares about i i think i was mispositioned in some areas but like there were some moments where i was like i can't survive this like i can't how do i live how do i how do i fucking stand live i'm gonna go pee i'll be your back chat
i'm back also i realize i think the worst part is that you think my support life is hell right now it's only gonna get worse next season it's it's only gonna get so much more worse next season for fellow support players i will that I feel like I feel like I did misposition myself as Mantis because I don't play Mantis that often anymore and I just I played way too aggressive there um and got punished really easily by the angst the angst punt because like I don't have escape ability for angst my entire thing is I just shoot I just hoping that I get healed I get healed past it that's like my only hope oh so If I lose this GM game,
I lose a lot.
I'm just saying.
I would lose a lot.
So, Rocket better be carrying me.
I better see a carry of a lifetime.
Because he's on an alt account.
I know that's your alt.
I...
I got banished for this match.
Thank you for their tier...
Thank you for gifting three subs.
you how many games away there's no that's there's no such thing as how many games away is how many people have i over today that's the real question how many people have i ruined
well i'm the gatekeeper i'm here to make sure people don't get top 500.
I mean, if I win four games in a row, which is like in Dreamland, like, if there was a utopia where everyone's dreams come true.
We could.
Or everyone's dreams can actually come true.
That would be the day.
And then world peace.
If I ever win, if I win four games in a row, World peace will fully be established.
That means world peace is possible.
We will fix...
We'll fix world hunger.
No one will ever be hungry again.
No more poor.
No more homeless people.
That's when I win four games in a row.
The day I win four games in a row.
But that ain't happening.
The cancer will be cured.
Yeah.
If I win four games in a row, and secure top 500 right now we have cancer will be cured.
I'm not hoping.
That's the thing.
There's no hope anymore.
I mean, we're doing this.
I have to run in Viz because there's three tanks and that's a lot of.
So if they don't So if they don't Honestly, if they don't want me to win They hate They like cancer I'll say it
If I, if I If they don't want me to win They don't want to find a cure for cancer I'll say it Insane I'm blanking What does matter Yeah I got the venom.
Jesus Christ.
Venom no swing or shield.
We need to get these squids.
Please help me.
We got banner.
We got banner at least.
I hate this.
I got BP, I got BP.
There we go.
Please help me.
Please.
I...
I'm pushing.
This is not fun.
I got Luna.
No, you didn't.
Oh, she got foot.
Oh my god.
Who did?
Oh!
We double support all did that.
That's awkward.
Is everybody fine?
They're gonna combo.
Watch out.
It's okay to cat combo if I use this!
Wait, what the fuck?
I got him.
Thank God.
Okay.
That's called gaming.
Let's go.
We have like two different people they can combo with.
Okay.
I think my team will be fine right yeah that'll be fine whoops oh wait that wasn't me i didn't do that it's fine pushing up pop off i got venom holy she did
oh my god oh my god oh my god magic's behind please i got magic magic one Okay, that's okay That's fine I got him I got our cap and Bruce never mind I missed I'm gonna try again Jesus Christ what the fuck is going?
Oh, no You can't get me if I'm invisible Guys, he got me he Got me that's okay Wait, don't leave me wait don't leave me get the squid don't leave me are you out venom in the corner here oh god it's like what that was please please i'm on the job please please what do you mean never mind what do you mean Oh,
my God,
never mind.
He just, he just give up.
My life is, oh, he's like, your life is not that important.
And I, what the, that's fucking crazy.
I'm so sad.
My life.
Life is not that important, Tim!
He actually went different mine!
Hey,
he's gonna come for me, guys!
Oh, never mind, he didn't come for me.
I'm gonna flank, I'm gonna flank.
Oh, no, anyway!
I got Groot, I got Groot.
No, I'm fine, I'm fine.
JK.
Jesus Christ I have all
That's actually I still can't believe he said that
I still can't believe he said that I'm like processing the fact that my life has no value I'm grabbing you My life has no value to them.
I'm going to try to pin them.
Okay.
Jesus.
Oh, nice.
It's okay.
I put...
It's no longer okay.
Nice, nice, nice.
The only thing that has value is those ray grids.
So it's like no voice in.
cons equals the fuck they're like oh i bet she's just an mpc she never talked
you gotta support a guy that'll stop caring after it i was bro it was just there it's okay it literally could have oh my god
Ah yes, the rocket OTP special.
Sounds like overwatch.
I'm fucking IMAXed.
Out of sight, out of my own.
It's a lost cause.
I'm like, you could have just started.
Why did you stop?
I could have been freed.
Rocket, I'm counting on you on the battlefield.
all right i'm not sure where are you okay all right out of sight out of mind
here we go what is the hell is name what's that say okay hold the corner oh i fucked it up i fucked it took me a while to like Figure out what he said.
I got strange.
I almost died.
I actually almost died because of it.
I wasn't expecting.
I got strange again.
I just, it was, I just, I didn't expect it.
I'm flanking again.
I got strange again.
This place is worth a good luck.
Clear the way.
shit we're so fuck i'm just not fuck let's go
my hand's fine this triple tank is crazy i'm blanking again i'm surprised they just you know what what they had to do oh no oh no you know what they have to do they all they have to do is just play just play uh storm wolf that's nearly it they got one of the correct and then there's mad and then we have magic name work so like we almost got it
I'm here okay nice I'm gonna yeah he's sucking up all my ears I have to keep this for I need to keep oh my God dude
all right I that was crazy I didn't even have to there that's actually crazy it's okay he'll be together oh my god I got lucky there we go see I knew it together I didn't have to use us oh where is that name where oh the name was there dead together see yeah this is called figuring out it's so nice it's so nice when they don't have characters that that will dive me look at me go look at me go i'm just oh walk up a bit walk up please look at me go i'm just chilling never mind but i'm actually having such a nice day i can walk anywhere i want it's crazy
i never had i feel like i've never had that experience in like four games already i can't pull it because he has a so i need to be aware okay i'm getting out i'm backing out i'm backing out are you okay you are he still hasn't looked at yet like why is he saving it for marble rivals too i'm just gonna the new avengers movie
oh my god it's okay you can have that other hide i'll stay here i'll just stay here bro he still has his ult what is he doing not have passive i'm flanking again oh there's a namor he's looking for the whale oh i hear his little wet footies oh there okay he was not living that no matter what i got him namor's one behind it's all right i'm flanking i'm flanking please go up yeah are we gonna get our Fucking will fall the generational will fall like will fall and strange up right here This is it and they'll be like together Oh he hit us That's crazy Hello,
where's together wait where's where's together wait where's where's together?
Oh, he used it on himself.
Okay Yeah, I wasn't gonna use it for one man.
Oh my god He's a hero.
Look at him go.
Oh my god.
Look at him.
Yo, let Rocket heal me.
Don't heal me.
Oh, he's dead.
He was a hero.
I'm ready.
I have all.
He doesn't know.
I'm in behind.
The generational inv... the changel...
I think he literally...
He saved that up for that...
He definitely saved that up.
This was his first strange out.
I swear to God.
I'm pretty sure.
I'm on.
But who's gonna save who's gonna save me?
Who's gonna save me?
He's gonna need to talk to him.
I'm dying.
Yo, what?
Oh my god!
That was not disgusting.
That was...
It's fine, I'm coming over.
Oh, goodbye.
It's over.
He's playing his theme song.
There's like a fucking jump scare.
The fucking cop, bro.
Yeah, I got yet.
He's like, the hero is here.
The Avengers.
use this assembly.
It's literally one guy.
Hey, there's some magic.
I'm flanking, I'm flanking, push up.
I got magic.
It's very chill.
Nice.
I'm push up, push up.
Not nice.
Good luck, everyone.
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
I should have I should have came back to save you, but I let you die.
I got scared.
That was my bad.
I actually got scared.
I was like, okay, but like.
I actually was like, as long as the magic doesn't touch me.
I got old, we can go in.
I got their whole team.
Okay.
that's cool what do we do with that nice oh we do that okay oh my god I want I'm trying to give him the shield oh my god this Luna look at that Luna fight for her life that Luna was fighting for her fucking life right there trying to kill the captain of Mary it's like please that's cute that was me last game that There's a flanking spot right here.
That was actually me last game.
I'm going in.
That poor Luna.
What?
Am I just a lit?
They used...
Oh my god.
They used everything to drown me.
I'm flanking again.
Alright.
I got magic.
Oh, okay.
If you...
Can you...
Okay, let me...
I guess walk up a little bit.
Oh wait, did she like get out of her alt already?
ready there's no way no she's still oh we need to change something up i i i don't know we're getting wet now well that's okay i have well i have a well out of nowhere okay i can ult this they don't have they have strange up but it's okay
cosmic all right there's together
strange is one he is he could he could be dead there we go all right one more fight i have an idea i don't know if i'll make it i'll be here and then strange will all and then i'll be like Do you stop it?
He didn't even start it.
He didn't even start.
Oh, no, he stopped.
Yeah, he didn't even start the portal.
Bro, what?
Bro, he's not even gonna do the portal?
Oh, my.
Oh, my God.
Oh, my God, please.
It's over.
Unless.
Get him out of here.
It's okay.
It's not okay.
Oh, it's definitely not okay anymore.
Oh my god, it could be okay!
It could
be okay.
It could be okay.
What's going on?
Oh my goodness, how many ores do they have?
Oh my god, there's a...
Oh god, okay, oh god, oh god.
Ah, that.
Almost have all.
Keep me up, keep me up.
There we go, there we go.
Nice, nice, nice.
Please, please, there's a magic!
Please, there's a tank and a magic!
Stay on point.
We're trying!
We're just supporting!
We just support!
Oh my goodness, dude.
Oh my god, this is the TP that he waited.
It's okay.
I got something.
It's my, my, it's called my, my boat clutch.
A clutch play.
Don't worry!
This never fails me!
Just me and Jeff, me on the left, me on the right, Jeff on the left, they'll never be able to stop us!
Let's go!
That's the rocket clutch!
I bet you get like plus 16, dude that's the worst part because it was a GM lobby.
That's a cheat.
Oh, my!
I don't know, man.
I don't know if this is a word.
Plus a 14.
Plus.
I don't.
Bro, I got plus.
How far are you?
How far are you from Celestia, bro?
All that for plus 14.
Oh, who's Jen Felix?
Who's this guy?
who's gen felix i see high rank i accept i
if i lost i would have lost like minus 20 no 100 i agree there's no way life would be that kind to me i would have what would have lost like plus uh minus 20 there or minus 20 uh uh minus like minus 30 no 100 minus 30.
three more three more and then we'll find a cure for cancer actually no if i'm getting like plus 14 it's like plus five more games honestly just do they even have any good emotes other than her dj back to terrorizing Hey!
Oh my god, fellow Jeff!
Whoa!
Okay.
That my fellow Jeff chose violence today.
You must goon to the body?
What are they doing?
What the fuck did I just join?
One must always goon.
Remember, Chep, one must always...
What happens when you stop?
Gooning.
Never forget.
Whoa!
Found you.
I can smell you.
Ooh, you can't hide from me.
I guess I'll never know.
I'll never know.
what happens white woman jumpscare hi hello how do you do that how do you do that how does she do that wait I want to do that that looks so cool wait how does how does she do the spin chat that's so cute oh shift are
What?
I can't do it!
Oh, I have to...
Oh!
Wait.
It's the little things in life that makes me happy.
Jesus Christ.
What is this lava?
What the fuck is this lava?
The most...
Oh my god.
Did we get red thrills?
See ya.
Thor lock it.
I knew it was too good to be true.
Literally the enemy team.
Logan.
And then I saw two other people that were in.
Two other people.
That were in.
That were top 500.
Maybe they'll have.
have a fellow red thrills on their team if god is real they will give the other team a red thrills again nope guys i told you that ending team they don't want to cure cancer
that's on them guys i tried so hard guys i tried so hard
Any gatekeepers in enemy's chat?
You had to try to gatekeep me.
The gatekeeper has become gate kept.
I'm not the type who fades quietly into the...
Oh my god.
What is this?
Captain America and Thor?
Life is good.
Alright, let's hope.
Maybe, maybe, maybe.
Maybe they'll kill them before they kill me.
Maybe.
That's what I'm hoping for.
What time is...
Oh.
Can you one hold?
It feels good to step outside my bubble every now and then.
All right, here you go.
Oh.
I realize what time it is.
30 seconds before you attack.
Get ready.
All right.
Maybe that was...
Maybe I should have just streamed my top island route.
Maybe I should have just streamed.
Maybe if I streamed my grind, things would have been easier.
I think I actually would have hit top 500 if I streamed my grind
The beachy mode Oh the beach ball Alright What the fuck?
Oh my god Okay I should have I should have picked Actually no Oh I don't know who to heal.
Like, who...
Who do we heal in this?
Oh my god, oh my god.
Like, me hit!
I feel like...
Okay, maybe I should flip.
Oh my...
Like, who...
Who am I healing?
Bro, I...
I... I...
I don't know.
I'm not playing this.
I feel like I can't heal anybody.
I'm like, who do I heal like in this scenario?
Like I have to everybody is like fucking flying everywhere.
I swear to God.
There was like nobody to look at.
Yeah, um, Yeah, that ain't happening, I guess.
Or do I go Mantis?
I don't know, actually.
I feel like if I go...
Wait.
That's unlucky.
I went to Triumph here.
He did it!
What the fuck?
That's not on...
Oh!
Good fight.
Alright.
That's fine.
It's okay.
It's not, but it's okay.
I had a feeling this was gonna happen.
It's okay.
Alright.
Solo tank.
Oh my god, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, bro.
Will we be okay?
But...
Will we be okay, guys?
Oh my god!
I don't think so.
I...
okay it's fine
it's okay oh fuck oh my god there was a mine there
it's okay it's okay um this game sucks but it's okay it's so winnable like you know what's even crazy this is an entire lobby of of either pros or like actual top 500 players and these These are the games we're playing right now.
These are the games that we are playing, guys.
This cursed ass top 500.
Okay, that's fine.
The fact that these are how games are like, this does not look high, Elo.
I don't feel like I'm playing.
Hi, Elo.
Oh yeah, apparently he's like one of the best Iron Fist players in the world.
He just likes the, he just likes the pun.
Oh my god, I'm fucking leaving.
My art.
Oh my god, he's five.
Um, we double support ulted, so I'm a little concerned.
Okay, we double support ulted, so I really have to build up right now.
I need to build up right now.
This is really bad.
Like, I need all, like, right now, because Spy Man has all...
Come on.
Okay.
No!
I didn't see the Jeff!
He did them!
He used the, um, what he did is he used the high ground.
So I don't see it.
Should he just hold it when Jeff went?
He used that thing.
Oh my god.
I didn't see the...
I didn't know he did the high ground thing.
He did the fucking...
stupid-ass high-ground shit.
And that fucking...
I should have just ult it.
I'm just gonna ult when I'm right here, the Jeff up.
Yeah, it's an exploit.
Yeah.
You're not supposed to do it.
I literally didn't see the Jeff up because of it.
Because I couldn't...
This mine's over there.
Don't fall for it.
I hate that exploit so much.
There's two exploits.
exploits.
I don't know how to patch the other one.
The other one was basically, um, the other exploit is that you, um, you can have your jetfall infinitely, but like an infinite jetfall duration, so you don't have to,
like it, so it's not timed at all, which is pretty fucked if you think about it.
Oh my god, almost died.
Okay, let's go.
Oh.
Oh, yep.
Here's nothing I could do.
That was unlucky.
It was just me having to walk.
I die regardless.
We have no shield.
I require some aid Oh my god, is that shield?
That's crazy Oh my god, that's a shield
That's crazy
Okay Oh Um, um Emma Um, Emma?
Um, why did our Emma walk- walk in?
Why did my Emma walk in there?
I was so confused.
Oh my god.
Where's my door?
There you go.
I'm just like, help, please.
It's okay.
If I stand here, maybe I'll be okay.
Maybe.
I missed last game, guys.
Remember last game?
Where, like, where, like, I didn't have to worry about that?
That was nice Hey
guys, um Um Oh my god, thank god There was mines behind me Oh
More than half of the mission area Keep going It was mines behind me Life fucking sucks.
Life sucks.
This game sucks.
I love this game.
I fucking love this game.
Can't get enough of it.
I'm in a love-hate relationship right now.
Goodbye.
Oh my...
Bro, bro, stop!
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
I'm just like, stop!
I've got like a fly swat, it's like, yeah.
It's like, or like this, it's like...
He gets, he gets like, squeeze it slowly.
A slow squeeze.
Bro, I committed.
Bro really wanted me to die.
He could have saved that beefy all.
He's like, no, fuck this Luna in particular.
He was like, I committed too much, too much already.
materials guess what i can do do not worry guys i got luna
don't worry guys i got it did i get her guys did i get her i died before i could see did i get her guys sure did you did it buddy you sure did oh he went the wrong way oh my he didn't go the wrong way never mind i really did he think he went the wrong
he's going the other side i'll do it again
okay oh okay that's very unlucky oh he got dragged up
Oh That's us wait, we're still going oh we're committing we should have not committed.
I We definitely should not have committed that
Guys did I do a good job on this.
Oh shit
Okay, that was Okay, I'm gonna
Thanks for the shield As long as we don't...
God, my frames are...
Oh my god, I have 80 frames.
This...
This
guy...
Oh my god, thank god there is a...
Don't mess with the amazing Spider-Man!
Guys, did I get her?
Guys, guys, did I get her, guys?
Did I...
Guess...
Guess did I get it?
Oh my god, Adam!
I can't save you from that!
Adam,
I'm...
Oh my...
Ew!
What did I feel like getting juggled?
My life!
It was just like a forever juggle.
Our poor guy, though, I saw that.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry that...
You, you had, I saw, I had to see what I saw today.
You did what I did earlier.
Oh, shit.
Okay, nice.
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh, my God, he's actually one.
I'm so sad.
He's actually one.
Okay.
Oh, my God, he's back.
Don't worry, in like...
There we go.
Oh my god.
How did he live?
I'm so sad he actually lived.
Do I trust my Adam?
The most important questions in life.
Okay, all right, Adam has to raise actually.
If I get even, I swear to God.
Oh, that's so unlucky.
It's spider time!
Okay.
Don't mess with the amazing Spider-Man!
I'm here!
Oh my god, don't chuck me into the mines!
Oh my shit, he almost chucked me into the mines!
Oh my god!
Oh, I'm alive!
Somehow!
oh no it's over for us oh it's so over
we have no else oh we had no else if he's saved
oh my god he missed i got rid of recipe again
Oh no.
No!
He was
one!
He was actually one.
You guys have no supports.
We're coming over!
We're skating fast!
We're skating!
Get the health packs!
Get health packs!
We're skating fast!
Eat ass, skate fast!
Just get health packs!
Okay.
Okay, there you go.
You know what they say?
We did it.
We actually won that.
Let's go.
I did.
Bro, okay.
That Adam, the Adam team up actually fucking saved my life so much.
No, Gasser's not here.
I said if we win four games in a row, we're not yet where I hit top five.
100, then Cancer is here.
Our Adam actually saved my fucking life so much.
Oh my god, I got Celestia 2.
That's crazy.
I'm actually in Celestia 2 now.
I did a win.
Three.
I think like three.
That's crazy.
800.
And the dream is actually real.
Holy fuck.
What happened?
Not yet.
I knew when three in a row.
You know what it is.
Guys, we can buy the gear for cats.
Oh my god, we did it.
Web, web, web, web, web linked.
That's crazy.
Yes.
We...
Again.
The rake terrorist never gets punished.
I'm going to lose seven in a row now that you said that, chat.
I'm going to lose seven in a row.
There's no such thing as a good thing.
Never hope, chat.
Never hope.
Oh my gosh.
Noah Woods.
I mean, everybody did.
That was an intense fucking game.
Wait, I need to watch this one again.
I need to see the POV of the...
That guy must be so mad.
He must be so...
I'd be tilted too.
Not gonna lie.
I'd be so tilted.
Like, that shit was bullshit.
Like, that shit was actually so stupid.
Alright, there you go.
Yep.
I'm like, get out.
Leave.
She's like, why is she full HP again?
Why?
Bro, that must have been so still.
Dash, dash, dash, dash.
Alright.
The link.
Okay, I need to see this in a...
Alright.
No, I gotta...
Recam this.
I need to see this.
What does that look like?
Right here Alright, he's like my new target Link!
Link!
Why is she dying?
He did everything for nothing I like squashed a little...
How did you choose?
Yeah
Oh, oh, we have borderline.
I hope, I hope you're not throwing today.
What hero do you think you want to be today?
Sometimes they like to play Scarlet, which...
I'm not the type who fades quietly into the background.
Bro left you with more HP when I see when he started.
It's true.
I'm not the type who fades quietly into the background.
That's true.
Who am I going to banish from this match?
sometimes we feel a little quirky he feels a little quirky and then he'll he'll play Scarlet I remember you will play Scarlet Witch with no mic on with no sound on sorry with no sound on and I know because I thought I got them on my team one time we won though we somehow managed to win and I looked at their stream and they're like no Mike Scarlet Witch only no Mike no sound scarlet witch only i'm like oh i'm sorry you might be really good at scarlet witch but i'm sorry i have to avoid you the no sound is the crazy part to me no sound sarah thank you for the twitch prime thank you thank you a top-notch team to win this one just jamming up to their own music
They can feel the altrui.
I'm not gonna go to Mantis.
Alright, here we go.
This vision's 21-21.
They can feel it.
They feel the enemy.
They were Daredevil before Daredevil.
Daredevil.
It's the anti-Daredevil.
Guys, would you like some inspiration?
Don't worry.
There's a motivation dance for everybody.
Come on, we got this.
You guys want to cure cancer?
I want to cure cancer too.
So I better not lose.
Millions of kids depend on it.
No pressure.
share all
right there you go wait who am i all right here you go all right i guess i'll slowly push the cart for us that's fine i can slowly push oh that's not fine oh wait pushing cart
Oh Trying you All right, here's a damage boost just for you
I got you ultra
Okay, nice
Okay, maybe not maybe not Maybe not, maybe not, if you heal me, if you heal me, nice, okay.
Okay.
I wanted, whoa!
That's unlucky, that's unlucky.
Oh, it's mob co-fan!
I got kicked.
I didn't even notice he was there.
Oh, oh no, my mouse died.
Try to do that.
He has saved my map.
Oh no.
Oh no everyone.
It's fine.
We might have very limited.
Okay, we're gonna have very limited.
Very, very limited.
Movement right now.
Alright, I'm not gonna run in anymore.
I actually Julie is a very...
Oh.
Alright.
That's fine.
I'm scared of getting...
Hey, don't get caught.
Go.
It's all I got.
Yeah.
There we go.
You can tell...
I'm sorry.
I'm not throwing.
I just have...
My mouse actually died.
Okay, after...
Okay, I think my mouse would be charged up.
I think I should have charged it before.
Oh, Maya.
Can you guys look out?
Okay.
Oh, this is bad.
Oh, my God.
I just got it, too.
All right, it's fine.
Nope.
Oh, my God.
I can't do anything.
I'm trying to fix my rounds.
Okay.
I have more rage now.
I have more.
Oh my god, okay, I have more range.
I have more range.
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
Okay, I have my full range now.
We're gonna...
I'm not... It's fine.
I'm not off the wall.
Okay.
Oh, shit!
Not okay?
Oh my god, not okay.
There was a group behind us!
Yes!
Okay.
It's time.
Doing the one thing I know what to do.
Doing the one thing I know.
What to do.
Come down now.
Doing the one thing I know.
What the fuck?
What the fuck is this?
What the fuck is this ever doing here?
Okay, okay.
I'm sorry.
Sorry my mouse died so I can't really play me.
Why is Iron Fist breaking?
I'm sorry.
If my mouse died.
It died!
If my mouse didn't die, it would have been fine.
But my mouse died.
I'm sorry!
It was my bad.
It was an oopsie doopsy.
It was a little oopsie.
Yeah, it's just a little oopsie.
I'm sorry.
Okay.
Oh my god.
I got rid of my res.
A lot of them.
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
I have both too They don't know my res is right here They don't know Oh my god, both supporters also are Okay, it's fine, we're gonna do this here
Oh my god Disappear
It's okay, I have my res See, he's fine He's not fine But the others were fine.
You know, the others are okay.
He's fine too.
I think he's fine.
It's okay.
I'm chilling.
Don't have to worry about me.
I'm just down here.
Maybe we'll destroy it.
He's gonna have Starlord ult, isn't he?
Three, two, one.
Oh, shit.
No, never mind.
He'll have Brutal, which is even worse.
Okay, I think my mouse is charged enough.
I'm pretty sure.
I could play.
Maybe Adam?
Maybe Adam will be better.
Switch things up, including which side you're on.
Okay, I did throw a little bit because my mouse died, and then I very limited my cable.
My cable was all caught up.
So I did, I would say I was the one that quit.
I was the one that ruined the cure for cancer.
I, I, guys, I would admit that maybe I might have fucked it up.
I might have messed up there.
I can do this, maybe.
I believe Little Timmy would not make it because your mouth's tight.
That was maybe my bad.
Just me.
It was maybe my fault when that happened.
What a strange alliance.
My mouse.
Wait, let me see how much it's.
That 10 hour of rivals may not have been, oh my god, it's only at 10% right now.
Well, my bad bring back.
Look, I said I'm sorry, is that not enough?
I said I'm sorry.
I'll link us here So we can walk I thought we would You know walk up but I guess not I even Okay I don't have Where he is I don't have clicks anymore I don't know what you want from me I can't click anymore Oh You are safe now my friend Okay.
Jesus Christ, he built so fast.
I don't think we have anybody that can play.
I don't think anyone in the team played War.
Oh, Ultron.
Oh my god, Ultron, you crazy.
Okay, we have to...
I'm fucking leaving.
I gotta play for Res right now.
I don't know.
What's up?
I don't even know.
Alright.
Three, two, one.
Okay.
Okay, we...
Guys, that's not on me, though.
I would like to say...
That ain't on me.
That wasn't on me.
I did the res and everything.
We just don't have anybody.
that plays uh wolf unfortunately i am born a new we're punishing why aren't we playing punish here yeah so let's just go we don't we go 3d ps3 support doctors being corny and shit i'm playing three tanks all right no clicks oh they want this win why do you already want the playoff ctk do top 500 as well you don't need any of that you're right we need a this is the one moment we need scarlet witch you already got MVP you don't need any of that I should I should really swap off but I haven't died yet
Okay, I'm trying not to waste my clicks, but it's hard when
3, 2, 1 All right
guys guys die on foot, I have res that okay, wait, we have wait, what is this comp wait a minute, what is this comp?
Oh bro, wait what the fuck, you guys already have it all, give me top five wait a minute Also, why is there still a wall?
Guys, wait a minute.
It's like Calvin, he bought Calvin all over again.
Alright.
Hello.
Thanks for the shield.
Okay.
Hello.
I didn't do a boring game.
Did my job.
I don't know what else I could do.
Like, I did my job.
Guys, I guess.
Oh my god.
Minus 20.
Not, guys, I'm sorry.
But it looks like Little Timmy might not make it to Christmas, guys.
But it's not my fault chat.
It's not okay my mouse dying might have been my fault my
My mouse died might have been my fault, but I was not though.
I was not part of the problem where in my my entire team went three DPS
Look my mouse I was part of the problem But I was like 1% of the problem.
My mouse dying was only 1% of what happened.
There were 99% of other things that had led to this moment in time.
Yeah, it's charging right now.
Don't worry, it's charging right now.
I'm not a full piece of shit yet.
I was such an ELO terrorist that I got the Celestio 2, which was top 800.
Celestio 2 is top 500 right now.
That I was such an ELO terrorist that I somehow started climbing.
I don't know how.
It was weird.
This was not my intent.
I literally, my intent was to maybe derank the GM, but I ended up getting into Celestio 2.
I think like Rocket joined in like maybe Rocket joined in like two games ago
Hello everyone Oh hey everybody's chilling Hello guys Whoa look at these classy Look at these classy motherfuckers Right here oh Hey can I watch
is it like freak you freaking get out of here what will you do if i will he defend his woman will he defend her oh you know i'm not why are you close to My spidey
He's like she's like she's defending him.
He's like get your hands off my spider-man Jesus Christ That's crazy the ERP in my Marvel rivals Good to see the e-dating scene isn't dead Like how that was your first message like this is He's like you just couldn't believe it and you You had to...
No yowie in this household.
How dare you sniff my man.
Push, Ben.
Now I think I need to win four games.
I need to win like four games in a row to secure it.
I'm buying ammo.
Fuck this.
Wait, this is Drac- I'm buying a Jeff.
No Jeff?
Jeff sucks on this map.
Jeff is so- Bruce, really?
I guess both sucks.
This map sucks for Jeff because there's so much open corridors.
I think Adderban is fine.
Never mind.
I think I would- I swear to God if they have Jeff, I swear to fucking God.
fucking god if they have jeff i will be i will not be happy this will not be a happy day
all right buddy what do you play don't make me front line bucky
please what the fuck oh it's the archduke for i was that supposed to be archduke Frightening night But that's World War one you fucking idiot I thought is this a I just took fruity night or some shit Yeah, that sounds like something he do in World War one Not much it's just so I'm guessing five more wins maybe It might All right,
I'll let you know if it's I think it's D rank if I lose this I D rank back to select steal three
so it all lies on this game it all lies on this game i told you they give it and they take it i had too many free games so the world was like it's over oh my god it's so over i told you the what happened Holy shit, how did I get hooked?
I was hit.
I swear to God, I was behind people out of everybody.
Holy shit, that was a Roadhog 1.0 hook right there.
I refused to believe that I got, like, that was crazy.
That was actually a Roadhog 1.0 hook.
Oh my god, I'm trying to help.
Okay, we got the Bucky.
I don't know how, but we got the Bucky.
Like, that's all that matters.
No more hooks for me.
Um.
That's, I know what to play.
I think it's time.
Oh, shit, he got two.
Guys, it might be time to do animal crossing.
Wait, he got two, but...
Oh, the enemy.
Oh, he didn't get two.
Oh.
I thought you got two, bro.
What happened?
it's time it might be time for animal crossing it might be it all right it might be it i can't heal this
actually i can do a luna for this this is a luna this is a luna guys it was nice being celestia too for like maybe like two seconds it really was
It was so...
When did they get a wolf?
When did the wolf show up?
Guys, no.
This does not look ideal right now.
It really doesn't.
It's spider time!
Alright.
It's okay.
It's not okay for him, but it's okay for me.
Oh, goodbye.
All right, here we go.
All right.
I don't know who has gotten eaten, but it's time to go in, everybody.
Let's hope I don't die.
We didn't get the nest.
the nest i i thought i don't know i assume my team while i was doing the ult would shoot the nest and then i would know what it's like to be alive you know it's you know it's just the little things in life he has to let's just oh he has their time i think oh they did they actually did I had a feeling they had time.
Oh, it didn't matter.
They still died.
Thank God.
Thank fucking God.
Never trust a team.
I know.
Sometimes I'm just ignorant.
Sometimes I'm just like, maybe it'll be different.
You know?
Maybe today will be different.
But like, it's still gonna be me.
Today will never be different.
What are these people?
Tom still.
Okay, they're going cloaking.
Dagger.
What the fuck?
Where did she come from?
Oh, my!
Okay, I did not...
I was so confused.
I was like, where the fuck did that come from?
It came from the goddamn sky.
Because it did come from the goddamn sky.
Bro, he's like fucking Benny Hill.
right now okay they also don't have frontline okay we have frontline but you know what i mean
oh my god they have a dc guys guys It got through The payment went through They got a DC Please It's literally five
It went through Everyone go Everyone Guys I'm going to put this around here I know where he lives!
I know where he lives!
The PA actor finally started acting!
Let's go!
I said that...
They understood the assignment.
They understand.
He would attack him.
We did it!
I'm Celestia 2 for another game!
oh my god it's actually crazy we don't deserve this oh yeah we don't but the paid actor but i invested a lot in these actors okay
okay i didn't even know when they we were we start when did we start
okay now it's even okay that shit that was sick goodbye my nice okay that was not nice for me oh my god if he actually fell that would have been so fucking funny though please
60 seconds left how are we still here there you go Do we move forward?
We move forward?
Let's go.
And then the 4 is gonna be like...
Oh my god.
Okay.
My second actor.
My second paycheck.
Guys, we did it.
The second transfer went through too.
I found him.
Ente, thank you for the...
Oh my god, I thought he would go left side.
Why the fuck?
Please, we just need...
Archduke, get our ass over here!
Bro, he's not coming back.
We've been fighting this.
We got to overtime in a 5v6.
He's not coming back.
He's...
Guys, listen, we did not deserve this win.
Hardest 5v6, by the way.
Bro, the fact that we got to 5v6 on overtime.
Ray, thank you for the tier one sub.
Thank you, thank you.
And yeah, I don't know if I said it right, but thank you for Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
take this he got school in the morning toky how much is my thing charge
how much is my mouse charge 38 we'll do at 50.
please surrender i don't want to give him a chance to come back
watch this be plus 16.
Alright.
How much do you charge that guy?
I didn't pay him.
I just know.
I found where he lives and I sent someone.
I sent my regards.
Four.
One.
You have to stop there from securing the mission area.
Yay!
Thank
you, God.
God is real.
Hard earned.
Oh, man.
So hard earned.
My plus 16.
It's what I like to see.
That's what I'm talking about!
I worked so hard for that.
The 16, baby.
It's so very hard.
Now I'm 16, dopamine.
I'm currently 832 right now.
How many places is it?
Yeah.
830.
I think it would be high Celestia, too.
In 24 hours?
I don't know, actually.
Because, like, top 250...
I feel like maybe, like, 50 points, maybe?
I think 50 points would be, in rate...
Would be, like, safe.
Why am I hoping?
Nope, never gets me far.
Just think about terrorizing.
I won games that I should never have won today.
That's actually crazy.
There were so many games.
Jesus is cool.
How cool is Jesus?
Is Jesus how cool?
There you go.
What a name.
Jesus is cool.
Very cool.
What makes him cool?
Let's keep posing.
I'm waiting for him.
I want to know what makes Jesus so cool to him.
I want to know his life story.
He was a good person.
But I feel like I'm talking to a child.
He is not rot.
Who's shooting me?
Oh, it's epic duck.
That sounds cool.
Being good is pretty cool!
Oh my god, who the fuck is this guy?
Who is the... I'm RC champion.
That's on the enemy team right now.
Who the fuck is he?
Don't worry.
I should maybe worry a little bit.
Okay.
I think I charged enough.
I think 40% is enough, right?
40% should be enough.
I'll be like, do you want to be as cool as Jesus?
Do you want to be a good person and be just as cool as Jesus right now?
You know what to do.
Yeah, I got 40%.
I think that's enough.
Uh, oh my god, I got 60!
Wait, GPO Wireless charges so fast.
Yeah.
I'm not sponsored, by the way, but I love GPO Wireless.
They're just...
It's just so fast when it's charging.
Pick your hero.
Or villain, I'm not judging.
Is she close?
Stop hoping.
Hope is.
Hope is a lie.
You'll only get disappointed.
Only disappointment lies ahead.
Hope is cope.
Exactly.
You're just coping if you're hoping.
We are just okay.
We don't need shields.
I'll be there.
hey it's my um it's my top 500 rank up game and um um my chat would be very happy i feel like they'll be like it's time to make chat very very sad like i'll add you if you let me win this game
guys i'll add you on my friend list if you let me win this
wait that's an insane strat
To be fair, that's not much because I'll add anyone.
If I see you're close to top 500, or if you are top 500.
Do none of us have that?
Okay, none of us have front lines.
That's cool.
I like...
What the fuck?
You got deleted!
Holy shit!
Oh my god.
Oh, he's cute.
Yes!
Guys, it went through again.
Guys, it went through.
It went through again.
They were like, this is not possible.
They did not.
No way.
He heard.
He's like, God, I want to be on a friend's list.
That's actually insane.
Yay.
Dodging is wrong.
Disclaimer.
In case any of the devs are...
I'm not endorsing it.
I...
But yay.
dodging is not cool guys but if you happen to dodge on my team when we're losing i mean like you know things happen you know and so that whoa that guy's ended it went down at such an awkward time chat thank god and jesus wouldn't dodge about his ISP, guys.
A dog ate his Ethernet cable.
Pretty unfortunate.
Are we dodging?
I don't even know.
Are we dodging a queue?
Oh, hey, there's Mopko fat.
Wait, did he secure Top 500?
He adds me on his up and not on my main?
Ouch.
That hurt.
You're...
I'm the side account.
Yeah.
I'm...
Bro.
Bro, I'm the side account friend.
I'm only second account material.
Bro, that hurts.
Man.
To be fair, this is the second account.
Bro, what the fuck?
I have so many people's second accounts.
added.
I even have Cal's second account on my friend's list.
Not the real Cal's main account.
That.
Actually, side account.
Yeah, I'm not.
I'm the side duo.
I'm the one where, like, not gonna risk my main.
Okay.
i didn't tear eyes that hard look it's not that bad see we don't need to scroll down we don't need to scroll down see though i swear to god though these games have been so rough for me like
we don't have to scroll down but look guys
we're not no no we don't need to everything will be fine we're just queue dodging apparently because uh uh whoever was on the enemy team i don't know who it was on the enemy team but whoever it was we're target banning a rocket so he was like we dodge now i was supposed to end okay i was supposed to end like an hour ago but I'm just curious,
you know, I'm, I'm curious if it's possible.
I'm just, I'm, I'm just curious.
Mia, thank you for the raid.
Thank you.
Why and when you can, well, it's not just curing cancer.
There's also, uh, solving world hunger.
peace amongst the world but thank you so much for the raid i hope you had a great stream hello hello everybody for those who don't know me my name is dokeybird um oh freaky venom he can get freakier this is the only reason why i have this okay but this is my little welcome to everyone um but hello everyone my name is dokeybird i usually stream on uh youtube but he today i'm here on twitch because uh it's a guerrilla stream and there is uh there is 20 hours left at rank and um i decided um to i decided to be the final boss for the top 500 leaderboard because if i can't get top 500 this season no one can when they queue i'm like the e-o-m-m uh agent right now i i'm the gatekeeper
can um because i know there's a lot of there there's a lot of people desperate right now for the top 500 leaderboard because there's 24 hours left they all wanted they all wanted so bad
and i've already given up on my dream so i'm here to crush other people's dreams too But yes, I usually stream on YouTube.
But yeah, today I'm just playing Rank Evil.
For those who don't know, Top 500 is Celestial 2 right now.
I'm currently at Celestial 2 at the moment.
I'm also currently, I'm Ranked 829.
It wasn't supposed to go this way.
I thought I would derink, but we're here, I guess.
We're here.
Yes, we're here.
No, we're not locked.
Okay, I wasn't throwing.
I wasn't throwing.
But hope is a lie.
Every time I start hoping, I'm just in for disappointment.
It's a lie.
But I used to be top 500 a long time ago.
And then I stopped trying.
I even forgot to charge my mouse mid-game.
Like three games ago.
oh yeah i've been and i had to like i had to play mantis with like fucked up cable
no i need to win three games i think i think three games secures it but i don't think there's a world where that could happen maybe like one universe in
Maybe one dokeybird in one universe out of the way that has had it.
Only, yeah, just only three games, guys.
It's so easy.
Dr. Strange has seen it.
It's just that one dokey is living the life right now.
1v1, join range.
Bro, how are we gonna 1v1?
You got top 10.
Bro.
You got...
This is like...
It's 4 in the morning here.
And I'm pretty sure it's like...
What time is it right now in Korea?
This is the only 1v1 I'll do.
This is the only 1v1 I'll do in the practice range.
i think he'll still beat me i think the most intense 1v1 in history where is he oh wait okay all right i'm ready cloak only
the only 1v1 that matters all right here we go here we go i'm gonna get my absolute shit kicked in but here we go cloak only i don't even know how a cloak 1v1 will work true test of skill it truly is This is a real test.
All right, how do we know when we start, though?
How do we know?
Oh, whoa, whoa.
Oh, oh.
Sorry, dang.
No, never mind.
Jesus Christ.
I swear to God, Rock, if we lose this game, I swear to God, if we lose this game.
I'm not the type who fades quietly into the background Yeah, minus 35 Oh my god, Rocky go on streamer mode where where they're just gonna Even they don't know who they are look at the twitch directory
This is an expensive match The worst part is like even when I win I just get plus 14 oh wait they're talking about this guy this guys I'm oh he doesn't know he doesn't know he's in the he's in the room with a top 10 item he's like yeah I have aura he doesn't know he's in a room with oh man Joe all right Bruce
can you face reveal this is my face what do you mean to win this one all right guys
gg they god you have you have such a high ego right now they actually don't know they're like yep gonna carry on off he's gonna get his shit kicked in there's no way everybody he's gonna get fucked up Yeah.
Oh, we have the iron fist or not.
He's very confident.
I'm ready to see this confidence.
Actually, I could go clo- um, we're gonna go cloaking.
I'm gonna go cloaking.
Oh wait, never mind.
Let's just go to this.
I was gonna go cloak and then we build all in get point really fast.
Because that's like, um, that's what you do for meta.
I don't know.
You can't deny that would be a hot ticket.
But I've always preferred the cold.
Alright, here we go.
The battle starts in five.
Four, three, two, one.
There we go.
Alright.
Oh, down we go.
Didn't get frozen.
Things are looking okay.
Okay.
We gotta make sure that...
Oh, they have Hawkeye, though.
They have Hawkeye.
I'm a little scared.
Because you can get one shot.
Hey, Strange!
Could you let...
You know...
Not do that?
Oh, that's fine.
Oh, that's not fine.
Oh, I should have went and run.
rocket.
Oh, no, actually, I'm glad I didn't go rocket.
How do we heal that?
What do you mean?
Guys, what happened?
He said he said he said things would be different.
He was so confident about his fucking he was so confident.
Oh, what happened to the office?
What?
I don't understand what happened to the office.
Bro, I don't know what happened.
I thought you were him.
I thought you were him, bro
I'm gonna use this bucket There you go.
Okay, and that's why I'm not tweaking this though What?
Okay, this sucks.
This is so what?
Oh my god, I got double stunned guys i don't think he's him guys guys i don't think it's where uh okay um
um guys what i knew the moment we had the iron fist being like bad my arm fist.
It's over for them.
I knew it was over for us.
Did he miss the graph?
Okay, that's fine.
All right, it was over for us.
It really is.
Hello.
That's much better.
Hello, team.
Hello.
It might be over for us, buddy.
It really is.
Oh my god.
Now he's on, now he's on Panther.
Maybe we shouldn't have Q Dodge.
Oh my god.
I thought she would kill me.
That's okay.
Sometimes they give us and they take us away.
It's just be like that.
It really, it really do be like that.
I can't move.
I think it's also we only have literally one.
Maybe you're just bad.
bro bro bro I'm here bro
I need a bro there's so many people to heal there's so many people to heal bro oh no oh I'm trying so hard to heal please oh my god please it's over it's so over
Oh my god.
That Iron Fist was definitely all talk.
What are you guys doing?
I think I'm going to actually devote with this game.
I'm not the type who fades quietly into the background.
The right heroes could make all the difference.
crazy why did y'all leave me i got five bots that's crazy he says that we have literally a top 10 player on our team and he's calling us the bots
bro this cat ego of a lifetime actual ego it's good to step outside my bubble every now and then
Actual giant ass ego
I want to have his confidence too Bro this guy was so he thinks he's actually like God incarnate Like he's like this world's blessing Like God's blessing to the world right now And his He's like Oh guys they're not They're going to bat an arm for this arm for this He's the second coming of Marvel of Jesus.
We have the best player in the world, fucking saying shit like that.
I knew it was over.
Like I had that fucking feeling in my bones.
There you go.
Goodbye.
It's already over before it began.
Jesus Christ Hey guys, are we?
Yeah, I'm keeping my...
Goodbye.
No,
it was...
No, it was the...
It was the Iron Fist.
Report my whole team!
Oh, bro!
Bro, this guy has no idea who he's talking to.
That's...
Look at you, the goat fat.
Oh, my God.
It's all bullshit.
It's actually crazy.
I top you.
Bro, no way.
I actually OD ranked from that.
E-O-M-M.
Give him E-O-M-M.
take it i d ranked i got minus 25 game 16 and minus 20 time to report the whole team gee why you and then why
it's insane he's keeping me now oh wait i should avoid him okay did i avoid it reek you all right it's 1v1 time already okay jobs done job done
i found a bigger terrorist than me bro okay i actually got checked is he hidden profile bro i had like two games got canceled and
Bro, you really have an ego if Grandmaster 1 as your career highest?
You never even hit Celestial!
Holy shit!
He has played five!
Wait, how much have I played?
Bro, okay, Ian, okay, that's crazy.
That's actually crazy.
He actually peaked a GM.
He has never even hit Celestial in his entire life.
The fact that his entire life he hasn't hit it is wild.
Where is he?
Okay, here we go.
How do we start the match?
The real gatekeeper.
All right, here we go.
All right, ready?
Oh, he's going full.
Look, where are you?
I'm sorry, I've been...
I meant that cloak, sorry.
Cloak and...
And...
Okay.
Let's do it.
He was a cheater.
What are you doing?
No!
Wait!
Holy shit, what?
What did he do?
Oh wait.
Oh my god.
Oh.
No.
No, I almost had it.
It's a gaming.
Holy shit.
I told you.
It's top 10 for a reason.
Oh, I didn't have it.
I didn't have my thing.
Wait, give me a sec.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
I didn't have my cooldowns.
Bro, why is Bro losing?
It's game bro.
This guy is top 10, bro.
That's a fucking insane game sense!
Alright, here we go.
Wait, I need a full heal.
Fuck it.
Give me a second.
And then...
Alright.
Yeah.
Alright, here we go.
Do what, before he's gonna fuck me up.
Get ready.
How is bro losing?
I don't understand his brain is bigger than my he's Korean his brain is vegetable right now
I'm I almost failed math what do you want I almost failed math I am a failed math I am a failure of an Asian.
I'm a banana.
I'm yellow on the outside.
White on the inside.
This guy is full Asian.
He fucking lives in Korea.
He lives in Korea.
His brain is massive.
My brain is dumb vegetable soup from
Also from, like, staying up too much.
He's also a pro.
I'm a failure of an Asian.
I'm not the type who fades quietly into the background.
I literally almost failed.
I almost failed math.
And I had so many tutors, too.
Do we have...
Guys, do we...
Oh, my God.
Do we have red souls?
Do we have red pills again?
There is, that is the only reason anyone would ever do a Thor ban.
Oh my god, life is so cruel.
That's okay.
Red Queen is good.
It's a little heal here.
You can stop migraines.
What manner of creature are.
you none of your business when you enter my realm i'm never coming anywhere near your flocking realm you can count all right oh animal crossing let's go we're doing animal crossing oh it would be actually pretty good to do i will try this out it's actual doom queue hours now now it's real doom queue hours it was nice being see i told you guys never hope never hope guys never hope
Never believe in anything.
Oh, and then they go Wolverine because they were already stream sniping.
That's crazy that they're stream sniping him.
When you can just open.
When you just open my stream.
Oh, we can't find us that.
We're three tanks.
I'm just a fucking poor little raccoon.
That's all I can do.
Alright.
There we go.
This is very good gameplay, guys.
We're almost there.
We're almost to the promise, lad.
Look at that.
Just a little guy.
Making the easiest game of my life.
Alright.
let's go whoa wait why are they wait why did you not kill there okay guys guys how come they oh wait we did nice we did it's okay it's okay this is guys are you enjoying this gameplay
Oh my god.
I haven't let go of right click yet.
Oh.
That's embarrassing.
Good for...
You know what?
He tried.
It's good for him.
You know, good effort.
Does this damage my thing?
Oh my god, it does.
Oh, it's fine.
Yay.
Let me just stand here.
I'm on my Uber ride right now.
I caught my Uber.
Yay!
Bro, I don't even need a dodge.
Don't even need a dodge.
I literally just have to...
Oh, that's a lot of us.
Oh, I should...
I'm gonna put this closer, actually.
There we go.
I'll put it closer.
Oh, I forgot how to...
Oh, I should not have altered.
I legitimately thought there would be more people.
Did they have another res, maybe?
Hello, everyone.
Just barrel stuff them.
Barrel stuff them.
Why are we...
Don't let them throw!
Bro!
Oh, my God.
It's okay.
Watch this.
I have high ground.
Oh, shit!
I still have high ground.
I...
See, now you know why I don't like Rocket One Trick.
I literally...
You guys saw the gameplay I had to do as Luna and Invis, and then Rocket.
I'm literally just...
I'm just chilling.
Let me just stand over here.
Until I kill like someone finds me, then I'm not chilling.
But it's so chill.
I deserve this.
I actually do deserve this.
This is how majority of Rocket One Trick's play, too.
That's the worst part.
All right, do you have fun?
I mean, it's nice to relax right now, honestly.
Is this Resume?
Yeah, it does.
Oh, shit.
Whoops.
That's unlucky.
Oh, they're resetting now.
Oh, goodbye.
I'll just leave.
I'll leave and grab my health charge and then I'll be gone.
Oh, goodbye.
Yay.
Oh my god, goodbye.
Got my arch all charged.
Wait, thank you.
If I have to restress everyone else, this has to be stressed too.
Okay, I can...
That's fine.
Oh, what the fuck?
No, get away from me.
Can't nobody mind control me?
I'm a raccoon.
Yay!
Can we kill this?
There it is, it should be fine.
Bro, why are you standing there, bro?
There you go.
Yay!
Oh, you're really down the door.
You're like my favorite door player, too.
It is the nicest thing anyone has ever said to him.
I've seen so many people yell at this guy.
It's like really cool.
They double support.
Oh my god, they...
with support on it like I wish I was joking I've heard so many people rage at red drills all right I got high ground what you gonna do about that yay EOMM gizif and EOMM take it free my hood time to switch things up including which side you're on zero zero 90 look this is not a button i'm not here to do damage guys
hey but i have 19 assists though oh wait i did 51 damage with my 11 accuracy guys that's so hot right now is that isn't that hot guys what does animal crossing do there's a reason why people play animal crossing is when they're people when the enemy team is going full dive me night so they fucking done my story knows it's me so like when i was like what did you say so you knew that had to go so when you play animal crossing uh Basically,
like, dive characters can't do anything to the supports Because our heads are so... We're so tiny Me and a Jeff are so fucking small And we can just run around, like, jumping, crawling everywhere That there's no point in diving us Because we can literally be like this And be like,
wee And then be like, meow So there's no, like, there's no actual backline We just run around and chill And just hang.
See, look at that.
How are you gonna dive a shark?
Look at, he just swims away like actually i i even established that but that was so useless that is so useless literally that's what i mean there's like oh they're doing animal crossing too but the thing is it doesn't matter like we don't we're not running that oh look at that look see i got shot at i run away.
Aim for effort.
See, literally, literally what's the point of diving us?
He has to dive like...
Oh my god, he almost diving.
He has to dive like other, like others, the DPS or some shit, because he can't do shit to us.
Yeah, they're playing dive and counter dive, but like none Buster die.
We're like, literally just gonna... The only issue about Animal Crossing is that the heals are not as strong as obviously not as strong as the other supports.
But at least we're not getting though.
And we can heal when we're getting died because venom they can't do shit.
I'm just chilling.
Yeah.
The people are like, get off Rocket right now it's sort of like outdated knowledge but like also it depends on like the situation to be fair there's five like what is he gonna do like what is that guy gonna do he's like my little weak ass tentacles is gonna fix this look guys i got it too 1 0 28 It's ruined now.
Report this venom.
No, the perfect...
Wait, did the venom in the game?
To be fair, he's trying to dive a Jeff and a rocket.
That's pretty fucking... I also think he's not trying anymore, honestly.
I don't think he is trying, to be fair.
I hear a Star Lord.
Or is he...
What is he trying to do?
Is he just What is the star they're doing?
Holy shit.
Look, yeah, all you can do is dive our hell out.
And it's working.
See?
What can they do?
Disappear!
Who did...
What did he get?
Oh my god!
You got...
Two tanks and a DP...
You got a tank and a DPS and a Rocky Raccoon?
Like, look at this.
That is so sad.
That...
Never miss.
This is real firepower.
He tried so hard, man.
All you...
What the fuck?
Oh, this is bad for me now, but it's okay.
Oh, shit!
Oh!
They brought the dice, bro, the only way to beat us.
Wait, we're...
We're...
Oh my god, it's over.
Okay, this TP fucking sucks, guys.
What the fuck is this TP?
But also, look at this girl.
Look at me and Jeff go though.
Whoa, look at that.
Okay, we should get our point though.
Okay, we lived it so long.
We should not live that long.
The natural counter that was just bring a gun.
That's why you're buffing stuff.
No, we spend them does not need more buffs chat.
We're fine.
Free my hood.
It's gotta go back to...
Oh.
Oh, that's awkward.
I literally just got the...
What the fuck?
Is he still alive?
Oh my god, Rocket is still alive.
I didn't realize that.
What the fuck is he doing?
Who is he fighting over there?
His fucking demons?
I'm just looking at my side, trying to figure out what he's doing.
Hello.
Oh my god.
guys see
this is why this guys this is why this is exactly why
i'm not doing that yet when we're going back here cyber we broke his nectron See, this is why.
I told you guys.
This is the only way to counter-dive.
Me and the Jeff is just chilling.
It's fun.
I keep the Jeff alive.
Oh, they got off of Animal.
realize it just not ain't working at least they know it's actually such a it's fine as long as we don't leave god damn it we led him to the hello
oh he's coming back Never miss.
Gonna never miss, guys.
I mean, I can just...
Just put this here.
Just in case.
Oh, he saw it.
He saw it, didn't he?
Wait!
What's wrong with...
Get the fuck off my wrist!
How many times do we have to teach you this lesson?
Mad.
Bro, I'm trying to be helpful.
So I'm bro, it's the fuck off my res beacon.
Hold left click, hold right click.
Bro what did that res got?
All right, I'm gonna use, I'm gonna use the back, I'll be back guys.
I drank a lot of water, so I keep eating.
Oh, I mean, that's how I'm gonna use it.
it works but that's why i've been using the bathroom a lot
i'm back i'm back everybody i'm having fun though maybe i should have just been streaming my rival's grand maybe maybe i've been streaming the entire time it wouldn't maybe i could have got there a lot sooner maybe i could have actually got it it helps with this it's because i play better off stream you see me make a lot of fucking mistakes though i i do play a lot better off stream than i do on stream and also like you guys saw those moments where i had like 70 frames when the fucking strange portal opened like yeah you guys saw that right it got yeah it doesn't happen when i'm off stream but it's definitely a lot less frustrating
Let me...
I'm Pedro Pascal.
But the best thing I ever built was my family.
Damn.
That's hard for Pedro.
Mr. Fantastic.
Hello.
But how do I do this?
He's got...
Wait, how do I do it?
Damage.
Oh, that's how I do it.
Okay, I got it.
My!
Get over here!
Alright, go ahead.
Stop you.
I'm a menace to this- Oh shit, I'm sorry.
Misclick.
It was a misclick.
No one's safe from Pedro Pascal.
quietly leaves no one's safe not even myself not the tree call HR
all right who do we got who do we got oh my god we lose we lose a lot again They just got the other team has only the other team and we lose we lose a lot again quietly into the background The fantastic backshot Oh Why Why did she be like this?
Why they do this to me?
I've been a positive impact in the community.
That's what they said I deserve nice things.
Why magic?
Is there someone playing magic on the enemy team?
Because why the fuck?
Oh, wow.
They target ban the mat.
That's crazy.
Banning torch.
I don't care.
Venom?
Bro, I'm not gonna...
I don't wanna play...
Penny?
Bro, what kind of...
Who are you fighting?
Who?
Who are we fighting?
Who the fuck is on the enemy team to have all these bands?
I will bring peace to this universe.
I'm so confused.
I'm Luna Snow.
Like the moon, I shine in darkness.
His demons.
Oh.
Of course this is my minus 25 game.
I gained 17, I lose 25.
This life really is.
Round one!
Music makes people happy.
Heroes make them safe.
Maybe I can do both.
Why is he on Jeff?
I mean, why- I'm sorry, he should be on Jeff, but why did he throw himself off the cliff?
There's so much to live for right now.
Yeah, so...
Wait, is he throwing?
You are the winter soldier, aren't you?
How are we supposed to know that?
How?
How were we supposed to know that, though?
Maybe just don't touch the fan when you GM?
Oh my god.
Someone, you!
I mean, I mean, I can just...
Alright, we'll just report him to the devs.
Honestly.
We can just report this guy to the devs.
Just leave, man.
Okay.
Bro.
It's...
Oh my god.
Oh, he's streamer mode.
Oh, Mag is actually the goat.
Yeah, this guy's...
That's crazy.
No, this guy is actually at win trading.
And then the fucking guy was like, oh.
I have a 94% win rate.
Maybe don't control the bands when you...
And I'm like, bro!
Me and bedtime is Celestia 1 on his main.
The fuck you talking about?
That's actually crazy.
That's wild.
We can't report.
Because, um...
Um...
I don't know which one is he.
but he wasn't he it was five this one right
five yeah see we can't report him fucking clear your career profile though
it's the hackers it's the hackers you're so fucking stupid you're actually so stupid oh my god it's them The one with a torch win rate Is the hacker She plays with the hacker Every time That's why he was like So you Ben Don't let GM That's actually crazy That's actually crazy And he has hidden profile You're so stupid Who said this?
Is it today?
It's today!
Fuck you, bitch.
She said that.
Bro, no, she cues with hackers all the time.
She cues with blessed who got fucking banned from what I've told from other pros.
And all his accounts kept getting, all his alt accounts kept getting banned and everything.
So she's the one that named Jesus her main every time.
Actual.
as i was told by other pros that blessed was a hacker um because it was a huge debate and then he finally got like fully banned on his main and then every time he makes an alt account to boost her or play with her i don't know um those alt accounts get banned because like my friends will report it and then um i once were i won't not accidentally i once reported once one of the counts too and it also got bad
and i'm like how the torch is a main bad line how the fuck was i supposed to know we have a hacking 94 win rate torch player too like
um where is number five no this was it this one Oh, he was the one that was throwing.
He actually was the one that was throwing.
Oh my god.
Just because he can't wait.
He was actually the one.
I'll just report.
I'll just talk to my devs right now.
Can I report?
I'll just message devs right now, actually.
Can I Another report On stream that just happened Person who keeps playing with hacker Playing with hacker and booster Plus Hacker throwing my game Trying to throw my game
Um Let's see.
Um, ban evasion on multiple accounts.
Ban evasion on multiple accounts.
And then...
That's funny.
I don't think they knew.
Okay.
um look I usually don't get pissed but if you active like I'm just thinking like if you queue up a hacker all the time and like this hacker has ruined a lot of games that's when I get mad and then try to throw my game because I banned torch how the fuck was I supposed to know you were a torch player when torch is a main bad line like you never he never even he didn't even hover torch too that's the crazy part he didn't even fucking hover torch like if he hovered torch i wouldn't have banned torch
okay um
sorry i'm just writing the report over that's crazy that's actually fucking crazy I'll just hack I don't know if he's hacking on this account right now I don't even know He has like I know apparently his blessed account had all of this Banuvation And also hacker
Yeah Oh no he has This is his other account He has like I said he has had 10 He has 10 accounts In top Like he had had 10 accounts in.
Yay, thanks for being a hero.
No problem.
I'll be your hero.
Not 10.
Sorry, that's Aimball Calvin.
Five accounts.
He has had five accounts in top 10 before.
Not 10.
That's Aimball Calvin.
Like, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
But yeah, no, nothing gets me more pissed off than that.
It actually, like, pisses me off.
like really I told this story before in um members but that was her I didn't do nut if you guys remember the story I told it that's why I got really that's why I also got really mad when I found out like you know when I just found out because like I was just playing with my friend and then this was this was her her and her duo and um I didn't care I was just like I was just playing the game I don't really pay attention sometimes to like what's going on in like text chat stream and like and then that she was like the one that was being such a bitch to me for no reason i didn't say nothing i didn't she was like like like um this was like when um my duo was like but like i didn't no one would know like we were duo too or anything i was just i was literally just chilling Oh,
yeah, I should report the other guy for throwing too.
I forgot about that.
Who am I going to banish from this match?
Report player.
But, like, for those who didn't know, weren't in the members, throwing himself off as Jeff Maltz multiple times for during game.
See, look at it!
Human torch!
Wow!
Like...
No, okay, so, um...
We were playing a game, I was in this rap game, it was like a month or two ago, and I was due to someone, but like, we were both on streamer mode, and they were on an alt account.
So like, but the alt account was like my, like, it was the same rank as main.
And they just didn't want to play on the main.
And, you know, because, like, they don't want to lose their main elo right now.
Sadly, it can't be like that.
But, oh, we have four support players.
That's unlucky.
Oh, nice.
But, basically, my duo doesn't like her.
He hates getting games with her and Because like and the hacker because like he's lost games against the hacker multiple times and he hates that She just uses her to lose her every time With like have him like hack and stuff to get her high elo or some shit From what I'm told and so like every time he and every time he sees them He would call them out in game like no matter what He recognized that it was her and the hacker,
but they were on alt accounts.
So he called them out.
And then he called them.
He was like, oh, like, I don't care if you're...
Because he was playing Ultron.
And he was like, please put Snowflake on me to the Luna.
And she refused to put Snowflake on her because she wants to pocket the hacker.
So, um...
So he wanted to pocket the hacker.
But normally you would put the Snowflake on Ultron.
Oh, the Ultron can...
Okay, I'll tell the rest of the story later.
Fucking it's gaming time.
I'm sorry.
This is a cliffhanger right now.
We're at a cliffhanger right now, guys.
But I swear, the story will get really interesting.
For those who are not members, I swear to God, this is a very...
This is a very interesting story.
Okay.
I just need to focus on this right now.
now oh my god i thought he was gonna
please he's so low there we go there we go
oh my god i'm gonna be dead aren't i
right here
oh my god i'm hiding in here please can we cap the point Why am I still here?
Alright.
Oh Maya.
This is bad we sort of.
Okay.
I think this is safe.
I feel so safe in here.
Just needed the cat point.
That's it.
Jesus Christ, please!
Oh my god, we didn't cat point.
I swear to God.
Alright, I'm gonna go Ultron.
I'll go Ultron now.
I hate playing Ultron.
I'm not very good at him, too.
I'm not very good at Ultron.
But like, it's...
I know nobody's doing...
anything with damage boost.
Oh my god, I didn't realize he got frozen.
That's my bad.
That was...
By the eye of Agumoto.
There you go.
Oh my god.
We're all like super split up.
That's the only issue.
Because we don't have frontline, so it's a lot more...
It's a lot more fucking chaotic because of it.
We just don't have fucking front line.
Everybody is just...
Oh, so nobody is calming where to go?
Alright, it's fine.
Alright.
Alright, here we go.
Here we go.
Oh my, that doesn't matter.
I can't do anything.
There's like, uh...
I got deleted.
No, it's... It sucks because, like, there's literally no front line.
Like, they all have... There's all...
Everything is, like, front line.
Everything is just so chaotic.
There's just no front line.
Oh, well.
There's nothing we can do.
The current score is...
Zero.
Okay, the story.
Okay, basically, um, so, um, what happened was that, um, the Luna, uh, who was the name, she didn't snowflake our Ultron, which is my duo.
And then my Ultra, my duo got really mad because, um, because, like, that's meta.
That's how you're supposed to play, like, Ultron and Luna.
You snowflake the Ultron so he can live.
And then he'll just drone the DPS.
And I don't think we're winning this.
I really don't think I'll do this.
So basically what happened is that, bro, I had a drone on you.
Basically, and also Mantis, I should be frontline.
I'm not behind you.
It should have been the Jeff that heals you.
shouldn't be me.
Jeff should be the one that heals you, bro.
Like, so if anyone is not healing you, it's Jeff.
I was playing Mantis and Ultron and I droned you.
Like, so, no, it's not my, it can't be my, okay, it might be minus 25, I don't know.
But like, it shouldn't, it could be like minus 20, most likely.
Five, four, three, two, one.
But also, like, ever since that guy got caught, got caught hacking, he his main account disappeared.
Like, he never played any...
He never played...
He just creates accounts, basically.
He plays accounts to...
Like, I don't know.
I'm healing you.
I'm standing on the back line just so I can heal you.
Like, I don't know.
Also...
Like...
Literally doing my job.
Doing everything I can.
I'm standing behind you.
I'm standing behind you still.
So, I hope...
All right, so you're getting healed.
You can't complain about lack of heals.
I'm literally right behind you.
Whoa.
Oh, you can't say it hurts.
Girl, you can't.
I'm okay.
Oh.
All right.
Okay.
Oh, I'm not gonna make it easy.
All right.
Yeah, because he would, he used to be like top, top 50 or some shit on.
he was like a top 50 silo player and there was like a huge debate on whether or not this guy was hacking from all the pros from what i'm told and then um and then like oh i think i should have oh
i'm sorry bro there was nothing i could do there was actually nothing i could do but there was nothing i could do bro i like what do you want me i could i could walk a little i have to go for my own life all right so what happened was that um the lunar refused and then um my duo got mad and like stood in front of the lunar was like please heal me please put the snowflake on me i know you want to and then he got really tilted and then like was like type big was like hey i if we want to win a game i need you to snowflake me so i can get healed and because she just wanted to pocket the hacker and then um and then the luna was like uh he know like i don't remember what she said but like she was just like um ignoring him and then my duo exploded on her and was like uh look i know you want a snowflake your um um your uh i know you want to snow snowflake your um e-boyfriend but like if you want a game um please i just need a snowflake and i can pocket your boyfriend and then you can get
boosted um all you want like and then she was like uh to him um oh yeah yeah yeah if yeah i yeah if i'm the boosted, you're a booster, so who's worse, implying that he's boosting me?
And I'm like, what did I do?
Also, getting boosted is a lot worse than being boosted, than boosting.
Like, I feel like getting boosted is a lot worse than being a booster.
Because at least the booster, like the, like, because at least the booster is good at the game.
Like, like, I was like, I was like, I was like, yeah, what are you saying fuck me for?
And so, and then, do you think you want to be today?
And then she was like, yeah, did you not see your duo?
She altered nothing when the round was already over.
But I altered the point.
and then the mag c9 because I ulted so we won the point because of it so I was like bro what I won us the round with my ult because the mag tried was chasing after me when I ulted so then he c9 and then we won the round like so I was like why are you saying fuck me for and then and then my duo was like um oh i hope you enjoy your discord sleep call um um tonight after this game um and then she was like i hope you do too and i'm like bro but i said nothing during this entire conversation i didn't do anything i said nothing i was playing the game and I was reading and then and then so then like I don't know she hates me because I played with a person someone like I play with so many people I play with so many different people like I can't control what my duo says like I can't control it like I wasn't even paying attention so what was my god like i'm playing the game
and then yeah and then she like attacked me as a way to attack him i was like bro if you're like attack attack him for it like just use something else like why are you attacking me for what he said like me three seconds before you attack oh yeah but she also played with like um like a fucking a racist too that would say slurs and stuff in vc so i'm like oh before she played with a hacker and that guy also disappeared too because like everyone like um exposed him as like a really like a weirdo and then he also disappeared from rank
oh my god wait she was on stream remember that time when there was like this weird ass go.
And it was like on the Loki map.
And then like her and the other guy were just flaming each other and they were duoed.
Like that was them.
That wasn't the... That wasn't like the book.
She wasn't playing with the hacker.
She was just playing with the weirdo.
The creep.
The actual creep.
If anyone remembered that game and we were like, what the fuck is going on?
But yeah, that was when she used to play with the creep guy.
The like actual like gamer words guy And then he was just like talking shit about her And he was just like talking shit about like Like his duo or her duo Was just shit talking her Talking how she's such a bad player and stuff And I was just like what the Okay I need us focus now I'm not focusing I'm sorry Okay that's my bad I'm sorry
the thing okay oh my what how did oh we didn't stack oh my god we didn't stack in it okay All right Yeah, it was when we thought it was like weird ERP and shit
That's what I'm saying like
Bro, I'm trying my best to heal this like this is like a ring around the rosy situation right?
Oh my god this game is fucking forever
Like Bro oh my I had to reload
I'm trying my best to heal
I'm trying my best to heal all of this Nothing is dying fully How is this fight last We just capped wait i'll fight for my family oh my god we literally just catpoint that's crazy but that's basically the story so like i don't know she doesn't like me and then because she was like being really fucking weird to me every time i see them i'm just like oh
okay can i all right that's fine
okay bro this game this game is hard this game is hard I have to full focus this
game okay Jesus Christ what the fuck oh my god it's cuz they have a silo and we don't they have a silo we don't have a we don't have a silo so it's so hard to peel
this might be um it's fine it's fine i told you guys emom giveth and eom kith guys it's okay as long as
i think it's also because we have a store maybe
jesus christ i'm trying my best
I'm trying my best I'm trying my best to heal all of this I hope rocket if he hears me he I'm gonna give him all charge right now oh I'm actually so focused right now these guys are not I have to be aware of all my surroundings and it fucking sucks rocket please all first
Thank God.
Okay.
I think I'm five.
Oh my god.
Please have to reload.
Oh my god, this is...
That was a little messed up.
Thanks.
Please.
Please, this is so stressful.
This is so stressful.
Oh my god, I have to...
I'm like...
I'm trying to be aware of everything.
Jesus Christ.
This is so stressful.
nice we got the push-up okay we we might have used too many olds oh we might have used so many olds do we have any okay we have two olds they're gonna tp
oh my god we have please to them
I'm trying to There we go There we go Oh my god That was so stressful Oh my god
That was such a stressful round Holy shit I was like Fucking I feel like I was like 8,000 IQ trying to That's why you can tell I was not commentating at all Because that was such a stressful game I had to like I had to be aware of my entire surrounding too No,
these are all pro players Right here Majority of people on this lobby right now Are you not majority but like 50% of the lobby here is pro
So it's not fun It's not was it was not fun 20k yes i have 17k all right because i have to look right make sure like my right was is fine and my left is okay try raising two superpowered kids
all right
Oh, that sucks.
Um, we couldn't stack in time.
Oh, that's unfortunate.
That's unfortunate.
We were not stacked up for it.
Alright, here we go.
Okay.
Please, they are playing, uh...
They're playing Luna.
So, like...
I'm tempted to play Luna just for the combo, actually.
I should play Luna just to grab the combo but I feel like I don't know actually I don't know it would be better because then we can have patty cake too okay oh my Who did he even hit?
Oh my
god.
Oh, I just got all...
I was like, who did he even hit?
Jesus.
It's clear I'm still needed here.
Okay, this is fine.
This is not fine.
I'm gonna swap off after all.
Because like, I honestly think...
Just for the combo, maybe?
I'm debating.
I don't know.
I don't want to play it.
What?
Oh my god.
It didn't.
We all stepped.
Oh, what?
I thought we were committing.
Oh, I'm dead.
I'm dead.
Oh, nice.
Nice.
Oh my god.
I got you.
I had to use that to win the round I think it's just we have rocket oh he used that to relocate
okay bro I'm Jesus Christ please please kill him
Holy fuck!
I missed the platform.
This is not good for me.
He has...
The only issue is that they do have siloed up.
I don't know if we can stack this.
Oh my god, that's just scaring me.
I am ready to put on a show.
Oh my god, I try to stack it You gotta TP for it I tried the stack It didn't work That's unlucky Why are you not TPing?
Oh I just got all two I have to play Luna The only way to live through that is with I think with Patty Cake I think we didn't ask to be heroes but I'm not the type I have to play Luna that's the only way to live through and I'll give it to him and then I'll damage boost well I think I sure needed to swap the strings there yeah they're buffing that I was on Invis wait
again I shine in darkness The battle starts in five Four three Do we want in viz?
Okay All you need to do is capture the mission area got it?
What I was I was in viz I could have I could have kept my all are you fucking kidding me?
Oh my god.
I literally could have kept my all Like Oh my god.
Invisible?
Feeling fantastic.
I stopped.
Fear Magneto!
I could have kept my ult.
I'm so mad.
Like, we lost my ult because of that.
Oh, I got hit.
I got hit.
That's unlucky.
I'm just sad because we lost our Invis alt for no reason.
Just came back.
Oh, this is not winnable.
I could have had my Invis alt.
I literally...
Oh my god.
If I knew they were planning on swapping it, I would have kept my...
I could have had Invis alt for that fight.
It didn't make sense.
Where are they?
Where are my teammates?
Yeah, because he's solo us in here.
Wait.
I have to use that.
This fucking sucks!
I'm sorry, but...
Oh my god, there's nothing I could do.
I'm...
Oh my god This is such a hard game I am strengthened I don't give up so easily Win, please I think
it's unlucky because we're forcing Thor I think that's really it We're just forcing Thor into this And we are not We can't run triple
Win, please Bro, that's all he wants.
Please, he just wants to win.
I feel like I'm going to let him build also a little bit, though.
Jesus Christ.
This game is too hard.
Guys, I missed my...
Oh my god, why?
Why?
Go play.
Run!
I am ready to put on a show.
Oh my god.
I don't have all.
That's the worst part.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, there you go.
Oh, thank you.
Thank God.
I'm so scared!
Please, Jesus, I pulled her back.
Please kill her.
Wait, did we...
We broke it.
Okay.
No!
Oh, C9!
Yay!
Yay, I made a C9!
Oh my god, his wish came true!
Please win!
His wish came true!
What a game!
He got his wish, guys!
Please win!
The desperate plea works.
His plea.
But he was like.
He created.
He chanted a spell on this game.
When we knew saying win please would work.
Win the please.
Who said that?
I think it was.
It was.
Was it this guy?
Icarcto.
I don't know who this guy is.
The wish.
Groucher.
They give the 150s.
Thank you.
It was fair.
See, if the other players were just as polite as this guy, then games would be much easier to win.
Is it Gen G?
I mean, I can look it up.
Gen G.
Marvel Rivals Ignite.
Gen G Esport.
No, he's not in Gen G.
He Carkstow.
That guy's not an Gen-G.
Whoa.
Why are you mad?
Just be nice to you.
Just say please.
Oh, is he on the bench?
Oh, wait, he's a support player?
Yeah, I don't see him in the liquid.
It's not time yet.
It's too early.
I'll give him a little treat to satisfy him.
I'll be right back.
You guys little treat.
Treat.
Now he's a happy boy.
That is top 500 in our hearts.
Yeah, you guys little treat.
So now he's not a troublemaker anymore.
This is...
This is... This type of record is true... This record is true pain.
This is actually...
I hate making a zebra.
this is actual pain the zebra
we're going 50 50.
yeah and the winds of course of course they're less than though of course they are because i can have nice things i can never have and i'm going i bet you i'm going to get like 17 or 18 not 19 though because we're not here to make me happy Wait,
I bet you I'm not even, I'm gonna get like plus, if I win the next one, it'll be plus 17 or plus 18.
Or even 16 if they feel a little quirky.
But it won't be 19, though.
It's never 19.
See, plus 18.
19 is just a little too generous.
Oh, yeah.
Also, like the, that girl.
She used to be super nice in game, too.
I don't fucking know what happened to her.
Because I remember bumping into her in season zero.
And she used to be, like, so nice.
And then, like, she started being...
And then later...
I don't know what happened to her.
Because I remember season zero.
She was, like, really nice.
Com actually changed her.
No, it did.
It made her a bitter person.
Maybe it was a facade.
Yeah, because I remember having her in, like, my game.
And then she'll be like, hi, Doki.
And she'll calm and stuff and everything.
And like, now she's so mean.
I was like, like, I would say she's mean because she was so mean to me randomly.
When I didn't say anything.
That's why I was like even more pissed off.
Frank actually changed the verse.
Changed her.
All right.
I'll do Luna for today.
I'll do Luna for one game right now.
Me when I lose two games in a row.
It's my Joker moment.
Yeah, then she started playing with Packers and stuff.
And I was like, bro, I don't think it's that important.
No fan iron fist, GG
Oh, that's by the way yellow colluge is choppa
That's choppa by the way For those who You remember choppa guys
That's him They say that music brings the world together.
The ghost.
Okay, I need to stand in front of my Jeff.
I hope my Jeff is okay.
I'm gonna stand.
Maybe I'll hit something, you know?
Wee!
I'm healing!
Yippee.
I'm doing it, Mr. Krabs.
Whoa, I'm doing it.
You think he's okay?
Is you think...
Oh, shit.
I don't have heels now.
I'm scared now.
You know when you don't have any more heels and you're just like...
Oh, my God!
He had how many people in his...
He just had the entire mafia in his mouth and just threw it into our faces.
I was like, bro, chill.
The thing is, I'm not building ult, though.
That's the scary part.
I should have waited for them.
Because the Jeff is building all the ult charge.
So...
Oh my, I'm just going to use this just in case.
Oh, I used my clap in the wrong moment.
I should have kept my clap there.
Okay, is Jeff?
Yes.
Oh my god, I'm so close to that though.
Oh no.
I don't want to use it yet.
Oh my god, please tell me I'm Bubba.
Please, yay, yay.
Oh, it doesn't matter.
It doesn't.
Oh my god, it doesn't matter because we don't have...
We don't have a fucking...
We don't have fucking...
Why did we not have a strange?
Okay, it's okay.
We don't need strange.
I don't think we're touching, guys.
I...
I don't think we're touching.
I'm surprised we didn't get a strange here.
That's all we need.
This is the only thing that sucks, because like I said, they have two defensive ups.
please live please live please live please live
oh my god please be alive please continue to live oh please live oh my god it's full metal lamps oh my god please don't be till queuing please also don't oh my god it's the infamous full metal lamps for those who don't know that you used to be an infamous um penny one trick and now he has become an infamous um angela one trick and sometimes he gets very very tilted
as long as you're not still queuing bro you do whatever the fuck you want What?
Damn.
What is it?
Yes.
That is his hero pull.
As long as he's having fun.
But I don't think he's having fun playing that.
Wait, this guy's what?
Oh my god, he's so low.
I'm so sad.
Okay.
there you go top 10 korean iron fist going there he is there he goes at it again
i just i don't know i don't know if we're living this our chef was definitely not living this though i it's for sure
oh my god oh my god there was no way i was living that out of there I had no clap.
If I had clap, I was literally one second away.
I was one second away from getting clap.
Clap, clap.
Oh my god, there he goes again.
There he goes.
Oh, and he's dead.
There he was.
Oh my god, they bubbled him.
Now what do we do?
You brought a strange over.
I got two supports.
What did we do?
He brought the fucking two- that's scary.
What the fuck?
That was so scary.
When he brought in the fucking mag over, the stranger, I was like, what do we do?
Oh my god, there he goes.
Kung Fu fighting yet again.
There he goes.
He's Kung Fu fighting guys.
There he goes again.
Almost have all two.
Oh, he could have lived.
He actually could have lived there.
I should know he can.
He was full charge or some shit.
Oh my god, I got stuck.
I got stuck.
I'm so sad.
I couldn't I got body blocks so fucking hard Oh my god and they're running triple supreme fucking nerds A fucking curse It's time for animal crossing Boom, Kobe
There you go
It's animal crossing, Todd You got nobody It's animal crossing Here we go We're crossing and again and again and again and again
Yay I can feel it it would be everything but plus 19 and up It would be everything but that also I shouldn't oh my god I forgot we stopped the push oh now I jinxed it now I fucking jinxed it now
it's 6am I know I was supposed to end a lot earlier guys I'm sorry but like the the Elo agent must continue her job Round 2 Superpowers are amazing Also The ice effects look great on stage I have an assignment From upstairs From up above That I must continue to terrorize
I got word from up top I gotta continue to ruin lives An agents of Atlas reunion tour I don't know This is a true dude.
Keep on.
The soldier must continue.
The battle starts in five.
One of Guan Guan's best agents.
All you need to do is capture the mission area.
Oh yeah.
Apparently like, um, gains are also mostly dependent.
Like, because DPS players, they get like plus 25 and up sometimes.
Especially their MVP.
So it's like, it mostly depends on like, stuff like...
Stuff like how many final hits you get, how many damage you do.
So as a support, it's like, fuck me, you know?
As a support, we don't really get that privilege.
Fuck yeah, fuck yeah.
Hey, Bucky's in, oh, and he lives somehow.
I'm gonna get eaten, aren't I?
Hello, hello, hello, hello, hello, hello, hello, hello.
What the fuck is...
Oh my god, I have to use this just to be alive.
Okay, that's...
I like how it's just two Jeffs riding beside each other.
Like...
In the high, are you in Celestial, though?
In Celestial, if you're in, like, the lower Elo, that's, like, um, if it's, like, um, bro, this guy is getting fucked up.
If you're, like, in Diamond and Below, then, like, yeah, you get, like, plus 30 and stuff.
Yeah, but, like, if, like, Celestial and GM, it's, like, um.
Because, like, when I'm playing with some of my friends, they were, like, oh, I got, like, plus 18 on support.
I'm like welcome to my fucking life like I was like what do you mean wait is that not how much you're supposed to get like bro I got I can't believe it I got it
I was like yeah that's how it's supposed to oh my god the mag save my life thank you mag the mag is the secret double agent wait is it chop oh it's chop Thank you, Choppa.
Thank you, Choppa.
Yummy, yummy.
Oh, I'm dead.
Oh my god, I'm dead.
It's okay, he hasn't got, he only got me.
Bro, this is a fight of a fucking sentry.
EOMM agent!
The transfer went through, guys!
We did it!
But Choppa's a pro player, guys.
I don't think he intended.
He just didn't think that this change was gonna do it.
He's done it.
Choppa, my goat.
For far, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you, thank you.
The transfer went through.
Yet again.
Watch this.
I told you.
I can't have any nice thing.
I literally need plus 19.
I improved the definition.
Getting edged right now.
Is this edging?
Is this it?
Like a true agent Guys, is this edging guys is Edging in my shooter game Born a goon forced edge I told you but yeah like if you're a support player you might get lower than DPS it's crazy when like my dps players they'll be like yeah i just got plus 26 and like plus 24 plus 22 and i'm like what like what do you mean no plus 21 look at that plus doesn't matter that i got 30 to most healing in the doesn't matter because like uh but plus 27 i've never seen those numbers before I um but because like support numbers are very heavily dependent on also like the damage numbers you do as a support um so you might get more if you do more damage as a support like the damage numbers and also final hits um that's why supports don't get a lot because like I didn't get a lot of i only got three final hits um and i did barely got a lot of damage because i spent most of my time um healing um um and supports is truly hate all right let's see i don't know how much is jeff got plus 17 see look at that
plus 17 it's because his heals he has two final hits i swear it's also reliant on final hits too I think it's heavily reliant on final hits and, like, damage number.
Look at, plus 17 for the support.
All right, let's see.
Oh, I can't.
I can't look at these guys.
Oh, wait.
It's because I'm on someone else's.
Healing number is barely given.
And also your KDA, too.
Yeah.
Your KDA as well.
Yeah, no, they still haven't fixed it.
So that's why, like, like dps gains more too and then obviously like if you if you're mvp you get more as well but like supports just barely get anything um it's like the mercy problem back then but like the opposite of the mercy problem where mercy was getting way too much sr uh back then in overwatch days i don't know if some of you guys remember this but back in overwatch there was a lot of like inflated tricks um that boosted in um in elo because overwatch um adjusted their um sr gains for mercy players um i don't know if it's like supports in general but the more res you do the more you gain and the less you lose so mercy players would just purposely let people die so they could res more um so they boost the stats of resing so they would purposely let you die and then so just so like they can get more sr um so people they would do that and um healing the more heals you do um the more uh yeah the more it's just literally it was based on your like res is basically um and then from
that a lot of like mercy players found out about that tactic and then mercy players from like gold flat um suddenly became like master and GM players um truly abused because people were loot and they were losing less so um I don't remember how much the gains were back then so like an example would be like you would lose 14 SR if you lose on mercy um but you will gain like 30 if you win
yeah so yeah and also they overvalued yeah they did that too they overvalued uh healing so boost at all, because they want to pad their heals.
And then, so that's why you would see, like, a lot of Mercy players, because I remember back then, you would, like, you're like, who is this player?
I've never seen this player before.
And then you look at their thing, and it's literally, they were, like, I remember back then, because I was in GM back then, and I would, look at it, and I'll be like, I've never seen this player before, and I look at their history, and there was, like,
last season, Plat Gold Mercy player.
And this season, GM Mercy And I was like so fucking confused because I was like what like where did you come from?
Yeah, and that was back then they fixed it in like two seasons.
I remember this was like a lot of time ago
Sure Do it
Doing it All right But this is what it's like this is the opposite of the mercy problem where supports don't gain a lot oh we've got god hey how did they know damn
we are destroyed oh we're a defense this is defense gg go next
Oh, what is that?
We're attack?
Is this?
No, it's rockets targeted bad.
Oh, we're attack.
Okay, I thought we're defense.
When you have the fame part figured out.
Yeah, I was.
Put on an Angela.
Actually, I don't know who to put this on.
I feel I should put it on...
Oh, actually, I have a side lock.
What am I talking about?
Damn!
Yeah!
But a little Overwatch history for you guys.
The Overwatch lesson.
Four, three, two, one.
There we go.
Alright, what do they play?
Bro, what's going on?
Everyone was jumping.
Oh my god.
That's unlucky.
Not dead.
Oh my...
Jesus.
That was a lot of damage.
Jesus Christ.
That is still a lot of damage.
Alright.
Bro, you're taking so much damage.
I'm scared.
I'm so scared.
all right I'll push cart I'm cart duty haha I have to reload so I push cart
okay our sidewalk is grabbed as having the heels of a lifetime right now I swear this fight is lasting forever
Do you think they know I'm here?
Nah, right?
Nice.
Clap, clap!
Clap!
Oh my god, please.
Please, can we kill him?
Please!
I will risk my life!
Oh, nice, we did it.
Jesus Christ, that was a lot.
I felt like that's...
Oh, it's because they're running.
Oh, have they yeah, they were running triple support.
I'm just wondering have they always been triple support?
Alright I'm gonna be with them for a little bit because I'm scared.
It's fine.
I'll push it a little bit.
They won't die, right?
Famous last word.
They'll be okay, right?
They should be fine.
Oh my god, they were not fine.
okay I wasted clap there I need to stop wasting clap I just can't help it I see I like to use it on cool I shouldn't but like I just can't help it oh oh nice I only use mallet I only use mallet ha ha ha doesn't know.
I'll let her heal.
Oh no.
That's unlucky.
Five, four, three, two.
I'm sorry, I leave now.
We have that.
Ha ha!
Right?
That's yours.
Holy shit.
Oh, never mind.
no ha ha
I thought we would get ha ha time it sucks they're in triple so like it's gonna go on forever because we don't have triple
it really is gonna go on for the rest of our lives all right it's fine this is why also like the TTK is way too long you know how like I'm like I like it when TTK It's not, but this is like, you know, there's a moment where TTK is just too long.
I'm going to pin them.
Sometimes you just, it's just got to.
Sometimes it's just got to stop.
Oh, okay, I'm going to do it.
Yeah.
Not yet.
Okay.
got affected.
Oh, this is bad.
No resets.
Please, please, please.
Look at me.
Look at Oh.
I just die.
I just die here.
No, I try to go closer to my players because I knew that
where's my sila oh there he is i was trying to grab my sila
holy shit i even clapped it that's crazy bro i clapped i swear oh my god i clapped it dude that's the crazy part i was clapping so hard That's last fight.
I think we just got a run triple support.
Oh my god.
I'm clapping.
I don't know what else do you want me to do.
All I can do is clap.
Oh, oh fuck.
Okay, that's bad.
That's all I can do.
That sucks.
That actually sucks.
We fucked up the ult.
I didn't realize she had it.
Did she get Luna?
I don't think she got Luna.
Oh, we actually double support Ulster accidentally.
I'm so sad.
We messed up one time for all rotation.
We were rushing.
We were rushing so high.
We're not grabbing all too fast, I see.
we ain't getting it oh no he got the reset oh no he's coming he's coming he's coming over
bye the one time i i fucked up the old rotation i didn't realize we got we got invisible up
tab the moment they engage on us.
Because I've let her alt it every time.
Okay, it's time.
It's time!
It's rack time!
We're 99 out of 100.
Because we got edged by Marvel Rivals yet again.
Marvel Rivals have done it again.
he's back he's back can you stay the spot and then swap with us what what did he say wait what did he say wait what did he say i couldn't here no thank you oh he doesn't want me to play rat okay oh he went oh he does oh go raccoon i'm so confused i'm so he told me to swap what does he want three two what do you want i'm getting mixed signals i'm getting
for me oh it's because he won star lord okay that that's what he was the thing is though now that we because we don't have that's much better look at all armor for days though actual armor for days
all right there we go here i go just playing my trusty raccoon look at all these armors we're so rich in armor everyone look at all this armor armor for days oh my god choppa oh my god oh my god this free real estate it's free real estate so much armor what what happened to my oh there's a jeff well the jeff can't really do anything to be fair there's like a jeff roaming around oh what the fuck oh that's unlucky i'll pass you up i'm starving
our jeff is are we're having the most intense 1v1 right now we're having an intense 1v1 like i don't know what to do this 1v1 is crazy oh this is unlucky you know what we all the portal
Yeah.
I don't know about Liv, but...
All right.
Wait, what?
Wait a minute, what?
Wait, this is...
Oh, shit!
Okay, they know, they know, they know, they know, they know, they know, they know, they know, they know, they know.
I did not know this was like...
spot.
Oh my god.
I did not know.
Oh my god, I'm fucked.
I'm actually fucked.
I was very surprised.
Wait, why forfeit?
Who the fuck is he saying, is he saying full metal labs?
I don't know why we're forfeiting.
I don't have a buffer for you.
Oh, it's our invis.
It's unfortunately our invis.
Don't worry, I'm doing my best.
I'm doing my best.
I am actually.
I am doing my best.
Okay, do that.
Okay.
This is real firepower!
I am ready to be on a show!
Okay.
Alright.
That's okay.
It's not okay anymore.
It is absolutely not okay anymore.
Oh my god.
Hello, everybody.
Hello.
He's keep doing it.
He's still againing.
Final score.
One, two, two.
I don't even know who's...
I guess because we didn't go triple support during attack.
Well, you can't expect to win them all.
He's a crazy raccoon.
This guy's pro, though.
He's duode with...
Guys, translate.
Who's he shit-talking?
Chat.
Minus 21.
Me?
What did I do?
Wait, what?
He was shit-talking me.
He told me to stay raccoon.
What?
Okay, no, you know what?
No, fuck that guy.
Fuck that guy.
I was glazing him because I was like...
Because he's dealing with chopper.
He was dealing with chopper.
And, um...
He's in Crazy Raccoon?
No, fuck that guy.
He's not.
You got one guy by first chatter.
Oh, he wasn't?
Wait, what was it?
What did he say?
All right, fuck that guy chatter that tried to shit talk.
It wasn't one guy.
There were several people saying that.
Because, like, I have Automod on, and he was like, He's like raccoon diff and stuff like that.
I,
when you, I was right-clicking.
Actually, fuck that guy.
Yeah, no.
He's a loser.
I wasn't getting one guy.
No, fuck him.
Actually, fuck him.
Negative chat abuse.
I just, you know what?
Fuck him.
See that guy?
Bad player.
Toxic mentality.
I hope I gate kept you from top 500.
You're seeing how I got up to this rank and how my...
My raccoon alt was so slow.
And I was like, what?
I'm sorry?
We were literally...
What did I do wrong?
I thought Invis was gonna alt first.
No one told me to alt first.
Yeah, but Chopper stream snipes.
He opens my stream.
That's the thing.
That's crazy.
That's actually crazy.
Choppa's dealed with him too.
That makes me pissed off.
Because Choppa knows me.
And he even sent me like a video message and everything.
Not a real home.
That's not a homie right there.
Not homie behavior.
Actual not homie behavior.
I was planning on seeing Choppa too.
During like.
When I was at the land.
Now I'm glad I didn't.
Because that actually pisses me off.
Like, if you don't defend your friend, if they're getting...
Like, I'm just saying, if you're friends with someone, and you're dealing with...
And you do it with someone.
And, um, you don't defend them.
And I'm saying...
You think I don't...
I have people who understand Korean.
Like, that's just not...
That's just facts.
Like, that's...
Like, um...
That's literally just, like, poor...
like bro behavior right there.
That's just, I feel like for me, because I have so much personal experience with people backstabbing each other and like being snakes and stuff, like I have no room for people like being snakes and things.
I have no room for that.
I don't know.
I just don't like that.
I really don't like that.
Because like, I...
Uh...
in 30 seconds stay strong yeah i don't know it's just put gives me like such an off-putting feeling about it i hate that i actually hate that shit so much it's very snake like and i don't i don't enjoy that
because like if if you talk i've i've defended my friends like i talk shit about like behind their Bro, and then I would message my friends about it.
I was like, bro, what the fuck is going on?
Like...
Because, like, I don't like that.
Like, I hate, like, non-genuine people.
But that's just me.
I just, I don't know.
Just not a big fan of that.
And it makes me a little sad.
Because I thought Chopper was a real one, you know?
Also, like, bro, this is what I'm saying.
Like, pro players and they're fucking weak.
mentals too wait what oh my god I was trying to climb whoops that's my bad I fucked up there I don't have heels I don't have heels I don't have rest I don't have rest please I have up I'm back enough this is real firepower Stand down!
Oh, wait, he got nobody.
Wait, he got nobody.
Oh my god, but what about me though?
Okay, that was so smart.
Right there?
That was so smart.
Oh my god.
My wall.
my wall my wall I should have put it somewhere closer but I was so scared oh my god oh I couldn't get away I couldn't get away oh now he plays triple support what a bitch now he plays triple support so I it makes me really mad because it's like you know I think he knows who I am and he talks in a different language thinking that he gets to hide behind that's the thing he knows English but he had because a lot of these cream players actually know English and they hide behind they were he's hiding behind Korean Thinking that I won't be able to know what he's saying.
So that's what they...
That got me...
That fucking...
Rise my gears!
Yeah, to hide something, yeah.
Yeah, I hate it when people do that.
Oh my god, story time!
one time I had that happen to me when I was at school and like one lady was shit okay there was this parent and her kid and like she was shit talking like um she was like shit talking people during cafeteria in Cantonese and like not knowing that I could speak Cantonese and it was so off-putting and I was like in middle school or some shit and it was so off-putting and I literally turned around when I heard like a mom and her kid were just shit talking like random students They're back in Cantonese.
I literally turn around and was like, bro, like I know Cantonese like, um, don't stop that Like this is really fucking rude like and then she like they both shut up They both shut up after I said that That's why I'm saying like I don't like that.
So it like made me like extra peeved about it because I hate people who do that in general Okay, I'm gonna Gotta put this here.
I have to move it.
Yeah.
That's fine.
I have...
I will here.
I will...
Yeah, and they always shut up when you talk back too.
That's why I say, that's why I like, personal experience, I've never liked that type of behavior.
I might be making enemies right now though but I just don't like rap behavior in general as I play raccoon I just don't like that behavior playing right as I play raccoon all right it's fine
Yeah.
Where is this?
What?
Where is it?
There's a fucking random Jeff here.
This is a random, are we not giving a fuck about this Jeff?
Power to us, I guess.
Oh, I fucked up.
Oh, he fucking used it on the...
Res?
Okay.
That's crazy.
I didn't even notice he was using it on the Res, to be fair.
I wasn't paying attention.
I wasn't paying attention at all, so I didn't realize...
That's my bad.
we are 13 seconds oh they're just running at us oh oh Emma I'm trying bye I guess goodbye yeah it was worth it for him what it's unlucky hello goodbye I leave out I leave all right I mean I guess I can put it here um we can engage with this let's just go I want engagement with Ultron actually trying to keep
This is real firepower.
Oh.
Oh, nice.
We got him.
Ladies and gentlemen, we got him.
All right.
Yay.
I love playing raccoon.
Ha ha ha.
Ha ha.
I'm gonna put oh my god oh my god how did that's so bad I didn't think oh my god oh my god it actually got I did think he would die that's so bad okay I threw that part I didn't think he would die
I was literally...
Oh my god.
What the fuck is wrong with you?
Please, please, please, please, please, please.
Please, please, please.
Oh, I got it off, though.
No!
I got it off!
I literally just got the old off.
Two, three.
Time to switch things up.
Including which side you're on.
I ult first, though.
I would ult first.
I don't know.
I would always ult first, and then I'll try to ult the second.
Was it not?
I'm pretty sure I ult it first every time.
Unless I'm mistaken.
Unless it's just ping.
Oh, it's West Coast, yeah.
I have no idea I swear to God I was all thing first
Nah but There's a lot of fake people though That's why I don't interact a lot with people Like being a content creator You realize there's just so many like There's so many like I guess like Fake people in the world That's why I don't do a lot of collabs anymore and um also why like i have a very very small group of people interact with what the fuck i think it was crazy he went triple support when they're fighting against us but he didn't go triple support um he didn't go triple support when it's like when it was just when I was on this team.
It is safer.
That's why I was super disappointed.
Because I thought, you know...
I thought Choppa was different.
I know it's just like one incident.
But still.
I think it's just a bitch move.
Holy shit, that's a...
god wait that's a wait what yeah i was gonna say that's a lot of people that that
oh here i am i don't think it was fine to up that only because like it's just us what
what the i mean it's just us three do it can i do i engage I mean, I can.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, okay.
I don't even know if I should engage.
Like, what the fuck am I...
What am I looking at?
Oh, by the way, I know which team I'm not, I know which team I'm not, um, I'm not cheering for it for Ignite.
All right, let's go.
This is real firepower.
Yeah, fuck that team.
If players like that, it ain't worth it.
Oh shit.
All right, I'll go something else.
Only 60 seconds left.
Oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, Doe fucking weird.
Oh.
Alright, here we go.
Hello, everyone.
Thank you so much for the raid.
For those who are new here, my name is Doe Keeper.
You know what's crazy?
Some of these people don't even know I stream, so they're, like, exposed.
These, like, uh, uh, players are exposing themselves.
in like, on my stream.
They're like actual toxic ass behavior.
Sorry, I'm being a little bit of a downer.
I just don't like that.
I'm just trying to fucking chill.
I hope they don't get top 500.
I hope...
I hope these people don't get top 500.
the gatekeeper continues oh crazy raccoon the crazy raccoon guy apparently like you try to hide behind another language to talk shit about me which is crazy shit honestly
yeah that's what I'm saying that's crazy ass behavior not crazy but that's toxic as Fuck.
I'm like thinking about it too much.
I'm gonna be positive again.
I'm thinking about it too much.
Yeah.
I'm gonna take the health pack real quick.
Fuck you.
I'm trying.
I really am.
I really, oh my god, I try to come over to save your ass.
That's so unlucky.
Wait, did Arluna live?
Oh, Luna is still being chased right now.
Arluna is still!
Arluna!
Oh, shit, Arluna!
Arluna.
Oh, I wish I could, like, leak shit, too.
Like, because I always defend crazy, like, this guy in my games, too, when I play with other people.
pros and I wish I didn't you know I wish I did it feeling fantastic
that's the thing that makes me the most upset that I defended this guy too and ranked when like other pros were talking shit about this guy and I don't even even know him that's the thing i didn't know who he was i just knew he was on crazy raccoon and i defended him to my pro friends and i was like he's on crazy raccoon like that makes me a bit more that's why i'm like extra yeah
spill the tea no um i won't
60 seconds does he know I'm here oh my gosh there's that
sucks cuz I have to use that
that sucks you
might need to use them for later Ah, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, sorry.
So super.
Thank you, my dear one.
So thank you.
Thank you.
That's insane.
I feel like I need to stop defending people.
I don't know.
Just because of, like, what?
Just because of, like, who they are.
Like, what?
What?
Because I respect Crazy Raccoon.
But I'm gonna stop that.
I'm gonna stop doing that.
Because they're just, you know, I assume they'd be like professional, but they're clearly not.
They're not professional.
Like, that's this guy.
I won't say all of them, but this guy is not professional.
We are undefeatable.
Yeah.
It's just unfortunate, you know?
Jesus Christ
I gotta make sure our Luna's okay Oh my god Where's my Luna?
Oh wait, my Luna's here Alright You get used to people disappointing you?
Yeah, I do I just need to stop that I'm too much, I'm too like not genuine I'm too emotional of a person But I've been like, I guess because I've been like, um...
I've been too nice to people.
That like, it's like hurt me more, more than benefiting me.
Yeah, it like bites me in the ass, exactly.
100% agree.
I knew you we weren't getting one guy ready Okay
I'm not dead I'm not dead I might be dead now I might not dead
I'm not dead that's fine it's okay we're not dead yet we're not dead yet there we go Jesus how long is this match oh
my god oh this is oh no
Yeah.
Not worth my energy.
No, first real.
I agree.
Iris, not worth my energy.
Those games are hard.
Holy shit.
Sorry about the downer mood there.
That just hurts.
It really hurts.
It really hurts there.
We're gonna reset ourselves.
set ourselves here sucks losing a lot we lose so much for those where we set ourselves here i just had to like vent that out i had to vent that out earlier because like it just hurts a bit because i defended like crazy raccoon players against other pros um because i know crazy raccoon the org and i respect the lot of players i respect the org and i respect like a lot of the players and i will say a lot of na players would like they'd like to talk about other players and then like i've gone against crazy raccoon and i have crazy raccoon players on my team and then like i would have like na players that would just like talk about them and then i would defend them to them i'd be like they're I think they're good.
I'd be like, they won Ignite.
They won um uh they won Ignite.
And I was like they won Ignite and I was like they should be good because they've done accomplished these things and I respect the org.
And I've defended the org and everything and I've defended um the players so it just hurts a lot more knowing that these are the attitudes of their players of this particular player.
Because I like they all got here um you know they all like got here on their own and everything too so it's like um they have the skill to be there and then so i like defended them to like some of the na pro scenes from the na pro players and so it hurts a lot more that this is the these are the this is this is a player from crazy raccoon um and the fact that he hid behind another language on my stream.
You know, all of this...
I hid behind another language to talk shit about me.
Even though I defended them behind the scenes.
To, like, the pro scene.
Like, whenever I play with, like, pro players.
So that's why I'm, like, it just hurts a lot more.
And I just...
It just sucks that he hid behind another language.
It's just so scummy.
like that's the thing i didn't really want to talk about but like after that i'm like fuck that if you're gonna hide behind another language to talk shit about me um on my stream by the way and say why am i here why is she here like she doesn't deserve to be in this ring and i'm like i literally won like several like on stream several games and a row solo queue to be fair there's like i would say i would say there were some games that i didn't deserve winning because i was getting picked non-stop but it was also like it was so out of my control because um i was not i was playing a support that requires peel yeah yeah if you're gonna talk shit do it to my fucking face that's what pisses me off the most i would be less mad I would be less fucking mad if um uh um if he said it in English but he said it in another language and if he did that to any other streamer like if it was a Japanese streamer or a Korean streamer and he did that to a Japanese streamer or Japanese VTuber or Korean
VTuber or Korean streamer have a lot of controversy that would happen there
would actually be like um people would get really mad sorry that like woke me up a lot really why because like um because it's all about respect it's all about respect to other content creators because if he did that to like like imagine if he said like i like if he said that if he's like uh because i've had i've seen like experiences where um i've read experiences where like uh players would have to like issue apologies because it's just very disrespectful you know
uh rusty they give a tier one sub thank you thank you hash brown they give a tier one sub thank you thank you get in n8 you can get away with it in n8 you can get away because everybody talks shit all the time yeah And you can talk shit.
Like, in NA, you can talk shit about anyone anytime.
Like, I've talked shit about other people and everything all the time.
But it's like...
But just hiding behind the language things really pissed me off.
Because, like, assuming I don't know how to recreate.
Which I don't!
But I have people again.
Go against them non-stop.
And they are just banning your fist.
Fist.
Your fist.
I think I might solo.
it might be better to just so it might be better to just uh hue dodge or solo because that's actually frustrating too i'm luna snow 30 seconds before you attack get ready yeah shouldn't we both be retired by now cap not as long as there's still a brighter tomorrow to setting here.
I really just dodged them.
I hate like, uh, yeah, but, um, Choppa didn't even defend me.
That's the thing.
I thought he was a homie.
Oh well.
So that's what made me me.
But yeah, I'm gonna reset myself.
Um, after this game has been fucking going against them too all right after after i will reset myself after this game just because like i said we're going against them
one more angry round i don't know look see he goes triple support
Yep.
Never goes triple support when on my team.
Unless he...
I'm okay though.
Sorry about that guys.
I know that I try not.
I normally am never like this, but that's just...
It actually just...
Makes me so...
Not tilted?
But like...
That's a lot of all.
Wait, and a gentle?
That's... Oh, look!
See?
He goes triple support.
Yeah, I guess I'm retarded.
I've still got songs to sing.
That's actually so scummy behavior.
He doesn't go triple support when he was on my team.
That's so scummy.
We are a little scummy.
Yeah, that's how much he wants to beat me or some shit or farm me
He wants to like he wants top 500 so fucking bad, but like when I was on
When I when he was on my team he refused to go triple support Is that crazy
There's no point in throwing Luna all against a storm because he's just gonna eat it.
So I have to Luna all everything but the storm.
Yeah, what's the context?
Just very disrespectful things.
But yeah, I'm gonna try.
I'm gonna present myself after this game.
Okay.
Oh it's because we're against them again.
I wanted to pew dodge because it's just not fun because they're just Target banning.
They're just target banning rocket and like this guy is purposely trying his fucking ass off um Against me, but he refused to play triple support Early like when he was on my team
Bye They're just gonna they're just gonna eat us up
Yes, he is.
They're just gonna do the Sharknado.
Oh, we killed him before.
Thank god.
Hey, can we kill this fucking Venom?
That Jesus Christ.
I was on that venom for 20 years.
We report them.
It's not reportable.
He's just being an asshole.
That's really it.
He can't report someone for being an asshole.
There we go.
It's just like that.
Pooh, pooh, pooh, pooh.
I'm gonna tell, like, my friend about it, though.
I'd be like, you were right.
That was like, you're right.
I won't.
There you go.
Okay, I'm just gonna clap.
I clap.
I keep clapping.
Here you go.
Here's your thing.
Where's the storm?
I'm scared.
I'm so scared.
Where's the storm?
Hey guys, can we still kill?
Can we please kill him?
I swear, it's just him.
Are they gonna TP?
No, they're not.
I'm so healthy.
All right, here I'll go.
Oh my god, please don't die.
Please don't die, dude.
Please don't die That's okay.
He can't die Okay, wait he might be dead.
Oh my god.
This might be it for my team I'm trying so hard to kill him.
Thank god Thank god Thank fucking guy Wait, are you okay?
You're fine.
You're so healthy sir.
You're so healthy I don't know how we live that, but I've always believed in them.
I don't know.
I don't know how we live through that.
But I've always believed.
I didn't, but like...
I've always believed.
I would like to think that I believed.
Oh, we go.
Why can't we be friends?
Why can't we...
be friends why can't we be friends
why can't we be friends why can't we whoa let's go jeff yay
it's over we're so back it's over we're so back I'm Luna Snow.
Like the moon, I shine in darkness.
The right heroes could make all the difference.
Because we don't have Jeff or Jeff player.
Round two.
Music makes people happy.
Heroes make them safe.
Maybe I can do that.
Sorry, I had to reply to a work message.
Good boy!
Jeff!
Who's a good boy?
My Jeff is.
Because it's like, oh my god, this is my...
I'm, like, not tired.
This is bad.
Might not get us through this one.
The battle
starts in five, four, three, two, one.
You have to stop them from the situation area.
He hears?
Wait, what is he doing?
What was he doing?
I had to do a work message.
You replied?
What do you say?
What did you say?
I didn't see it Oh, okay Oh my god, I'm trying Oh my god, I'm sorry I'm sorry, I got distracted I'm so sorry
I'm sorry, I got distracted
Don't worry, Jeff We'll live Oh Don't worry, I live, I'm sorry I live, I guess.
I don't think we can touch.
Oh, okay.
Never mind.
Oh my god, I told the friend about, like, one of my friends who was, like, talking shit about, like, and then he was, like, a fucking corset was the CR player.
Damn.
That's unlucky.
Oh, not yet!
Oh!
There you go.
Um, it's okay.
I'm here, I'm here, I'm here, I'm here, I'm here, I'm here, I'm here, I'm here.
We just don't have any more ults now.
We just don't have any ults here.
It's unfortunate.
Okay, that's fine.
I'm coming back.
I don't know if I should stay in Viz.
I mean, if I should stay there and I'll go in Viz at this point.
Like, I don't even know what I can play.
I don't know.
Do I stay?
Go in Viz?
And then this is...
Yeah, I feel like I should.
I'm just going to go in Viz.
Okay.
all right we can we get car can we get car oh my god we can that's good that's good to know nice he got two is there someone oh he got three go invis definitely telling you not because of the skin
i can't believe they got the star storm um they got the storm to swap off storm i can't believe it they must have said please win or some shit
maybe they said please win where's my please win oh my this is so okay it's fine it's fine it's fine we're okay we're no longer okay though
that's how I'm lucky they said that magic word they really did I mean I could go Luna now for this maybe oh I don't know I feel like I I'm gonna go Luna oh I'll go Luna okay because we have Adam now so it should be fine should be fine right technically technically it should be fine the only issue is we don't have push for the sword though to the switch up not for the strange up the switch up unlucky
I'm not gonna be stupid.
Oh my god, I'm fucking stupid.
I- I'm fucking stupid.
Unlucky.
I'm back in the fight.
It was a nice freeze, but unlucky.
Uh, we're so not- we're so...
Oh, this is bad.
I don't know what you got.
Oh my god.
Are you?
Are you crazy?
Okay.
No, no, that's not us at that point.
Oh my god.
That guy is stupid as hell.
That was stupid as hell.
I don't know.
That was so dumb.
That was actually.
What the?
Fuck!
What did I see there?
Oh my god!
Alright, if we lose this game, I know it's not me at this point.
I...
I know it's not me.
Like...
Because that was actually the most dumbest shit I've ever seen.
Oh no.
I need to get high ground.
And he took the chance.
Might not been the most calculative chance, but he took it for sure.
He for sure took it right there.
Leave it for me.
I want him.
I want that kill.
Give this man.
Give it to me.
Goodbye.
Well, does anyone get hit?
I don't think so.
Three, four, three, two, one.
We can win.
The thing is that blow-up now.
Oh, there it is.
Oh.
There we go.
Get him at him!
Yay!
Let
me add him!
Okay, there you go.
Yay!
Goodbye!
Oh,
boy!
Am I a good boy?
Bro!
What the fuck?
Where does he say that?
You still want to dodge the...
Not fun.
No!
Bad!
Yeah!
Am I good boy?
Oh, I know I'm a good boy.
That means he had my stream playing in the background while he's playing the game.
KK, KK.
K.
that's because i said it in game i said it in game he not i said it while we were playing
oh there's there's
Yeah, really?
Okay, I tell him Sorry about that.
Okay, he apologized.
He is young.
All right, I'm looking up.
How if I live with your sticks bitch like you understand kid he is young okay okay all right it's because you guys want to know why i told my friend i was like i understand now and then he was like my friend was like um My friend was like, yeah, that's why,
why, why did you defend them?
Because I told my friend about it, too.
I was doing like, I was, because I was doing business messages anyways.
I was like, bro, bro, this guy.
Remember that guy I defended?
And I was like, yeah, yeah, I was like, yeah, this happened.
And then they're like, oh, yeah.
And I was like, yeah, you know who was doing it, Joppa.
And then my friend was like, what the fuck?
And my friend was like, he shouldn't.
What?
My friend was like, bro, what?
I think he messaged Chapa and was like, bro, what the fuck?
That ain't homie, that ain't pro behavior.
Like, it's like, bro, it's like boys will be boys.
My friend was like mad because they're like, bro, that's not pro behavior because he's also friends with Chapa.
And he's like, bro, why did you let him say that to her?
Like, I think my friend was like, bro, why did you, like, let that guy say that to her?
That...
See, that's a good friend.
That's actually a good friend.
Because he was like, bro.
Like...
Because my friend was, like, being a good friend, and was like, bro, like, why the fuck did you let that happen?
He was like, you do know she's streaming, right?
Like...
So, like, he called him out about it.
And that's why he, I think that's why he messaged me.
Yeah.
All right, let's see.
Let's see how old this kid is.
He is young.
He's old enough, not good enough reason.
It's just respect.
It's all about respect in general.
It's just an Asia thing.
Like, I would assume, because that's the thing.
For me, um it's just because like i was in an asian company so like i would never like talk about like other like like like and grinding like n8 we can handle toxic if you guys didn't know if you guys didn't know some japanese companies japanese vtuber companies and like eastward companies you are not allowed to be toxic to anyone because if you are you actually can get warnings or like a suspension um even in rank yeah even in rank you are not allowed to be toxic towards like others in like asia servers in terms of like if you are a professional especially if you're like i would say that there is a jp uh there's like several jp video companies that it's a rule because like i remember looking at it and i was um because i was asked about na na stuff and they had that rule it is a big company they had that rule and they were trying to implement that into na vtubers and i was like you can't do that because na is all about like talking shit and all of that shit so that's why i lost a lot
of respect because like i hold like players in asia to like because i know it's a rule yeah i know I know it's a rule, but I don't know about CR.
I know, like, some VTuber companies and stuff.
So I told them, you have to get rid of that rule.
Because, like, NA is all about it.
And I'm like, I can, you know, it's talking shit and all that.
It's fine.
But hiding behind the language to talk shit.
Not cool.
Not cool if I...
That's why I got extremely more angry.
And then I told them, and they took the rule out, because they understood.
Because I was like, this is culture differences.
Like, I was like, this is a difference in culture.
Um, and they removed the rule because I was like, if you do that, you're restricting the talents to a lot of stuff.
Yeah.
Yeah, but the fact that he said it in Korean was what, like, pissed me off.
Thinking I can't read it.
Yes, but I'm also streaming.
That's why I was more heated up.
about it you know that's why I was like so heated up about it but I know shit talk is because if any people if an any pro fuck you should talk me and I'll be like I cry I cry but I know I know that it's they do it like I know it's like they I'll just be like sad but I hold a different standard towards like yeah Yeah,
and they say it to my face.
They say it to my face.
Yeah, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you, thank you.
It's just different, yeah.
That's why, like, that's why, like, it's more, yeah, it's a little bit of a lore drop and shit, but, like, it's so, like, you can understand why I'm, like, more, I, uh, I got a lot more heated up about all of that.
Because it just felt...
Like, you know, I, like, know the culture, and I know, like, the rules and stuff and everything.
I just think he didn't know.
I think he didn't know that I'm a streamer.
Or, like, that I know about this stuff.
Because I've been in that type of, like, community.
Like, I've been in that type of org.
And I've been in, like, I've seen the rules.
Like, yeah.
Um, alright, I forgot.
How young?
That's such a fucked up question to say out loud without context.
But for those who are wondering, Choppa apologized on behalf of him and was like, he's young.
He doesn't know.
So I'm like, all right.
How young?
It's such a crazy thing to say out loud.
Boys will be boys Boy doesn't even say his age How the fuck am I supposed to know How the fuck am I supposed to know Doesn't even say his age
He's no FBI here
I just hope he learns from this He's only 29 Doki I'm very young.
Higher or lower.
He's on me.
But I do hope he learns from it.
I do hope he learns from this experience.
Or just be more careful who you're...
Be more careful.
What you...
Do you think you want to be today?
Now, who am I going to banish from this match?
I'm just saying thank you to my friend who was like, you know, he didn't have...
God was real.
What happened to him?
What?
What do you mean?
What do you mean was?
What?
What happened?
Weapon to God!
He didn't get raptured.
The right heroes could make all the difference.
Alright.
Okay, we have a rocket player.
Alright, I'll go Luna so I can snowflake.
Rocket, the Iron Fist player.
Alright.
Like, I said thank you.
Like, he didn't have to.
Like, um, you know, he didn't have to be, like, messaging a chopper and be like, what the fuck?
But, like, he did that on his own.
So I'm just, like, messaging me, like, yo, thank you.
He didn't have to do that.
I just thought it was really nice of him.
See, that's what I'm saying.
That's what a bro should do.
That's what homie should do.
You have to stop them from securing the mission area.
to god if this guy if they're playing triple also i think dad's hungry now he's like feed me now okay i'll grab food for him later well not lit you guys know what i mean i'm just thinking because i do have like a can of food but um it's like i have a box of it somewhere i'm just trying to remember where i put it it's gonna be a bit awkward because i remember where i put the box
That demands food!
He's hungry!
He's so hungry!
Oh my god.
They're running triple.
A fucking course they are.
The only, the biggest issue about triple support, I said it before, but it's good long term.
It's a long term.
It's really good for long term.
Like, because they just have all the advantage over us.
always because like support all the advantage over us she oh my god was i not getting oh my god i was not i was like how did it jim oh my god he got closer oh my god my dog got closer he's mad he's like outside my door he got closer he's like where's my food woman oh my god he's outside my door That's why he's louder.
What?
Oh no, this is bad.
This is bad.
This is very bad.
We lost him.
This is so bad.
Please, please that.
I'm having...
This is a scary match right now.
No!
Oh my god, yes!
Oh my god, oh my god, bro.
I got hit.
I got hit there.
Glad was distracting me.
Oh, that's so awkward.
I got so distracted by him barking.
I feel bad.
I actually got so distracted.
With him kicking or yapping in my ear.
No, we got him!
I'll die with the team.
You got this, bro.
You got this.
Oh my god, it's so loud.
It's so loud.
I'm so sorry.
I'm so...
Please.
Oh my.
Oh my god, it's so loud.
Oh my god, I can't focus.
Stop!
I'll feed you soon!
Please!
He's next to me!
Stop!
I can't focus!
Oh my god, I have to I actually can't focus right now.
Oh my god.
I can't focus.
He's just...
He keeps barking.
I'm trying my best.
Thanks so much.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Like I said, long term wise, it's just so much better long term.
This is so bad for me.
Oh my god, please stop.
Please.
I'm trying.
Oh my god, I didn't see the mantis.
I can't hear him.
Please, I can't hear.
I can't hear, according to the mantis.
Oh He was barking I'm so sad Please I can't focus at all Oh my god, the play of the game is so loud right now Jesus Christ This sucks, this actually sucks so much This is actually, I'm actually like low-key throwing a little
Okay Jesus Christ is so aggressive.
I'd have to die.
I have to die.
No!
Alright.
Oh, I can't...
Okay, I can speed him between...
Go through heels.
Okay.
Just please.
Please!
I legit...
I can't hear anything!
I can't hear my game!
I like the cold!
We are undefeatable!
Okay, it's fine.
That's fine.
It's okay.
We can't see nine again.
We can't do this again.
We can't see nine again, everyone.
Oh my god.
We can't.
Oh my god, please, he's one.
Please.
Oh my god, where am I?
I can't focus at all.
He's just barking.
Don't worry.
Why are you so hungry?
Why are you so... You get fed the best meals.
bro why are you so hungry we don't have any support else that's the worst part i'm good i'm oh no this is bad
this is so bad god was i can see why i see why he's like god was real
He's just barking in my ear.
I'm trapped.
Okay.
Oh.
Why?
Why did he speak big man?
He threw my two game!
He actually threw by spitting me into the enemy team.
That's crazy.
That's actually crazy that he did that.
Oh my god.
Four, three,
I couldn't do anything.
Oh my god, please.
Please.
Oh my god.
Jesus Christ, this is the longest fight of the century.
It's actually the longest fight right there.
Alright, I can feed him now.
the current score is all right here we go two three time to switch things up including which side you're on i'm luna snow like the moon i shine in darkness you'll need a top-notch team to win this one
round two go oh my god
All I ever wanted to do was sing.
I know he does that.
Um, he got perma-muted.
I know you, Linnie.
I just never expected this whole time stream has to spill over into Quinlan.
That's just the guy that I got muted.
Or out on tour.
Thanks, Saul.
You always help me keep cool under pressure.
Oh, the guy?
That's the same guy we were...
The devs are aware of him.
It's him.
So he got perma muted.
I will not perma, but he got muted.
Yeah, the loser.
Basically, he throws any...
He also throws games if, like, you're on rocket, too.
Like, he's actually just a loser.
That's fine.
I froze somebody.
Oh, that's unlucky.
I don't know.
who I froze.
This all blurs in.
Oh, that's unlucky.
It's just so much damage.
Oh my god.
I'm doing a lot of damage, though.
Alright, I gotta reload.
We can walk on Mantis Hole in a sec.
I just said we can walk on Mantis Hole.
That's unfortunate.
That's unfortunate there.
He didn't say it.
He did say it.
I mean, he did.
He's
still there, Iron Fist.
is he okay is he though I'm just gonna spend just try to heal him
oh my god I'm trying my best oh my god I it's five it's five you know we try judge jury Okay.
There was nothing I could do.
I had no other shield.
That's fine.
Like, it was just, I had to just juke.
He could just heal him.
He could just get me forever.
All right, it's fine.
What?
That- Is he okay?
Over there?
I don't know.
Oh, I don't think he was okay.
I-
Guys, I don't think he was okay.
Alright, it's fine.
Here you go.
He's just gonna eat our mantis.
But he didn't eat our mantis, so...
You know, it's the little things.
All right.
Oh my god, he ate both our tanks, which is a lot worse.
There's nothing we can do.
He ate both our tanks.
Our tanks are like, I don't know, fucking traveling around the world right now.
I would like it if our tanks could have, I guess, died.
I guess.
How long?
I think it's like 15 hours or some shit.
Alright.
I don't know if this is winnable, guys.
Alright, it's fine.
It's okay, though.
Because we do have...
Yay, and then they're gonna be like yummy yummy later right there it is
Here we go Oh, yo
Um, what else was I some Mag Mag Like, mag?
Thank you, Magneto.
Very cool.
Very, very cool mag.
My mag didn't even fucking...
Very cool mag.
Very cool.
Where's my other two supports?
Wait.
Oh!
Okay Where did my other two support skill?
There was no yeah That's I was like mad Uh
Okay, we gotta Can you tell me how I'm truly sorry cap
Sorry, you capped.
That'd be cool if we can dunk on him like they did.
Oh, that's fine.
That'd be cool if they can do the thing that they did to me.
That'd be so cool, you know?
That'd be so cool.
I wish, like, the enemy team went rocket, too.
Wait, actually, didn't he?
No.
Alright, it's fine.
I have ult now.
And then I'm gonna get slam dunked again.
It's okay.
I have ult.
And I can't wait to get slam dunked yet again.
You know, I'm gonna push the cart.
Look at that.
He doesn't...
I'm so excited.
Watch, watch, watch.
Oh, oh.
Oh, it's because he was chasing.
So he didn't slam dunk.
That's crazy.
But one time he didn't slam dunk.
He was too busy chasing.
I was waiting for it too.
I was like, it is here.
The moment true.
The slam dunk.
It's a yummy, yummy time again.
3-11.
We didn't get anything out of that though, which is pretty bad because they're delaying this for a long this dude
Oh my god, I didn't get
Oh my god That's so unlucky No Final score two two three
That's fine Well, you can't expect to win them all Oh, I need to Fill, okay, I gotta do a business Stuff soon, lady That's fine Uh, I'll try my, it's okay Teams Teams just RNG Law Oh, yeah, I have to dodge Cause this guy will throw Um, oh shit, what the fuck I'm gonna avoid Because like He's gonna throw no matter what.
No, throw if he's on my team.
Basically.
All that for plus 12?
Fuck yeah.
That makes me happy knowing that.
That's right.
All that for plus 12.
That's fucking right.
Jesus, minus 24.
Remember when we had this?
Oh, those were good.
Those were good old times.
That is...
plus troll we did not have bro like this sucks look at this like 21 21 19 24 oh wait this is how many oh you guys remember when i said i was gonna be a short stream i can't help it it's so fun i love playing rivals i love rivals rank remember i c2 those are good times i love gatekeeping i love it it's fun gatekeeping is fun wait this guy added me why the What did he add me?
Bro, fuck off.
Oh, this is the Jeff guy.
I think he added me to talk more shit and be like, you must have been the one that muted me.
I'm like, yeah, don't be a fucking asshole.
Don't be...
No, he does.
Why would he randomly add me?
Because that guy was from yesterday.
Oh, fuck off.
Talk shit.
Get hit.
Hey,
that's the good boy.
That's him.
There's no Jeff hovering on our team.
Fan that shit.
That's funny.
You know what's crazy?
That guy, he appears offline too.
So you can't Q-Dodge him.
He purposely appears off that.
The people trying to Q-Dodge.
Look at that!
Are you watching the stream?
Fuck off, buddy.
You see I rejected him and then he instant added back.
Holy unemployment.
Look at that.
That's actually cringe as hell.
He has skull.
I think it's because I got him muted.
I don't know for how long.
Honestly.
I don't know how long he got muted for it.
I just know that the devs were like, oh, we'll look into it for you.
Buddy, you got more soul.
Yeah, buddy.
If I say ignore, you can friend request me for as many times as you want.
That's silly.
That's actually fucking hilarious.
Like, the fact that he, like...
The fact that he fucking sent another one right after.
That's fucking hilarious.
That's actually hilarious.
Which hero do you think you want to be today?
Is in seven hours?
one more hour and then i'll call it it's just fun i don't know i'm having such a fun time
who am i gonna banish from this match i just love playing one rivals and so i can do this for so long i just have a lot of fun and i enjoy your company chat while i do you well it's not doom queue i'm just gatekeeping right now
dooming I'm just gatekeeping that's different yeah
I'm gatekeeping I'm trying to make it so but I'm banning Jeff then I'm gonna do it no please don't Jeff they are enemy team you'll need a top-notch team to win this one no
I'm not the type who fades I'm done playing doing that right now
Oh well I've only had like Oh I have to play this I've only had like I think two Well I had several games But I've also been playing for a streaming for a very long time I've all To be fair I've also been streaming for a while But Um...
I'll do this.
But like, I can play rivals forever.
Until I find another game I can play forever.
It's just something in my brain.
I just like... the grind really just gets to me.
I'm relapsing hard for real.
There's just something about the grind.
Hey pizza!
And like, I'm not tired at all too.
That's the...
That's the weird part.
I'm not tired.
I'm peak cheap one and I saw the emblems of...
What the fuck?
Where did he TP to?
Where are we?
Oh, okay.
I was so confused.
Like, where are we?
Because like...
Would I be like, okay?
Okay.
This TP sucks.
I will say.
This is a fucking weird-ass TP.
This is a weird-ass TP.
I don't even know how.
We won that?
What happened?
Never mind.
Maybe this TP wasn't so bad.
What?
Holy shit!
I spoke too soon.
I got so confused.
Please, he's one.
Please, he's still one.
Oh my god, please.
Maybe he'll eat like...
Okay, there we go.
You always chase it.
Like, it was no cop just figure it out.
That's it.
It's literally figure the shit out.
That's our rule.
We figure it out.
All you're good for is triple sub- What?
Who is he?
Has there been like- Has there been like fucking- What happened?
Oh shit.
I think I live oh I do oh my god I'm so sorry I have to reload I actually have to reload I'm so sorry this is this is winnable this is so winnable come over here come over here we're gonna beat
I'm don't know now now it's a okay well goodbye okay I'm back I don't know what happened but I'm back please I I need I can't I'm so scared rocket you're not healing right there just gotta kill oh Maya
Look at that, I don't hit my- I don't hit that fucking...
Cloak and dagger?
I guess cloak and dagger will work over rocket.
Oh, I'm seeing me.
I can't freeze that.
It was just reflex, honestly.
Hey, I got him.
It was just reflex when I fucking freeze that.
I was like, I see someone.
I try and freeze Okay, we gotta push Yeah, he didn't think that through
Don't worry Serious and stupid Stupid whore That's not a good boy The vehicle reached a checkpoint keep up the momentum
All right, all right, oh wait, we have Dracula Oh, bro, I don't know I'm sorry, I can't I really don't think I could heal through that Sorry, bro I would love to be able to heal through that But I don't think so That It's very unfortunate.
That's...
Oh.
Oh, man.
That's...
Wait, what cancel my TP?
Our...
Oh.
Oh, our poor, that poor is strange.
I don't think that's what he wanted to happen, guys.
I have a feeling that I had a feeling that that was an accident.
Stupid champ.
The worst part is that he's an ace, too.
That's the worst part.
I'm Luna Snow.
Like the moon, I shine in darkness.
The right heroes could make all the difference.
You see how hard I'm rage baiting their DPS?
Like they're just going to continue to do bad.
See, this is N.A.
Toxicity right here.
Literally using like rage bait as a strat.
He's trying to tilt the other team higher in it.
That's so smart!
Wait, that's so NA.
Only NA people would fucking think of that shit as that...
Only NA people would fucking... It worked so...
Okay, fake tactics.
Thank God I'm not a league player.
I think I'm not a league player.
would actually be so fucking depressed i'm sorry sorry to all the league players i i literally think i'd be so depressed no she's right depressed and full of eight because i know like league is like a whole new level like this talk this is like like the stuff you hear in rival It's like baby shit.
Oh, shit, nice.
Yoink.
It's like advanced toxicity right there.
Oh, they're going scarlet.
Oh, it's over.
He did it.
They're doing it.
Oh, yeah.
No, I know, like, because League toxicity was so bad.
that they started to like like you can get chat bad like instantly or like it's why they don't have voice chat it's literally the reason why they don't have vc because that's how bad the toxicity is
jesus christ yeah it's like and so then people now have people have done like there's like i don't know okay do you guys know any like professional um shit talk in league you guys know like what do you guys say now to get past the filters I was told the one I know was keep yourself safe that's the one I know that's the classic yeah people just say jump holy fuck
crazy go learn learn how to tie dots holy fuck that's what i'm saying i'm not fucking leave player i feel like i'm so happy yeah yeah What?
It didn't kill?
This one, I got another chance.
Got it.
Your mother?
Jesus Christ!
Oh my god.
I quit Link because it was making me a worse human.
That's what I'm saying!
It's like, it's more like, um, How come you never try League or Mova and shit like that?
And I'm like, bro, I...
I already...
I don't want to be even more depressed, bro.
I already know the shit that goes on.
I'm dead.
Goodbye, cruel world.
Okay, that's on me.
That's on me.
I don't think I lost any point.
We got it.
Oh my god, your mother's shot.
The jump one is my...
The jump is actually crazy.
Because you can't be toxic.
You can't...
You can't be, like, toxic and legal.
You get insta-bad now.
So they're like...
They have to...
Because that's how bad...
That's how bad the problem is.
Alright.
all right
oh my god how are oh my we're doing everything we can let's see we're doing everything we can to fix him him
i'm trying to keep our cloak alive jesus christ what the fuck what the fuck where did he come from oh shit my lily Oh my god, her dead body is keeping him in the human world!
Her dead body gets him constrained!
Did you see that?
She was dead and he was still tied to her dead body!
That's so fucked up!
That's Ashley.
He couldn't leave.
He's chained to her.
for like all of eternity
Actually crazy Don't worry There's that one heal that'll change.
Okay, he's dead I was like don't worry.
There's one heal A lair heal I have all anyway Bro, what the fuck they're still following.
Oh my god, bro.
What is going on?
Okay, so I We're following you all the way back to I'm gonna put it on him just in case
Alright What
I'm I'm I'm looking forward I'm looking back I oh he died He actually died like What happened?
What is going on?
Oh my goodbye everyone It was nice.
Nope.
Hello everybody.
Hello my cloak is fighting guys my cloak has is fighting for her life right now and i'm pretty sure he's been they've definitely been fighting for 20 years i like how i was the only one that has noticed this cloak versus emma 1v1 did you guys see that cloak versus emma 1v1 on the sidelines there like and my entire team ignored it.
It was crazy.
I was not expecting that.
Another epic victory.
She was fighting for her life.
Your team wanted to respect the 1v1.
Yeah.
Plus 15?
What are these lobbies?
Actually, what are these lollabies?
Who's Isaac?
I got a game with Isaac?
What the fuck is Isaac?
Damn, this is rough.
Is it because, like, okay, what's the Elo?
Ah, Isaac.
Wait, there's three GM players.
That's rough.
That's actually rough.
That's...
see Celestia.
So I'm like, did we got a game with it?
I won't be late.
Chat.
I'll be on time.
Don't worry.
No worries.
Be happy.
I heard that apparently yours don't get enough rank points.
Yeah, they don't.
I talked about it before.
But it's all about it's all about damage done.
final hits and um it's it relies on your damage done and final hits mostly they calculated off of that so you don't do enough damage and you don't do enough final hits you don't get a lot of um you don't get a lot of rank points or rank points which is very dumb very stupid not that fun should i avoid people i believe in you
you avoid if you have to i believe yeah that's why dps would get like 20 to 20 like 20 to 25 points and then um and then uh support players would get like 18 to 22 if they're lucky oh yeah let me see
okay i understand thank you for thank you for saying sorry because it made me angie
there you go angie is an understatement but also he really needs but also if he's going to shit talk Make sure he doesn't shit.
I was like, if he's going to shit talk, make sure he knows it's not someone that's streaming right now.
Or just shit talk to your friend, not your fucking matchat.
Oh yeah, that's true.
Tell him to use Google Translate first and say it to my face.
If he's going to shit talk, say it to my face and don't hide behind another language.
jump short simple and effective that's what i'm saying league is league lead players are so creative with their talk because they don't want to get bad because you know league accounts are like they like have league accounts for years like like maybe like decades and stuff so they're super careful and making sure they don't get bad but they can also get they But they still want to shit talk because it's the league way.
They're like veterans.
It's like baby shit.
If they see like Marvel, Rival, shit talk or like anything else, they're just like.
They're just like, that shit's for fucking babies.
But then I'm baby though.
I'm baby.
I'm very emotional baby.
I played one league game and I...
Oh, for those who never heard the story before, I played one league game.
and then i i with my friends like they forced me to try league with my um and then i and then i pretend i i like um i right click close game and then i left the call and then i like got back on like 10 minutes later and was like oh i'm so sorry my internet
It was fun!
It was so... It was miserable.
I was just like, I'm sorry, my internet, you see, did you guys win?
And I was like, no, we didn't win.
I'm like, oh, I'm so sorry.
Oh, I'm so sorry.
I'm too.
Do you think you want to be here?
banish from this match they don't know all
right i don't know uh it's birch oh phoenix fuck sorry
i've done similar but with dodging cues ultra honor jeff banning jeff jeff time yo Fuck Jeff!
Yeah!
Don't fuck Jeff, but fuck Jeff!
That's how much I do like League.
Oh, I've been streaming.
I must have almost been 10 hours.
Oh my gosh, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
I can't help it.
It's just so fun.
Okay.
Alright.
I'm ready.
There's so much new now.
I just want to play invisible woman.
Get ready.
Armor patch here.
Pay up.
Thor.
We're going to need a little Asgardian muscle.
little
We have demons to slay what are we waiting for?
All right, let's go No, I was just looking at a message real quick I told you I can only endurance stream when it's rivals or when I play ring I just I don't know it just keeps me going It just makes me want to play as long as i can and it just makes brings me joy that i'm denying top 500 for people it just makes me so happy i just realized we are tank front line is um all right we have a very cooking bagger as well also have oh no we have to deal with magic oh no getting rid of squids this looks like you sucked oh my god
no don't no no no why did you all right you know what that means Do you know what that means?
Oh, this is very unfortunate indeed.
It's just I see my rocket die away and then I can't do anything about- I'm like, I'm- ooh, I'm tempted to go Animal Crossing just so that magic can't do anything.
Oh, that's... that's bad.
Bro, um...
Like, I don't know.
This might be... this might be GG's.
This might not be a... this might not be a game.
I hear ya.
Oh, he put his shield back.
Oh my god.
Alright, let's try.
Oh my god, I just want him to be alive.
Sucks.
I had to use that because I just didn't want to die.
I am ready to put on a show.
Alright, that's fine.
Nice.
Oh my god!
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
It wasn't too much.
Oh wait.
He was so far.
Thank god.
Look at your magic.
Magic on a rocket.
You're fine.
But I would like to also get healed.
That would be pretty cool.
It's like we won that round when I use my luck magic just saying Just saying I did win my I did win the we did render round without I and I am I am seeing So, oh my
Thank you, I'm just trying to stabilize for a little bit, but help a bucky help a bucky So I'm trying my bet oh my god bro I'm try my best to do that I'm holy shit oh it's so unlucky table I stabilize I can see on point if you need it don't get off the needle I gotta make another beacon Bridges one.
Nice.
Hey, look at the more.
The more one.
Okay.
All right.
Look at those daggers.
Look at that guy.
He's one.
All right, it's fine.
Everyone, look at Emma.
Natica?
Yes, she's one.
She's still low?
This is so stressful.
Oh, I wanted that pull.
Oh, my God.
That TP!
It's fine.
Everything is fine.
We love.
We love it here.
Everything is fine.
Everybody is safe.
I feel like, honestly, like, these games are getting, like, harder.
Please tell me there's red.
What happened?
Oh, thank god we're even.
Okay.
Oh, we're no longer even.
Oh, this is bad.
What hit me?
Wait, what fucking hit me?
I don't even know.
Luna dead.
That's huge.
It's huge.
thing is I don't even know what hit in me that's the messed up part
oh my god oh my god I just got I just got back in time we're looking at we're looking at look at how much he won look at strange on point he's out he's out please look at strange strange one don't don't go through portal that's There's one.
Who are we looking at?
Nobody.
He's like talking to himself.
We have to make sure they don't touch.
This is enough time where we just get points.
Don't let anyone touch.
I think they can touch.
Oh, yeah!
Yay!
Oh.
Bro, like, he's like, who are we getting?
And he's like, the one guy that's talking.
No one has said anything.
It's like, who are we getting, guys?
That's fine.
I'm going to play Bucky now.
He's he comes.
Yeah, I know.
A plus, he wants that rank, bro.
He's passionate.
He's actually passionate.
I'm getting you.
I thought we were supposed to be on the same side, Frank.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
Whoa, what the fuck I keep forgetting he does that
Are you streamer at 4?
I
Oh Yeah, there's we're not with.
Oh my god, I can't be here.
I'm sorry Rock.
Oh my god.
It's so loud Poor It's clear I'm still needed here.
Holy shit shit
My job here is done goodbye my fellow americans my
He's oral walk My job here is done farewell oh seven
Americans!
Okay.
Magic, rocket, Luna, they're all up top right so I can hear you.
Luna 1, Luna's on.
Okay.
I would like to heal these people too.
The worst part is I see the venom.
Like, stalking us right now.
Lay.
Don't worry, bro.
I got you, bro.
I got you.
Oh, my God.
Does anyone still got me?
I got you, bro.
Bro!
Oh, my God.
I walked so far.
I would be the one to get raised.
It's okay.
They don't- oh, we might not be- Yay!
The hitbox was crazy.
Yeah, the Canadian debuff right there.
She was like, wait a minute, you're not American!
He deserved that win.
God bless America.
that's my captain America oh is he barking now huh plus seven Jesus Christ I feel I'm on an uphill battle right now with life I swear here we go again guys all right give me a sec I'll be back for dad all
right I'm back you wanted his Water refilled.
No, it's not walkies time.
It's not walkies.
I know when it's walkies time.
I'll make it.
It's fine.
I can do it.
Also, have I like unlocked?
Oh, I haven't unlocked anything yet?
Oh my god, I played so much rocket.
Oh no.
I'm so close.
to the lord i got oh no i'm almost there that's so many people oh hey there's jared oh wait this is like riggs he's friend that tried i'll add it i'll add him just because like i tried to steal him what the oh he got the all right do we add this guy this random guy because this guy was like can i play with you and also this is not also this wasn't the other guy this was a what's his name
um the pro player i'm just collecting players right now yeah this is the jeff player the guy to have my stream open on the side
yeah the guy was like who's a good boy adam he's a good boy okay but how
oh he hit his statistic key all right i'll add you if you public your if you make your profile if you make your history public i want to see i'll only add you you put that to public okay i want to see
I want to see Good boys go public I say with my fucking mega private profile That even friends can access I only do that because I don't like I only do that because I don't like people Using my trackers It's like the only way to To stop people tracking
Okay That's the only reason.
I don't do it for any other reason.
Alright.
Do you think they'll ban Torch, though?
Do you think they're gonna do it?
Also, we have three tank players.
I just don't like people stalking my trackers and stuff.
It's...
It's just, like, personal preference.
You'll need a top-notch team to win this one.
Yeah, only I can stalk people.
That's different.
Only I'm allowed to stop.
So bitch.
It's my streamer privilege.
I demand streamer privilege and that means I can stop.
30 seconds.
So when others hide their pro- Yes!
Exactly.
They're cowards.
I have an excuse, I'm a streamer.
If I wasn't a streamer, if I wasn't a streamer, I would have it public.
That's all I'm saying.
And true, it's true!
It's true.
I swear to guys.
I...
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
Let's do it with.
Bro, he's just...
Mario around right now.
That'll be fine, right?
That'll be fine.
They don't need me.
I think they might need me.
Everybody needs a hand.
All right.
Wait, where is the...
Wait a minute, where are you?
Where is the... Oh my god!
Where is he?
I was fine.
I'm scared.
I don't know where he is.
It's like he's just He's just flying.
Oh my god
Bro, like what is he doing?
He's just jumping around he's fucking around the around the world around the okay It worked though.
It actually worked He went around the world That's so oh my god, I hear him be strong together i hear him
all right are they trip okay they're not they're not triple support though that's thank god i might just go rocket honestly against this because they're it's like they have hulk and they have um or in this i guess it's just because of this guy this guy I kept thinking it.
Alright, I only went Luna for the Iron Fist, but this is way too much.
Oh my god, I missed it.
I actually missed it.
Oh, this is unlucky.
Goodbye.
Oh, wait, he went Rocket.
Fuck.
Okay, I'm all in this walk.
I thought I was swapped in this woman, I guess.
Someone needs to mark the way.
He's gonna run the fucking lobby.
No one looks it up.
I was worried.
Mark the what?
I didn't hear what he said.
Okay.
I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm really trying to heal you.
I don't want to waste my all-up for this Like I'm trying to like get a fight going in But we keep getting picked so I can't get a fight in And which is pretty, which sucks a lot Guys, this sucks a lot Sort of sucks, guys Oh my god, it went all the way back here
Oh my god, are you serious?
It sucks the one time I can use my all and everybody's still dead
Jesus Christ Oh my god, please I'm trying so hard to keep you up.
I really am
It's just unlucky
Oh our bucky do something Our Bucky is getting hard but bullied right now.
CQ, that's Gomez's teammate.
Yeah, I'm not going, Luna.
I wanted to swap off earlier.
But, like, it was so hard.
Everyone just kept getting picked.
I don't know.
Everyone just kept getting picked and everything.
Wait, geez.
What?
It's him.
Who's him?
Tokyo map.
What?
Oh,
it's that same Bucky.
Oh!
I see.
Oh.
That's unfortunate.
Wait, where's my teammate?
Wait, where did she go?
Okay.
Like, where's my, where are my teammates?
Wait.
Where is my, that's like, where did everybody go?
I was so confused.
I just, I think it's just EOMM giveth and EO miveth.
have to take it i i there's nothing there's nothing i could do there's bro it's with my team like did you see what our luna our luna just let the hog beat him up yeah no this um okay okay i'll avoid fuck you at
least this was 24 bro Go on, go on, fix this.
All right, let's...
Is this guy?
I mean, he's very...
Bro, he's...
Wait, what?
Bro, Eternity 56 was his highest, and he has...
Bro, it's not...
What?
How?
How did you get here?
Oh, thank God.
Okay, we're taking him down with us.
Thank God.
He was trying to secure it.
He was almost there.
Guys, I'll let you know right now.
He was one game away from securing it.
Oh, thank God we brought him down.
Oh, thank God.
Thank God.
He was like one.
I think, I'm pretty sure he's like one game off.
Another gate has been kept.
Who is this guy?
Alright, let's see.
Did he open his history?
No.
I think he stopped watching, honestly.
He was almost You shall not pass!
I will not let you become top 500.
If it's the last thing I do.
I have a I might have a sponsor stream later.
but that's not gonna stop me from ELO terrorizing.
The gatekeeping is working.
They think I'd stop, but I didn't.
No one is safe from me.
All right, it's time to, it's time to role play.
It's role play time.
Hello.
Oh, hello.
Hello, Jeff.
Would you like a show?
Yeah.
Bum, bum, bum, bum, bum.
You guys enjoy the show?
Bum, bum, bum, bum.
What?
He went with his goddamn kicks.
Bum, bum, bum.
Bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum.
They're dancing with me.
Oh my god, look at these.
Where are they gonna take me?
Where are these chefs?
Whoa!
Oh, goodbye, my little chefs!
Goodbye.
Stupid, sexy mantis dancing.
They're taking me to the back alley to shoot, Jesus Christ.
I'm not the type who fades quietly into the background.
Guys, remember when I said I wasn't going to stream for long?
I can't help it!
Ah!
I'm having so much fun, though.
I'm having a lot of fun.
I don't mean you guys are having fun, except for when I crash out.
But I hope you guys are having fun during my non-crash out moments.
I can stop whenever I want.
Also, it's because I'll be gone for so long.
I feel really bad.
I'm, like, taking a lot of days off.
Because, you know, in the past, I would just stream.
Like, I was a streaming monster.
But, like...
And I'll be gone for a while, too.
I'm going to be on a business trip.
No, I'll be gone from...
I'll be gone from...
From...
Friday to Tuesday.
I'll be back to streaming on Wednesday.
So that's why I'm like, I'm not going to be at TwitchCon.
I know people are wondering about me at TwitchCon.
It's not TwitchCon.
Oh, we forgot to ban stuff.
Fucking hell yeah.
But because of that, that's why I'm streaming long today.
It's like, I'm gonna miss you guys.
I shine in darkness.
Yeah, I love streaming for you guys.
I feel bad, but like...
I invaded it, but...
Um...
Oh my gosh!
I'm also gonna meet someone, too.
I usually don't meet other V2 varies, but during this business trip, I'm gonna like meet up with somebody.
So it's like gonna be really exciting, too.
Yeah!
It's gonna be someone new.
I've never met up with it before.
I also haven't met up with people before, too.
I think like the only, it's very rare.
So, so it's gonna be pretty exciting.
It's not TwitchCon.
I know people were wondering.
Not TwitchCon.
I don't know how we're gonna come up with it.
I'm scared.
There's a hello.
I'm playing underneath now too.
Bro, fuck the hog round.
Hi guys, for losers!
Oh my god!
You're okay, you're okay!
I don't know.
I can go without.
Can we get back?
Yeah, yeah, I'm ready, ready.
So fast.
It's I've been streaming for 10 hours.
I don't know what's going on You're talking so fast with that what's happening?
I did not have a I didn't not oh I was gonna sit oh no no no goodbye Oh my Don't let her get close to me Don't let it...
Oh!
Oh my
god.
My best just left me!
I...
She just ran away!
She's like, it's...
She's your problem.
Bro, she actually went...
That's your problem.
Oh, fuck.
That's crazy.
I can't believe she just left me like...
Oh, that's unlucky.
Oh,
whoa, why are you barking?
Oh, wow!
She warned you.
This is bad because we used both alts for that.
I'm not a defensive alts now.
I don't know, I was gonna go first.
Well, they have Punisher, like, so good luck to them.
us pork pork why are you barking you had food oh wait we have captain america follow the american flag okay i don't know if that's gonna keep I I I'm so scared all right Guys are we okay goodbye everybody
Oh my god, please not again, please not again, please I can't focus I'm gonna close the door on here
All right, it'll be more muffled.
It'll be more muffled.
Yeah, the American flag did not stop.
It does not stop punishing.
Very unfortunate.
Who would have thought?
It's okay.
Clap, clap, clap, clap, clap, clap, clap, clap, clap.
Clap, clap, clap, clap, clap, clap.
that oh i hope he will live tap tap tap goodbye i
came back to help my never help i came back to help my mantis why did i do that can you guys support so i can go tank Okay Okay, we got we got it for like five five four three two Goodbye Goodbye
Oh my god
No, we're not we're not trying to aim for top 500 chat We're here to For those who are still wondering, I haven't been playing to try and get top 500.
I've just been playing the gate heat.
Do not worry.
This is not about aiming for top 500.
This is just about trying to make sure other people won't get it.
Because I know Zcube's trying to.
Hey,
can I...
Oh, thank you.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I'm trying so hard.
It's okay.
Everything is fine.
Don't talk, don't talk.
Jesus Christ!
What is this fight?
I that has not been a new goal well it has been you close than just yesterday but you know what I mean That's right gaslight gig keep Nobody deserves top 500
No one deserves it
Oh, that killed nothing.
Alright, well, we're sort of alive.
Jesus Christ.
That's so...
Oh my god.
I am ready to put on a show.
I guess we...
Alright, here we go.
I was fine, but thank you.
That was scary.
That threw one counting for myself.
I hate triple support.
so much i hate triple support i i hate oh my god how
i swear to god triple support is so boring
again god it's such a boring fucking cop This cop fucking sucks At the playing game said I played triple sword at the Jesus Christ Alright you can build support
Nice Bullshit stupid ass cop Fucking boring ass Oh yeah They're gonna make it
They're like, they're gonna TP, he's gonna make it.
I'm like, nope.
Got him.
Wait, is this Chenzin?
I shine in darkness.
Got him.
Your torch.
Yeah.
Keeping 101.
Yes, I am.
Okay.
Ooh.
Oh, these pros recognize each other.
I'm like, who is that guy?
Why Z8 dance?
Because Z8 for life.
What did he say he is?
Chenzo?
What is that?
Who's Chenzo?
What team is he on?
30 seconds before you attack.
Get ready.
the days when i'm glad we left new york for cocoa
he's in the la sure i know you guys know someone someone knows who chenzo is who's chenzo the battle starts in five four three two one put up there is he on a team or is just a rank rider
Yeah, I'm healing.
I'm healing.
Clap.
Oh my god.
Okay, this is a little getting a little scary now.
This is, this might be getting a little scary now.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Well, I don't have a lot of claps, guys.
Whoa.
Clap, clap, clap, clap, clap, clap, clap, clap, clap, clap.
Oh my god, everyone's taking so much damage Yay triple support I gotta Clap clap clap Is she high?
No, I'm just playing support It's just just support life, you know It's just the way it does Will we be five?
Oh my god, we would not be five Okay Oh no Oh no, he doesn't know Oh no, this is bad This is bad, this is so bad Clap, clap, clap Clap, clap Oh my god, wait, he's behind us
okay i did not expect him to be but oh my god not the tp you guys have no supports right now or you only have ultron i was not expecting like uh i was not expecting
bro that's guy i really wanted to kill the door i'm just looking at the torch trying to kill her ultron but he i think he missed every Yeah, I'll take her.
This is crazy.
You miss every shot.
Get, get, get, clap, clap, get, get, get, clap, get, get.
Oh, he's on, oh wait, he's on Rocky Raccoon now.
What the fuck is this triple support?
There's some weird ass triple support right there.
Oh, shit, that's right.
Gonna start damaging.
clap running away running away what the fuck how did I get up here we can maybe kill him one we didn't kill him guys oh my god oh my god it's okay I've clapped soon I've clapped soon guys clap clap get get kept clap clap oh god we got run We got run
Okay, I did try I Did try Oh my gosh, I'm trying so hard to keep him alive I really am.
Oh my god.
Oh no, not the...
Oh my god, it's Jitward on Spider-Man.
Wait, they got out of triple support, though.
It's okay.
It's just...
They're not running triple support.
It's okay.
We can out-rotate.
We just need to out-rotate the ults and also, like, don't die to Spider-Man.
It's just that easy.
Very simple instructions.
I'm pretty sure that we can follow.
Very easy.
There we go.
Just three, one very simple roll.
Oh, nice.
It's broken?
I have, I've broken it.
I'm in the back corner.
Please tell me he's okay.
Please tell me.
Okay, he's okay.
He's okay.
I have to look back.
So I'm glad he's okay.
He's for sure.
Because we have to kill Max.
Got you, Spider-Man!
I mean, I mean, Ultron!
I'm not playing for the other side!
Okay.
I'm in Ultron!
point keep up the momentum here we go wrong team oh wait i should i'll push the card a little bit just a little bit i think mantis is better for it because i have rage then she can you know do her Oh my god
Wrong one.
I'm a nut.
That's right Not me.
Wait, wait, wait, what?
Wait, wait, what?
He's you told me you got him He told me she got him That's a little bit Not gonna lie That was a little embarrassing
Whoa It was I got scammed.
I really did These scammed me
Okay, I got one shot.
Oh my god.
Okay that That's very unfortunate.
That's very I'm not using else here that's actually so unfortunate i'm juggling snowflakes right now i'm juggling snowflakes so hard right now okay now i can put it back on ultra please we have we have two fights left technically if we can support up all right yeah
spider is no longer one Oh He's I can't see I think I have to play actually can't oh we have ultra guys I don't think we're winning this anymore.
We've been stuck in this choke for 20 years and we still haven't killed that goddamn spider-man They said they would kill him
I was told you would kill the spider-man
Oh, I'm scared Come on, back on, back on, back on Back on, back on Oh my god Luna, Luna, Luna No!
No!
Please!
Please, they keep messing with him!
One shot, one shot, sorry.
One shot, close.
Okay, nice.
Good week, good week, Magwan.
Don't worry!
The rest is close!
You're on your point, you're on your point, we'll do it.
We're keeping him.
The rest is close by!
That's what Jonah never said before.
god please don't see that oh my god i'm so scared i'm so joshua please joshua please we're gonna poke all soon kill point kill point kill point kill point joshua please don't die look one please yay the rocket straddle always works!
The rocket strap always works!
Yay!
Every... I swear to God, I feel like my rocket win rate has to be so high now because I always swap rocket at the last moment.
Oh my god, plus 18 for the hell they put me in.
Alright, let's i need a check oh my absolute hell as always all right never mind it's not as high 18 out of ah it's all right never mind i guess they don't count it if i like play him for a little bit thank you for the win
oh wait okay give me a sec i gotta uh
Wait, I told...
Okay, it's like related to the business trip thing.
They're asking information about stuff.
Where is it?
Where the fuck is it?
Alright, sorry.
Sorry, I had to...
It was just a business stuff.
Okay.
I'm bedtime trying, but Guan Guan hates you.
Oh, I'm not trying for you.
anything la i'm just playing to play but have a good sleep guan guan hates me
okay goodbye bro he's like i'm trying but i think guan guan hates you i'm like what i'm not even trying
Quan Quan hates me Bro, I'm not even trying for top 500 I was just playing the play
I do this for free Exactly Exactly I mean wait Is he close or is he not close Oh she's trying to secure it right now What is he even playing with Oh is he playing with Navi Yeah he He's, yeah, he's trying to secure it right now.
Oh my god, bro, he's saving his life right now.
He's actually saving his life.
No, he's actually trying so hard.
What in this, this guy?
Oh, he's private profile.
Who are you?
Unprivate right now.
Why?
Bro, is that, wait, did he, did he unpublish it?
No, he didn't.
I'm pretty sure you just stop watching after.
I can't.
He's actually trying.
He's actually trying to get it.
Oh, Rocket!
Thank you for the raid!
Thank you!
Yeah.
We played...
I don't even know how long we played with Rocket.
Oh, we dragged now?
I have no one to drag down with me, unfortunately.
Unfortunately, there's no one here to drag down with us to the pits of hell.
Ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha!
It's just us.
Yeah, thanks for playing, Rocket.
It was a random invite.
I had fun.
Oh, I do like you make him shake.
You know what?
I need some bathroom, Manny.
Whoa.
I'll be right back.
I gotta use the bathroom.
I'm back.
Oh, these keys are getting longer.
I don't understand.
Aren't real people waking up now?
We're the real players that are waking up now.
I should have done this longer.
No, I should have done this earlier, not longer.
I should have done this earlier.
It's been fun.
It's just... I don't know.
I'm just enjoying, like...
I'm not griefing, but like...
It just brings me joy.
When... I swear, end of season?
Also, like, end of season?
People are like, so...
So toxic.
Wait, why can't I play on the beach ball?
This is discrimination.
Jeff should be... Oh, wait.
Jeff should be allowed.
Uh...
Hello.
Hey.
What?
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Come on, pet me.
Yeah!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, come on, come on,
you know what I want, oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, she knows, she knows what I wanted to do, she won't let me.
She's in the corner now!
She's in the corner!
And she's following an HR complete!
Sniff-buff, sniff-buff.
Whoa!
That's her little private show.
and I'm the dog.
I like how she was actively making sure I don't look.
I was like, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
She does.
She fucking does.
Oh, look, God was real.
It's him again.
Who knows what I am?
I'm a Dragoon.
I don't know.
Yeah.
Sorry, I read to read.
I zoned out because I got a message about the sponsor today.
So I was like reading through it.
And I'm like, what?
I didn't like, my brain didn't die.
I had to, oh my God, my team didn't ban anything.
I look away for one second.
I had to read.
a business message for one second For one fucking second and then we didn't ban anything
Oh, okay, so basically we get we got early access for like not early access, but we can download the game Go that for
But it's like Basically we can download it now But we can't Obviously we can't show anything You know We can't No it's for Little Nightmare Street We can download the game right now But obviously we can't show anything Was that Smash from Dark Zero?
The Dark Zero is Smash right?
Control He's apparently a controller player That plays like Star Lord and shit The battle starts in 5 which is crazy like aiming a controller against other like mouse and keyboard players because there's no actual aim assist right for controller players and rivals
why am i just friend him and be like you want duo just randomly because i'm pretty sure he's trying for top five maybe he is trying for top 500.
Oh my god, I'm gonna have to play Rocket too.
Actually, nah, that's fine.
But oh his ass.
My god, he's crazy.
Crazy, buddy.
I have to look away for one.
Hello.
Yay, Ultron!
Yay!
Wait, who?
Who got?
Don't worry, Jeff!
I got you!
That's so that's what a wild thing to say You see Actually crazy thing to say Bro he's all Yummy yummy Did we kill anything?
Bro, we didn't do anything.
Why did we even do shit?
Bro, we actually didn't do shit for that.
Hello.
How?
Please tell me.
Bro.
He fucking did it too early.
He did it too early, man.
That's sad.
That makes me sad.
That makes me so sad.
We still have a Spider-Man?
Oh my god, yeah, of course they still have a spider-man leg.
Oh, good.
Because it's working.
If it's working, why swap up?
Okay, it's fine.
You see, here's how he shoots, he's doing it.
Okay, I'm trying to make sure.
sure um do you guys know where he is because i don't oh there he is
wait how many did he get again all right nice i oh he jumped off oh where's the spider man oh there's the spider man again I hope he gets ult soon.
God, I need a grab ult too.
Hello, guys.
Oh, my God.
Aimed at two, though.
Hello.
Can you spare me some ult charge?
Some little itsy-bitty ult charge.
God, I'm so scared of getting...
Oh, my God.
I'm okay.
Yeah.
Not yet.
This is bad.
We double support all of it.
Damn.
I thought me.
Me at.
You know, that, you know, because like you think that.
It's like I'm saying you wouldn't please let me die.
Just stop.
I just want to die.
Just let, you know, Just all The ultrano isn't gonna save me from It's not gonna save me from oh my gosh.
Okay.
Oh my gosh a spy mask and a fucking Spy
You know what time is it is what
Do you know what time it is
Oh, this is bad.
I can wait as far as I could.
This was as far as I could.
Oh, shit.
Look at him.
Go!
Okay, it's fine.
Smash is still alive.
It's okay.
The shark and the shark.
not coming back.
We have Riz right here in the middle of the point.
It'll still work, though, I swear.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, we're keeping you alive, Smash.
You go, Smash.
You go!
I'm training for you!
And that was all I'm going to use it.
Well, how about all that rocket smack talk for a few months ago, they made her meta, unfortunately.
Because they nerfed Loki.
So his res is too good now.
They nerfed Loki.
So people realize, wait, if it's endgame, you play Rocket, and then you play Rocket when it's overtime, so you can give an extra res, and then you can just hide in the back and just start healing.
That's literally it.
This guy playing Starlord lets guys up.
I'm going to stay on Rocket.
Fucking stupid.
I'm going to swap off later.
After I'm used to my up.
I still don't respect them.
Who said I still respect raccoon players?
I play raccoon when I have dude he's not gonna hook me i'm safe look at me i'm so safe
there you go oh he doesn't know there you go one five oh that's fine watch this he got res did you see that Yeah, res.
Oh!
There you go.
Hello.
Goodbye.
Game changer.
Exactly.
And then I can stay up here.
Did you see that?
Look, this is why.
I don't know why.
And then they made him even, they're gonna make him even stronger next to him.
patch that's the that's the worst part oh oh shit we're all dead all right now and then okay i'll say rocket you don't have to play shark bro you ain't got rid of me yet or rocket i bro i went it was overtime i had all i won't say that What do you mean?
It was overtime and I wasn't gonna fucking ditch.
We got point because of it, though.
Okay, now I'm definitely not adding him.
Not like he's gonna accept it anyway.
But like, look, I'm not gonna add him now.
Why don't you follow that?
Yeah, now...
Now it's too late.
Oh, nice, I did it.
I don't even think he would have accepted.
He'd be like, well, fuck this bitch.
I'm said whore.
I'm so used to using that as an insult now.
There you go.
Bro, I...
Bro, you're a pro!
Bro, I'm disappointed.
in it don't mess with the amazing spider-man i'm not gonna live that
bro he's gonna swim he's just gonna swing out bro are you bro are you stupid are you i'm okay okay like does he not know how spider-man works
He's a...
That was interesting.
Does he know?
I was like, bro, the Spider-Man is...
He is swing his goddamn web.
That's the whole point.
He's Spider-Man!
All right.
Mag?
Okay, he like almost missed, but that's...
Oh, okay, I was gonna say it.
How did he miss?
Alright.
That's gonna be a bit worried at him missing that.
But that's okay.
He bubbled, so it makes sense.
Oh my god, he aren't...
I don't know if I live this at all.
No, he got Reese.
Oh, wait, he's dead.
It's okay.
We're coming over.
He's coming over.
We're coming over, too.
Yay!
Sand down.
Okay, nice.
Yay!
Goodbye.
Oh My god, not yay.
What I did not hear in fucking Jesus Christ.
Okay, I'm gonna say I did not hear Hear that all that scared a shit out of me.
I was not ready for it
Oh my god, it never stopped never fucking stops like it just keep oh my god It just keeps going it Just Is he no?
Okay.
It's fine.
I'm helping.
It's okay.
We're still okay.
She should die, right?
If...
Like...
Technically, she should die, right?
I'm just, I'm like, bro, I, I fucking damage boosted the Ultron ult and also the venom fucking pounding the invisible woman.
Like, I'm like, how is she alive?
Like, how much, how much HP does she have?
she's taking words she should not have been alive it was a full-on damage boost oh my god i'm scared i don't want to play in smash he literally he has the most he has the most damage as ultron because i'm scared he actually has the most ko's in the match Bro,
I don't want to play against Smash.
Actually, how much did he gain?
Oh, he does.
He must have it hidden, too.
That's usually what pro players do.
They hide their...
They hide their thing.
Oh, he does it.
Oh, he must...
Maybe he doesn't...
How much did he gain?
Plus 18.
Yay!
I like that.
Wait.
We're just the same.
and I.
Wait, what about God was real?
Wait, what did they get?
Actually, I'm curious.
Plus 22.
Okay, he's a GM player.
Okay, that makes sense.
I was gonna say plus 22.
Oh, he's not secure.
He's not secure.
Oh, to be fair, he's been screaming.
I'm saying he's not top 500 secure.
I don't actually do Do I avoid the Spider-Man?
I don't even know if he did anything.
Nine final hits.
13.
I mean, 13.
Is he mostly?
Yeah, I'm avoiding him.
No, he was rude!
He was like, why are you on rocket?
Okay, he wasn't rude.
He was just commenting.
But that...
That made me sad.
I don't think he knows who I am, too.
I don't think he'd be like, who the fuck is this bitch out of me randomly?
I'm like, it was because like, it was over.
It was overtime.
And I went rocket for the rest.
And then I had alt.
And I wanted to use the alt before I swap.
And it's like that.
It's not.
like why was still on rock i'm like i just wanted to use my
arm he actually he's still doing it that's crazy bro how much of a grudge do you have to be muted like actually how big of a grudge is is it right now to fucking be muted
just don't be a toxic asshole in game and you won't I didn't have to be muted.
Just create, if you really want to talk, create another account.
Unless that is your main account.
Like, it's so easy.
If you're muted, just fucking play on an alt account.
At least you're not muted on an alt account.
It's just that easy.
Why are you so mad?
It's been, you did this to yourself, bro.
Like, like, actually, bro, you did this to yourself.
Why are you mad?
That's IP.
I don't think, I don't think Marvite Rivals has that.
I think you have to commit multiple, um, oh, is he the Jeff good boy?
Where is he?
I'm the Jeff good boy.
Yeah, I'm private your profile, and they'll accept you.
That's the only requirement.
Lunar, thank you for the 100 biddies.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm private now.
I want to see you.
I'm private yourself right now.
These are so long now.
I heard his playoffs today, so many people are, like, warming up for it.
Wait, ZQD ranked?
That's, oh, nice.
Another, wait.
No, what, wait, is Etzu the only person in top 500 right now in the entire team?
Oh, my God, wait, he is.
Oh, except for lying.
But, like, lying.
I heard, like, all he does is play rank.
But, he's, like, a hard rank grinder.
Another victim.
Another one.
bites the dust.
Yeah.
Which hero do you think you want to be today?
But, um...
Oh, wait, I actually want to look at Smash's...
Oh, my God, I've been playing Luna, like...
The whole fucking last couple of matches.
Luna isn't that bad, but it's just so Boring!
Ta-da!
Did I make it to Celestial 2?
No.
But no one else is.
I'm a bad Jeff after this.
Fuck.
Is this?
This is a Jeff map.
I'm a bad Jeff.
Yeah, I'm gonna make it.
Don't worry, chat.
I'm going to make it.
I don't know if I'll play much of next season.
Because I heard, like I said, next season, um, next season is going to be a lot harder for support players.
Because everything is going to go against them.
Alright.
Spider-Man.
A friendly neighbor with Spider-Man.
Guys, they said triple support, not triple DPS.
Don't say that.
Don't say it's reachable.
I'm not here to hope, guys.
Hoping is bad.
Alright, here we go.
Go.
I have no more hope in my life.
Okay, that sounds really depressing.
In Marvel Rivals.
Sorry.
I meant in Marvel Rivals.
I mean, that sounded super edgy.
End game.
God, this...
I swear to God, this widow play...
is like the most cracked shit I've ever seen oh my god I guess oh my god and there okay it's fine she is I say that and then I get headshot truly is one of those days spider-man no spider-man come back oh my god Megan spider-man please I'm looking at you oh my god spider-man lost oh my god oh my oh my what that is so weird she's just shoot okay she shot the way I don't know I don't think she knew that was a window that's so weird to do Okay,
I'm good Snowflake.
Oh, you weren't looking at...
There was no way I was gonna grab Snowflake for you earlier.
Alright, nice.
Oh my god, he's actually him.
What?
Oh my god, he's actually Spodman.
Alright, it's...
You're gonna...
You're gonna do that thing!
We're... uh...
Where it's just they have triple support, so this game is going to last forever.
Again.
What the fuck is wrong with you?
What?
Oh my god, it's the...
Oh my god, it's Spider-Man.
It's the Spider-Man.
Oh my god, it's him.
It's actually the friendly neighbor.
my gosh mantis friendly neighborhood spider-man okay i healed you okay i i did my best just doing i'm just pre-healing him just in case i just don't rest my team uh you're halfway there keep going uh oh yeah uh i'm sorry i just uh all next i am ready all right i use bc oh my god he's dead
i don't think we're winning this fight oh yeah hundred percent no i got you i got you mag she got me and i got you
oh my god what the fuck happened
okay it's fine i talked because Because I didn't know if like...
I didn't know if our...
Sue was gonna alert or not.
So I was like, okay, I should...
I don't know where he is.
I'm...
I got scared.
I don't want to get yelled at.
Don't worry, Doug!
I heard Doug is...
Didn't Doug like a controller?
I don't know.
Oh, God.
Wait, where is Moonet?
Where is he?
Will we ever know where he is?
Jesus Christ why are we running like me more without the the Hulk also there is a mag that's just chilling here I shouldn't give them any ideas though they're like wait she's right why are we running it without the Hulk I don't want him to get any ideas where the my friend
There he is.
Alright, we're pushing the cart.
I hope our Spider-Man's okay.
Oh my god, he's okay.
He's okay.
Oh, he's ready.
Doug is ready.
Go, Doug, go.
I know you'll want to do it again.
Oh my god, goodbye.
Okay, I'm trying my best right now.
Again!
Goodbye, Doug.
Goodbye,
Doug.
Hello again?
I love Pluto so much, dude.
There we go.
Oh, no.
Oh my god, thank god!
Why don't I ever do that?
get players like, why don't we're...
What?
Wait, where is...
Where's the other?
Oh, it's right there.
I had to look again.
I was like, where is it?
Oh, where's my Spider-Man, too?
There he is.
Did he get the snowflake?
I couldn't...
Yeah, he did.
This is bad.
I'm trying...
I'm trying my best to get you.
Damn!
Finally.
I felt like...
I felt like I haven't had a mag that actually blocks alt in 20 years.
In 20 years, this felt like the first time.
Lunar, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
The only cure is more Marvel rivals.
That's the only cure.
Don't worry, I can make it.
I can make it.
That's the only cure.
Doctor, doctor.
Round two.
Me making a moth, please.
What?
Who's he?
Wait, is he talking to me?
Oh, dog.
Oh, he's talking to dog.
Dog.
I was like, what me?
It's like, oh no, Doug, it's Doki.
I don't know.
It sounded the same.
Talk to me earlier?
Yeah, Doug.
I'm letting you know.
Bro, is he okay?
Why is he stuttering?
Is he so nervous?
He's like...
If you made me a mod, you could get free Elo.
Good luck.
Jesus.
Guys, if I get...
Oh, he's dead.
Never mind.
Bro's so nervous.
No, he's nervous around.
Doug, Doug.
Doug, he's our man.
No one can do it.
I guess we fucking die.
All right.
That's fine.
It's fine.
Good luck.
I go down.
That's not how it's seen goes.
Spider-Man.
It's crazy.
They went two tanks and still it's not Bruce.
It's not Hulk.
Wait, at least the widow is like, whoa, that widow swapped?
That's crazy.
What word am I living in?
The widow actually swapping.
Guys, you would know if I didn't have a sponsor today, I would keep building rivals.
You're so right, chat.
I like to joke you none of us said that.
Chat, you're so right.
I'm talking to the chat in my head.
What?
You're so right, chat.
The voices, yeah.
The chat in my head, you know?
There's you guys in that chat, in the other chat.
There you go.
We did it.
Oh yeah, also I found out, don't stand on the cart when you're ulting, because, um, it's bugged.
The heals can get bugged out.
not fun i can't do anything um the chat like uh your heels can actually get people killed because it won't heal people so don't stand on the yeah the elevation so don't stand on the car if you're if you're using a support oh just sitting in their spawn i can't even die oh man poor spider-man he can't kill
Oh no, we're Spider-Man.
Not the Spider-Man.
He can't do the thing he wants the most.
That's sad.
Oh my!
Holy shit!
Bro, he used his own fucking thing against him.
That's so...
Damn.
That poor guy.
That's actually what a crazy shit to do.
He used his own fucking ult.
Oh, that's unlucky.
I almost killed him too.
I almost killed him.
Wait, did our Spider-Man die?
Okay, he didn't.
I was gonna say that would be so awkward if I just left.
There he is.
There is the Spider-Man.
Hello.
He definitely has ult, though.
So he's coming over.
He's slowly coming over.
Let me just slowly back up, too.
Yeah!
Woo!
Yeah, I'm not wasting my ult for myself.
Because Spider-Man is so blood-firsty.
Yeah!
Good game, guys.
Celestial 2!
We're back.
I made so many people to rank out of Celestia too.
Another gate properly kept.
Oh my god, he's jailed for his crimes.
What did he do?
Other than murdering thousands of people.
What else?
What did he do?
It's so fun.
come thank you for the twitch prime thank you thank you
nice it's because i have zero damage i swear this is like um not a lot of well i think it's because i have gm players maybe i mean that's why game hates me it does that's okay it's a love hate relationship uh i wanted to check oh i'm 200 709 i think need a win like wow okay i think this is where things don't get happy anymore i was gonna say should i avoid someone on actually let's check let's check oh yeah i'm getting 16 bro i wasn't for i'm fucking oh my god bro is bro what 16
That's actually bullshit.
Oh yeah, I want to check a replay of something.
What was it?
I don't want to check the replay of again.
I said I wanted to check the replay of something, but I forgot what it was.
Oh, that's good boy.
Oh, Smash?
What do I want?
Oh, wait, he didn't do it.
Coward!
No, I want to check a replay earlier, but I forgot what it was.
was what i wanted to check replay of a minute
uh one final hit five this guy he's decent on widow sometimes like when he had when he isn't getting like jesus christ wait isn't this guy the name or player oh my god this is some mysterious shit i'm gonna avoid this guy this guy was pretty bad And he's gonna be like generation pop-off.
Oh no.
I didn't avoid the other.
It took away the avoid from the other guy.
Yeah, because I'm not letting him fucking throw my game.
There we go.
I found him.
It's okay.
It's alright, guys.
Price is averted.
Uh...
Oh yeah, I wanted to check the...
The invisible woman.
What was it?
Was it here?
Oh yeah, it was.
Okay.
There we go.
I wanna know.
Wait, that's the cloak and dagger.
Sorry, they're both blonde women.
Look at this.
Look at this!
like how i damage boosted that like how look at this look at this damage boost like
all right that was bullshit okay i wanted to that boy yeah we did all right let's go the blonde women i can't tell other blonde women apart it's so hard I can barely tell I can barely tell myself apart.
You're tearing me apart.
Sorry, I'm like I think I am tired now.
Evil is a rejection of life.
There's a possibility that I'm tired.
Just a possibility.
But the gatekeeping.
hello everyone I played Marvel rivals for 12 hours straight hello part of a death album everyone's fighting why fight when I can do peace and war wait okay I was gonna say what whoa
Hello.
Wait, what?
Oh my god.
Oh my god, and then you have this really hype because their dog is doing zoomies right now.
You have a husband, ma'am.
Ma'am!
You have a husband!
Oh my god!
Ah!
He's eating her out!
oh my god they're rope they're erp oh my god they're erp right now they're erp with evils what am i watching wait this is what am i watching right now
caught that's crazy he's like no no ERP but are you guys date
I'm like a kid I'm like oh my gosh um are you guys dating They're getting some spice.
Oh my god, he's helping her shower.
Oh my god.
They're just talking in emotes.
No words.
Just emotes.
They are peeing in my Christian rival servers.
I'm a coward.
I'm a fucking coward.
I'm gonna make it hot.
Great.
Do it.
Hit and stay.
Are you in?
Are you in this room?
Oh!
Oh, he doesn't.
Oh my gosh, she doesn't like that.
She doesn't like how close I am.
Oh my, she's like, that's my man.
Oh my gosh, she's like, yeah, that's my man.
Oh my gosh, she hit me.
She got jealous.
He's like, get out of here.
That's my man.
Only my man.
Bro, what about this hyperactive dog?
Won't you let them ERP in peace?
No!
How dare you ERP in my lobby afraid of women?
Why are you afraid of women I'm not the type who fades quietly into the background now I just want to know I'm not a question I can ask he's afraid of women see it should be a thing I can ask it's a genuine question yeah it's his name see He's afraid of women He's not answering me.
Why is he ignoring me?
Because they are scary.
How?
How are they scary?
I want to know and then we're gonna lose and he's gonna say his slurs When he finds out I'm a woman I
He's gonna find out I'm a woman that starts seeing slurs because they are and then my team's gonna fight and I'll be like, stop fighting.
Stop fighting!
Am
I okay?
That's a good question.
All right, here we go.
Here we go.
Rocket.
of course the afraid of women man is put a raccoon player too um that's all right
don't worry i'll be away for the sponsor okay i'm just counting in my head ew what skin is that three two are you great oh it's like a gray shark That's an ug- Oh my god, they're playing- I have to play Invis!
Yeah, I have to play Invis!
I don't know why I've had two diffractions there.
He missed.
Yeah, I can play.
That was so smart from our Angela there.
Our Angela is so smart.
Are you pushing the cart?
They are.
We gotta get that cart pushed back.
don't worry I got you Bucky I got you I got you oh my god she's looking for it she's looking oh shit where did you take her goodbye chef goodbye goodbye oh she's coming she's coming no okay I can swap now.
I can swap.
Oh my god, they're also... I need to go to this anyway.
Oh shit, I'm against good support players.
And now I'm afraid of women.
There's no way... Yeah, I was gonna say, there's no way he lives that.
I'm dead.
I'm so dead.
Oh shit.
Hello.
I'm so...
He's still so dead.
Willie Steve, why are you standing there?
Thought you wouldn't see me again.
I don't think we're touching point, guys.
Yeah, I don't think we're touching point.
Yeah!
It's fine.
It's not fine, but it's fine.
I gotta make sure my team is okay.
feeling fantastic all right raccoon first right right usually it'll be a raccoon first right right right usually right oh my god I'm so scared oh my god oh my god oh my god I oh my god what's going on What?
What the fuck?
I don't give up so easily.
Oh my god, what happened?
What fucking happened?
We should ban Jeff.
We should ban Jeff on the Jeff map.
Can we just full redo?
All right, happy.
Did you do something on Jeff?
Whoa!
Bro, what the fuck you want me to do?
Oh no, oh no.
they're fighting now they're fighting they're fighting now i knew this was gonna happen i told you this was gonna happen i've got your back i knew it
i told you
I have a nice conversation with them and then they're gonna start fighting This sucks is like the thing is their support players are actually really good players like they have cooper too He's playing fly quest and fly quest is currently like number one
Oh my god, I'm so scared Okay, I'm still alive for now This is where it ends.
You like the...
For now?
For...
There we go.
I am actually on board.
Like, I can't...
There's just not enough...
There's not enough defensive ult.
I knew.
I knew that was gonna happen.
I had a feeling.
Oh.
Oh, I'm trying.
I'm trying my best.
I'm trying my best right now.
With the situation I'm in.
Goodbye.
this not looking so good for our team it's
okay it's okay sometimes sometimes you should never let you know it was a mistake to try interact with my team it really was.
It was a mistake.
Talk.
It really was a mistake trying to be friends with my team and... Oh my god!
How?
It's okay.
It's not okay, but it's okay.
Oh my god, they finally killed him.
What are they trying to kill?
I'm so confused.
Where's my team heading?
Goodbye.
Hello?
Dude, they're okay.
They're okay.
I think.
They're not really okay, but like, I'm just hoping.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Where?
You don't know.
Okay, they're gonna know now.
They know now.
Okay, they might know.
It's fine.
We're coming back.
Thanks for healing me there, Jeff, bro.
Appreciate that.
It's okay.
Wait, did we see that?
We see that.
He's such fucking reaching.
bro are you that retarded they're EU just you're just the EU dog bro I don't care about you you think solo Jeff feels is gonna out heal three people focusing on like you're mentally retarded you had your own yeah I went in yeah I went in as soon as I got my so they they actually made a change to Jeff off where go fuck yourself go eat a burger yes yes you got me bro yep yes you are 300 kg go shoot up your own school you're a real human bro you're very real see and this is why we don't have voice chat in league this is exactly why we don't have voice chat in league guys i told you that's what's gonna happen guys remember what i said like five minutes oh my god i don't remember 10 minutes ago or we're gonna make a he-ha and then they're and then and then the and then the guy the afraid of women guys gonna start slur like it starts slurring I just didn't realize that Jeff's gonna join in too I spoke it into existence I knew it was I knew it I knew it
I call it I truly did call it that's crazy I actually knew it was gonna happen too Jesus what the fuck I got beep bopped everywhere yeah all right let's go back I just
knew it was gonna happen.
I knew the moment I talked to my team As like a fun he-he-haha thing I knew I knew it was a mistake I got too friendly
Are we gonna win?
We are not gonna win this I don't think so.
But it's nice that, you know, we're not going to get full held, right?
We're going to get full held, aren't we?
Oh, shit, we're going to get full held.
I can feel it.
This sucks because I have to keep track of my...
of this Angela.
Because I don't want to...
This is real firepower.
I have to keep track of this Angela.
Because he's just going to keep doing that stupid push shit.
Oh, my God.
I don't want to pull it.
I'm so sorry.
Hey,
guys.
Whoa.
Yeah, it's not fun.
Yeah.
Oh?
I?
Did you get anyone?
Oh, he did.
Bro, there's like a fucking 2v2 right now.
There you go.
Goodbye.
Bro, he's coming.
He's going for another one.
I'm so scared.
Coming for another one.
Now you see me.
Bro, what's going on?
What's going on?
on.
I don't know.
I don't know what's going on.
Let I don't know what's going on anymore.
This is this is hell.
Guys, I think we're getting full health.
Guys, I spoke too soon.
We might actually be getting full health, guys.
I spoke too soon.
Okay.
Oh my god, it was possible.
Yeah!
Goodbye.
It's like, yeah, I'm watching like several what, you know what, fuck this, I'm invisible.
I'm gonna stay invisible.
Fuck this.
The moment I get out of invisible, it's all bad things happen.
Bad things happen.
I don't know if he'll be alive.
No.
Oh, no.
He's coming for me.
Bro, fuck up!
Bro, what do you want from me?
Hide and seek.
zero two three no he was actually just hunting me down well mel no he was just a penny one trick that's become an angela one trick and um that's it that's his entire story shinobi think of a twitch prime thank you thank you bro wanted me fuck 23 really after the hell i'm okay i think we actually have to avoid someone should have just played rocket.
Fuck that shit.
This is like the hell I have to go through and then minus 23.
I don't even know the point.
I guess afraid women.
I'll do afraid women.
And...
I mean, they were all pretty...
Not great.
Not fun.
They were all...
Um...
We avoided him?
I don't know if he was a bad Jeff player.
You're trying to secure it too, I see.
Oh, he's always so close.
I don't know if he was a bad Jeff player.
Hey, his name is John.
His name's Jeff.
Yeah, I don't think he was a bad Jeff player, though.
That's the thing.
It was fine.
yeah yeah you're right i'm going to doing a good deed and helping him um avoid women so you can't be more afraid hey john oh i forgot to oh he was that bad was he oh we avoid him i just hate playing as jeff that's it playing as jeff is just not fun one may feel empathy for an enemy and still destroy them you're right wait i should now i'll avoid him i'm thinking about it i'll avoid him so maybe i can get a better jeff player on my team now that i think about it i can always get a better jeff player
no need oh cool thanks bro i don't have to waste my voice lot i really appreciate it
I don't have no void.
Okay, yeah.
I'm just good here.
I don't know what I did wrong.
It was a lost game.
I was just fucking running around.
What did I do wrong, though?
I'm just thinking, like, wait, what did I do wrong?
I mean, free of void slot, but still.
I felt like I was just...
Maybe he's also afraid of women.
I'm pretty sure, like, in that entire game, I wasn't part of the problem that we had.
But you do you, buddy.
You do you.
And he prefers...
It was basically spawn camping me the whole game.
wasn't really trying because half basically like 50 my team was already like throwing like then i knew it wasn't winnable so i was just like at that point i was autopilot because i was like the attack i could tell during the attack like things weren't yeah everyone was just doing their own 1v1 at that point i was just like okay let me just but i know defense wise that game i wasn't i was mostly i was trying
um but um but yeah free avoids that i like how you said ggs it actually says like ggs what an
eu experience there
i hate everything about that's what saying.
I'm like, what the fuck did I do?
What was what was it?
What did I do?
Oh my god, the entire area is broken.
Hello, buddy.
Hey.
Whoa.
Everything okay.
Oh.
Where did she go?
Where did she wait, I'm by myself.
You want to avoid him so he got offended what i didn't even say i wanted to avoid him i was like i think he did i was like i'll avoid him just so i can get better support i can get pro support there chair
see you know depending on how aggressive we play if we play like high damage output um I can play strange and we can TP jump them.
I think Packers got that.
Who's Packers?
Him?
I'm listening to Link in part and on Adderall.
I see what we do.
I see.
Whoa.
Oh my god.
He's on Adderall.
He's going to do it.
Do you want to get Ultron here or Jeff or Emma?
Get Jeff out of the way.
Ultron Jeff or Emma?
Get Jeff out of here.
I'm tired of that motherfucker, bro.
Oh, you better be fucking gaming, or I'm going to be very upset.
Triple support and take over your fucking...
You better... I'll be very upset.
Pick your hero.
Or villain.
Alright, here we go.
I'm ready.
Let's see...
Just gotta check something real quick.
I don't know.
Oh shit, he doesn't know.
I don't know if we'll win this.
They have two top 500 players on the enemy team.
Or like X top 500 player.
And I have...
I'm gonna go heavy damage, uh, Packers.
Do you play DPS?
I can Neymar or Mantis?
Oh, all right, never mind.
We're not gonna TP jump on, bro.
What are we doing?
Well, that's just...
We already have two tanks.
You can go another...
No, I was gonna go strange.
I was gonna go strange and we could TP jump him if he did damage.
Are we doing it?
What are we doing?
Hello?
I'm confused.
No, no, no, no, no.
What are we doing?
We don't have damage for it.
I'm confused.
What are we doing, buddy?
I'm so confused.
Luna.
Alright, here we go.
Don't worry, guys.
I have mines.
Don't worry!
Moon Knight.
Okay, we don't.
Okay, maybe we got word.
Okay, okay, Packers.
Okay, Packers.
That was... Oh, GG's this game was over.
GG's.
Yeah, keep fucking up this little venom here.
They're gonna walk.
Guys, it's a 5v6, guys.
Hello, don't worry, hello.
Welcome back to the world.
Goodbye, everyone.
They don't know.
It was nice meeting you all.
They're gonna...
They still don't know.
I got the bridge.
Oh, he came back!
He came back!
No!
Come on.
Oh my god, he came back.
I don't know.
Maybe it...
The thing is, the thing I'm worried about is that we struggled 5v6.
Oh, wait.
The thing is, we sort of struggled 5v6, so...
I'm not that happy.
Guess who's back.
Back again.
I mean, we did heal.
I am ready to put on a show.
We did heal.
All right.
That's a lot of...
There you go.
three two one enter
i can't see you okay oh my poor uh my uh they use my uh it's okay it's okay it's not okay
that's just why i'm like He did struggle!
He fucking moved the portal.
I have Mantis all on point if you guys want to jump in.
He doesn't know.
This is you Mantis.
You're doing what you're saying?
It's okay.
Oh my god, he knows.
He knows.
Oh my god, you're crazy, you're crazy, you're crazy.
You'reointing, you're crazy.
You're so crazy.
I'm gonna go mags for this last fight.
You're actually crazy for doing this.
Shoot venom.
I've been stalling him, dude, it's just their backline.
I can't tell- their backline.
It'sini- super tough with Adam.
It's not happening.
It's fine.
We, I don't know how we saw that long.
Yeah, we did it.
We fucking did it.
I was just, I was everywhere.
Oh, Emma's still up, bro.
Let's do this shit.
We're good.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
I mean, I almost have, I'm going to use it.
I'm going to use it.
now swap to oh my god what do i swap here oh nice let's go he's gonna res though see he's not gonna res i don't think you can oh my god maybe not maybe maybe oh they're fucking getting rid of it That's unlucky.
I already ran Mantis and Moonlight.
It's all right.
I am here.
I don't know.
I mean, Mantis, you couldn't go first when we needed.
Drop left, drop left.
You need it.
Yeah, this time when you need it, please.
Go go go go.
I'm drawing attention force.
All right.
Come on.
Let's go.
All right, here we go.
Here we go.
Oh, I need it.
All right, here we go.
Here we go.
That's five.
How is he not dead?
Oh, Adam.
Here we go.
Got him.
Um, Adam has res.
I'm pretty sure.
All right.
Hello, hello, hello, hello, hello, hello, hello, hello, hello.
Oh, this is a very- we gotta die.
I'm just gonna die now.
They just don't die.
Oh, what do we do?
Oh my god, we have to keep playing Rocket.
Oh, this is unbelievable.
I don't know, bro.
We just need like We either run we either run triple tank or we need we need a we need a venom We need a venom if like you played venom, that'd be great guys Why did he come back?
Why did he come back?
Why I wanted it?
I knew this was gonna happen.
I was so ready for the cancelled match I was I was like yippee More aggressive because three of this.
Yippee!
I'm healing back for the venom now.
You're a shooter.
I said, do you play like...
For the things I said in the...
He didn't even say any...
Wait, what?
What did he say?
Did he think I'm the other afraid women guy?
What did I say?
Hey!
Oh, he was the one that said slurs?
Oh, okay.
Okay, never mind.
Never mind.
I didn't realize he was, I guess he doesn't want to get reported.
I think we just gotta, we just gotta target ours.
Is that why you avoided me?
Because he's like, I'm avoiding you because I said slurs.
Like, is that how it goes?
Go up on, dude.
Easy key.
Bro, how is he alive?
Bro, that's unlucky.
There's no way he'd lose that.
Okay.
Good deals, good deals.
There we go.
I look in one shot, dude.
There's supports.
We're good.
I'll play with him.
Yeah, we already caught him on stream, so I was just...
I'm just like, what the fuck did I do?
I have up.
Yo.
I'm gonna stay back for when they die.
Don't worry, I pocket you, girl.
There you go.
Bro, why did he...
Okay.
I was gonna go first in all of them.
What is that?
Help him There you go Oh my god Oh my god, thank god, he didn't get the damage thank god
Oh my god, why did he what?
What?
I got tanked.
Uh, yeah.
Can you play?
I'm just very disappointed in our Adam.
It really was very unfortunate.
It really was.
Yeah.
Venom's gonna be fine.
It'll be fine.
Oh my god, he was so low too.
Nice.
I helped.
Oh.
I'm trying to help.
You're blocked off.
Strange.
There you go.
Please, we gotta kill him.
All right, here we go for a bit.
I'll just play with my Hella.
That's really it.
That's the plan.
How are we doing that ult here?
Oh, we only have one out.
I know, I know.
What order are we doing it in?
Me.
We're doing it all behind.
Mantis, Luna, Invis.
How about that?
Now I see them.
Venom's on the roof.
What is the one on down, man?
Oh yeah.
There we go.
Jesus Christ, get out of me out of here.
Get me out of here, buddy.
Okay, um...
I'm trying.
So...
What's it with?
Hmm...
Are...
My Groot locked me...
You know how he's like, lock him in?
Lock him in?
My Groot locked me...
He locked me in...
Holy fuck!
The value's like, lock him in!
They just have mantis?
Yeah, just mantis.
I'm gonna try to eye it.
No, strange, strange, strange, strange, strange.
Okay.
Alright.
We are undefeatable!
Okay.
There we go.
Is that big, uh?
Alright.
What?
What a way with words.
Please, please, please, please, please.
Please, please, please.
Please, please.
I'm trying to go.
Please.
I got him.
How do I stop right?
TP.
Yo, close, close, close.
Out of one.
There we go.
Yes, we did it.
We did it.
did it.
I don't know how.
The moon clearly is haunting me.
I love triple support.
I love it.
Oh yeah, I will be if I lose.
If I lose this, I will be.
Life just likes to be a little silly.
Alright, so we're gonna go Mantis in this.
30 seconds before you attack.
Yeah I mean judging by how fast I mean Yeah, we just got a heavy pocket.
All right.
Hello Our hello gets damage boost and heals non-stop.
It's just me and hello Of course, I'm still playing.
What does this look like?
Looking roblox the battle starts in five four three Yep, don't worry area.
Got it?
Fight better.
The fullest.
Two.
I'm staying.
Three.
Oh my god, please.
I'm waiting.
Oh my god, I feel like...
Fuck.
I want healers.
They have no healers, no healers right now.
What the fuck is going on?
Come on, let's go.
I had a feeling this was gonna happen.
Oh my god.
I had a feeling.
I mean they used strange alt for it Yeah strange you went behind a wall and I couldn't that was very unfortunate Yeah, yeah, we were not living that mantis.
Okay, we can push with my alt here I'm gonna try to push my Hello, hello.
We're gonna walk now so I can kill the healers Wait for me.
Oh my god.
Why are we all grouped up?
Why are we grouped up with Moon Knight?
We know Moon Knight is out.
I'm dead.
I killed two healers.
They're trolling.
Come on.
Bro, he's just like moving.
Careful.
I'm good.
Uh, Adam Resin's up.
He's like, you guys have to be trolling, right?
I killed two healers.
Bro, our Hela is literally fighting for his life for us right now.
Our Hela is just like, please, how much more do I have to do?
That's all support ult's done.
Yeah, I just feel so...
Our poor Hela.
Our Hela is...
Not having a good day.
We only have one front line tank.
We need a tank bag and actually pressure the back line.
That's why they're creating more space than us.
Yeah.
Bro, he's so smart.
He's so smart.
Blinking as well.
Moon Knights might be on the right side.
Be right here.
I'm an emulist.
Fucking dog shit.
Bro, I can...
Okay, I was gonna say.
Dog shit.
Wait, what is...
I'm ultimate.
We have to.
Yeah, bro.
I killed a healer.
Bro, I'm trying.
I really am.
I...
please.
Oh no!
He's got the... oh my god, not the moon!
Oh, we have no sub portals.
I definitely got RNGed with two.
teammates.
That's okay.
I've gate kept another game.
How many moves does this man have?
Well, we have brute.
It's just like a misunderstanding of how to play the game.
How do you misunderstand how to play the game?
We're playing the same game.
I feel so bad for Ahela.
Ahela did so much for that game, too.
The keeper returns.
The It's so over.
I just, oh, they're at minus 24.
Why does it keep?
I swear, I'm in like purgatory.
I'm actually in purgatory.
Actually, I don't know.
I don't know who to avoid that game.
Bro, like 23, 24, 16, 17, 18.
Like, I'm stuck in hell.
Oh, Packers.
No, Packers for sure.
No, I remember now.
For sure, Packers.
No, I don't know.
Yeah, no, I've seen some very questionable things from Packers.
Welcome back.
Bro, there must be something wrong with this, man.
It's been five hours, I think.
Has it?
No, it's been three hours, and he's constantly sending me friend requests.
There is absolutely something wrong with him.
Like, I'm sorry.
Like, I usually don't say this, but mentally-wise,
like the fact that he checks back he spams ads me every time no it's just so interesting i'm not blocking him because he's so persistent and it's so interesting he really wants to yell at me like i can't help my guy like actually
he was in my no he's just a weirdo he apparently hates women too that's the thing he also really hates women no
he added out for like i didn't even say anything and i think he thought i was the other women that talked like talked back at him because i didn't say anything and then he like um and then he kept going on and on and then like in another apparently he just hates support players too.
He really fucking hates support players and women.
It's like, it's so weird.
And then my chat was just roasting it now.
And then, like, I told the devs about it because he was being such a fucking weirdo on my stream.
And I told the devs about it.
And then they muted him afterwards.
Because I'm pretty sure he has said some really fucked up shit to other people.
No, it's that guy that's being weird yesterday.
He's been spam adding me on rivals the entire like the last three to four hours he's been non-stop adding me trying to add trying to friend request me yeah there he goes again look there he goes like bros actually seek out bro like there he goes again look see every time i ignore it he comes back he checks too
No, there is a block feature, but it's just, it's so interesting to me.
It's so interesting.
I want to know, because he's hate watching me right now.
And that's, that doesn't matter to me.
That's just ad revenue.
Like, like, that doesn't matter to me.
Like every, I know he's hate watching me too.
I'm literally living red free in his head.
Oh, wait.
That means I can run 30 seconds of ads right now if I think about it.
What?
I give money to one you're angry at.
That'll show her.
No, he's like a...
He's either a...
Okay, he's either a grown adult or a teenager.
That's the thing.
Or, like, because he has hit puberty.
I don't think he'll ever like I don't think he'll ever like out unless that a woman like actually fucking hates herself there's no I don't think he's ever gonna get some
Cherry and Sabine um and Toki thank you for the Twitch Prime thank you thank you
I don't know if he has a job or like is going to school, because he's been playing Rivals, like, fucking weird-ass hours.
His job is a professional hate watcher.
That's fine with me.
I know I'm his gifter.
Thank you for gifting us up.
Thank you.
I'm banning torch.
I don't care.
And you know what's...
I just find it super interesting.
Pick your hero.
It's a nice case studies.
ladies no matter how low your self-esteem is you can do better than honestly you can definitely do a lot better no it started like uh it literally started like today like i've never seen this man before in my life and then he had he's like super fixated on me because i was the one that guess it makes him so angry it makes him really angry
uh this is a weird-ass combo whatever no i literally like reach out to a devil about him it was uh
your battle starts in five four three two one all you need to do is to the mission area got it oh we're going left side okay i hear him jumping i actually don't want to go left side it sounds scary left side scares me oh no i'm scared already i'm so scared
i'm so scared you know why i'm so even more scared we do not have a lot of heels if you think about it.
Oh, that's five.
That makes me more scared.
Our heals are not that strong.
We're literally running Adam Luna.
This is not the best of times.
Yeah, 12 hours.
And I streamed 10 hours last night.
Can't help it.
I just...
So I didn't have a sponsor stream.
You guys would know I would just keep playing, too.
That's the worst part.
If I literally didn't have sponsor, I would I would have kept going Okay, fuck this I'm farming off of you
Why did you put him closer to me?
Are Meg pushed him closer to me?
Are you serious?
Are you actually serious?
I would have lived I actually would have lived That's crazy
That's actually That's okay We're okay I like this red We're fine We're not fine We're not fine.
Oh, okay.
Oh, it wasn't unleashed.
Oh, my God.
I'm so scared.
Please.
Please, he's so low.
Please!
Oh, my God.
He's so low.
Okay, I'm coming back.
We only have Adam heels.
Oh, I forgot my seed.
Oh my god.
I'm running.
I'm skating.
I'm skating fast.
I need to stop being greedy when that happens though.
Sometimes I just get so greedy.
Because I'm like, oh, I can kill him myself.
But like, obviously I can't.
I'm just a little guy.
I'm just such a little guy.
just let him tap that okay okay I'm a little scared oh my god oh my god oh my God oh my god please what is going on I'm I'm trying to focus right now what is going on Jesus Christ I'm swimming I'm swimming!
I leave!
Okay.
That's fine.
Oh, they see nine!
They see nine!
Thank God!
Thank God they see nine!
That was crazy.
I was like, I think things are okay?
I think everything, so many things are happening.
Okay, I think we're okay.
I think we're okay, guys.
I A lot of stuff are happening, but I think we're gonna make it.
Okay, yeah, yippee yippee yippee yippee yippee yippee yippee
Now when I play too long I get so locked in I think it is also a lot I mean, like, playing support is that I don't stream my wrist a lot, or, like, my arm.
I arm aim.
I don't use wrist aim, but my...
Um...
That's why I can play long hours, because, like, support is so, like, much more, like, less aim-intensive than DPS in general.
So, yeah, I don't have to, like, worry too much.
Obviously, I still have to, like, you know, Make sure I don't fuck it up.
But it's not.
Oh my god.
Oh, I should have used C.
I should have used my C.
I just didn't think I was going to take that much damage.
Oh, they're not in Hulk anymore.
That's unlucky.
Where's the...
my oh
my god it's okay i messed up my the sea because i thought you would peek closer but he did it oh my god there's so much happening oh somewhere i got you i got you i still got you i think i i don't got you anymore
You gotta get over here if you want these juicy heals.
Nice.
There we go.
It's fine.
I think I damage boosted him?
I don't know.
I'll always be here, guys.
Don't worry.
Oh my god!
Worry.
Worry a little bit.
worry a little bit guys oh yeah no he's fucking dead dead
jesus christ i need heal oh oh my there was nothing we could do that was that was four wait
There was no way.
There was no way we could save them, man.
I'm sorry, buddy.
You were...
I'm sorry.
I'm giving this to the Star Lord.
You do not deserve that.
You do not deserve the Snowflake.
I saw your stats, buddy.
Okay, try hard.
Oh, I missed the freeze here.
Bro, when they jump, it's actually...
Oh, no.
I'm trying.
He has all two.
That's the thing.
I have to save my clap.
Can he walk the point?
I'm trying to...
I'm trying my best.
I'm trying my best to walk the point right now.
I'm frozen.
GG.
Oh, they've frozen.
him oh
my rocket is right oh hello hello oh that's unfortunate hello hello can we lock in guys what's going on okay so we do have a we do have a uh iron fist that may or may not i just win by the way i don't know what else to do it but uh yeah get the sidewalk from up on my tip and uh yeah it can make sure happen again are we running triple yeah i mean he's on cloak and dagger but like you know what i'll take it like yeah he's on cloak and dagger but uh figures can't be choosies you know like i honestly i would prefer rocket like they're not running phoenix come on go rocket Rocket,
come on!
Go Rocket!
Come on, buddy!
Ain't so bad, buddy!
I don't think we're gonna win this, even with Triple Support, because she's on Cloak and Dagger, and she's gonna get fucking Magelted.
She's gonna get fucking, uh, stoned.
I had a feeling.
I love.
Don't worry.
Oh my god, he's so low too.
I think that's the worst part.
No, no, no.
Okay.
That's fine.
Oh wait, we have...
Yay, we have a clear coat.
It's okay, things will be...
All right.
Things will be all right.
Jesus Christ.
Mag, please don't die.
I am clapping as...
Oh, okay, cool.
That's okay.
I'm okay with that.
Really do.
We didn't need it, but like That's all right.
You did great We definitely did not need it though But like it's okay You're doing a good job cloak.
I'm just glad you were willing to swap the triple support Like it takes a real man to say
Why did you fail I could have got alt I could
didn't fade if she didn't fade i had patty cake ready and i would have got uh i would have i actually i crashed out because i was like i was two percent and i was hoping that because she was oh i chose the wrong gamble i should have just i actually should have just ulted um i'm gonna kite point can you log
That's why I crashed it.
Oh my god.
There you go.
Holy shit.
I had to crash out there.
I really did.
It was 100% 100% worth crashing up.
Can I get flaked?
Because they're not watching anymore?
Thank you.
Yeah.
We need to save our cloaco for their struggle though.
We have sold bonds or shabako.
Please live.
Yeah, so nicely.
Nice.
I don't think I can live anymore.
I don't think I I lived for a very long time I really did He's not, he's, yeah, he's getting staggered as hell There's no way Look at the mag, I'm blocking him, look at the mag You're by yourself How do we look at him if you're by yourself?
There's so many What do you mean look at him?
It's just me and the other support.
Where do we look at?
Alright, I go.
I'm dead.
Not the best.
Oh, this is bad.
This is bad.
This is very bad because we used our cloca, which was our ace cart.
We have res, we have res, we have res.
Take the rest of you.
Hello.
I'm 1%, please.
Sick.
We have Luna combo again.
Walk, walk, walk, walk, walk, walk.
This was fine.
There you go.
Come on.
We gotta kill him.
We gotta kill him too.
And then also him.
Alright, we killed him.
Yay!
He fucking did it.
Oh no, Spider-Man.
Where's Spider-Man?
Where's that menace?
Okay, there we go.
Where's the menace?
oh thank god thank god we did our combo multiple times thank god it worked the menace is down finally the world will be safe i swatted that spider god piece of newspaper and slowly crushed it oh my god this is the i feel like this is the first time I've seen a plus 20 in 80 years.
It...
I feel like I haven't seen such a high number in so long.
It truly was a special day.
Oh, you stopped.
Nice.
This is not the same guy, for those who are wondering.
This guy is a pro player.
The other one's a weirdo.
This one's not the same.
This is a This is a pro player.
The other guy's the weirdo.
So both are weirdos.
I'm using the pack.
Grab your pack.
I'm ready.
That's why I should say not take coffee or energy drink.
This is my energy.
I am fueled by my love for the grind.
So you guys like get help.
You don't understand the grind.
it feels me it makes me so strong the plus 20 is my caffeine
it's okay and then after that i won't be as addicted to be fair it's only this season the season has been like really fun in general i don't know what it is um but this season has been um just really exciting in general i don't think i think next season i'm not gonna have as much fun for sure i have a feeling no i took a break i took a break look see um oh yeah this is sad but i have like random good streaks in general this is what this was solo and then then solo and then um let's see I did take a break.
See, look at this.
Okay, this is, look, 738.
Season 0.
177.
348.
I came back.
116.
77.
It gets lower and lower.
Well, not lower and lower, but it goes up and down.
It went lower.
Which
hero do you think you're going to be?
want to be today in iron fist ban iron fist i got a iron fist who is it ban iron fist ban iron we can we can be in phoenix if you want are you what the fuck or can you play something else otherwise we can ban phoenix now who am i gonna banish from this match ban from xyton xyton i'll be in iron fist next
rocket otp great
he not really but like what am i gonna do what can i do let him play what he wants oh no venom or service to ease the climb on mentally any mantis i can torch if i need to rmv needs that boost what the is rmv We're gonna have an Iron Fist.
Just be aware that in the back line.
Wait, we're not binding Iron Fist?
I guess because you wouldn't have damage boost.
But really?
You and heroes could make all the difference.
I'm Luna Snow.
Like the moon, I shine in darkness.
Alright.
No matter what happens, this is LG.
no matter what happens I'm calling it now I would I would keep up kept going honestly chat I will be real of you guys I would have kept going I would have but I just got text from the dog sitter and he's coming over soon so to pick that up because he's not going to die I I will have to set that up.
Oh, we will see about that then.
This has to be LG, because Ash has to go downstairs and drop him off.
So I have to stop.
Unwillingly.
Not because I want to stop.
Hey, bro.
I believe in you.
I'll fuck with Rocky.
I like Rocky, bro.
Don't mind it.
But Dad comes first.
Four, three, two, one.
No, because I have to prepare his, uh, are you running triple support?
Are you fucking kidding me?
Bro, nerd!
Alright, our Emma's AFK and he just...
What?
What the fuck?
He just...
He just literally...
Okay, that's okay.
Alright, Emma just...
Okay.
I mean, that's fine.
I just watched her Emma fucking let our...
We got three though, but it's fine, right?
He's not fine.
I was just like, what is...
What is her... Emma?
Okay, bye Emma!
I'm a bit staggered now, though.
Don't worry, I'm coming back, guys.
Oh, he rose.
Oh, yeah, I know.
These guys want to win.
Wait, Logan's been queuing all night.
Wait.
I swear, I've seen this guy on as long as I have.
Oh, man.
Not fair.
They have real players.
They have real players who Really, really want to win.
Hey guys, there's...
Oh, we're gonna...
Okay, that's good.
Oh, that's unfortunate.
That's actually unfortunate.
The reload, so let's hope he doesn't die!
I'm just gonna put it on like half an America.
Fuck it.
Why about putting it on the screen?
sila but now i don't know because this this captain america is going full america right now
oh to get a victory is he okay i think so follow the american dream oh my god he's coming over
he's helping me coming over he's coming over oh my god please tell me
I was like, please tell me someone's gonna block it, right?
Nobody blocked it.
Nobody blocked it in the end.
That's unlucky.
That's not fair.
They got real people.
As Logan falls that hard, that he's not secure.
That's crazy.
That's all right, Logan.
Sometimes it do be like that.
Sometimes life is like that.
No, we just don't have...
Okay, the only one that...
Hello?
Guys, guys, guys, guys, guys, guys, guys, guys, guys, guys.
I'm very scared.
Guys.
Guys, she's...
She's still grabbing them.
Oh my god.
According, he was so far up.
Guys, you don't understand.
He was so far up.
I even jumped, guys.
I actually, I jumped.
Um, good luck.
Oh my god, good luck.
I even clapped.
I clapped.
I did my little patty cake, hoping that you would live.
But I was wrong.
Okay, it's okay.
have up so it's not as okay but it's okay
oh the double support uh the captain america is technically our triple support
again oh he doesn't get reset all right so hmm now we only have two support us Technically
I'm gonna let yeah, I should let them you know, I'm gonna let the rocket heal.
I mean smart guys look look and go Yeah
There you go I had I was just trying to make sure Hello um
Oh my god, that's to be the smartest shit I ever done Actually crazy what I just did there.
Oh, nice Nice That's not good So I'm just really proud of myself.
You guys don't have, you have no idea how, I am so proud of myself for that.
That was crazy what I just did.
Chewk was so good.
Because I was like the only thing I, the only person I can rely on is myself.
Literally.
I can only rely on myself.
Please, it's just me.
It's just me.
Okay, I'm gonna...
Oh my god.
I can only rely on myself.
I won the mind game.
I won...
I won the mental warfare.
of this magneto that was actually crazy see I know I'm okay at Luna decent at Luna it's just what you see how like more fun it is to play Luna when I'm not getting run at by like three plus dive characters like yeah I have iron fist but he's just tickling me right now because he has no damage boost but like she's fun she's fun when I don't have like a Fucking venom a venom a spider-man a magic An iron fist like all of that shit just running at me.
It's so much more fun I just I just shoot things and they die like they're just there sidewalk to Thor Just fucking I wish we had 20 bands.
I'll ban half.
I'll do the I'll do I'll pull a Thanos and just that should be a game mode You fucking Half the characters are just got balanced as it all should be.
I just snapped the entire dive up.
I just think dive is so fucking boring to play against.
Obviously, like, yeah, of course I'll say I'm a support player.
Yeah, I know.
I'll say it because I'm a support player.
Yes!
Oh my god, they're going Jeff.
That changes a lot.
It changes a lot of things.
Ashley might make it a lot harder now.
Jesus Christ.
Lots of claps, lots of claps, lots of claps.
Are you doing okay?
Oh my god.
Who did he eat?
I don't know.
no okay
are they running they're running triple tank of course they are oh my god they actually are they really want to win i was like wondering why it's taking so why we're not doing nothing they're at home they're actually running i'll tell you right now they are running um I am ready to put on a show.
They're running, like, actual tournament, uh, tournament meta.
That's...
I'm dead.
I mean, like, a good for you.
Like, I hope it...
Like, the fact that they're going...
They went low-key, too.
They went full-style.
That's so cringe.
They want to secure it so bad.
Oh, my God.
a tp oh my god they're so cringe bro they're actually like please buddy i need please i need top 500 please please i need top 500 please oh can we please go ghost guys please can we please go ghost i really want top 500 please they're actually run like it's last day i gonna need top 500 they needed that fat the fact that running like the tournament strat of holding up close oh
my god and they kited you know they're calming hard right now you know they're calming this so fucking hard I am
ready to put on a show that sucks okay oh my god Poor the game.
No, it's just they're running actual tournament comp.
And they got all five, like all six people to agree with it too.
They got all six people to agree.
And they're playing, they're dragging, they're planning on.
Oh my god.
Okay.
That's fine.
It's like, I know they want to win.
It's just, it's so hard to get, like, I've never had a game in rank where everyone agreed, like, if it's all pros, I'd understand, but I've never had a game in rank where everyone, um, where everyone goes actual tournament comp, actual, like, um, go turn,
like, full tournament comp for this, that you will see in, like, professional play.
had it um with like actual like randoms because like they have half of them isn't randoms half of them are like actual pros but it's still like very impressive you know it's incredibly impressive i am ready to put on a show i would be very impressive they were able to goodbye
all right well I hope it was worth it.
I'm glad.
The gatekeeper has done it again!
The gatekeeper has done it!
The final gatekeeper in the final...
The Elo terrorist succeeds and I get Celestial too!
No.
Yay.
Let's go.
Desperate and still lost.
Oh my god.
Never rank 75.
Is he so slim?
Who is he?
Iso.
Who's this guy?
oh this was the guy that was like uh oh is it because i had damage boosted him like i actually babysat this guy so he's like i need that in my life i oh shit i'm sorry buddy i i'm sorry bro that sucks oh wait did the logan sack the expanded oh no i think he was like i'm Oh,
he let he quit because I know a Logan queues with necrust and I think I Think Oh, I'm sorry.
Oh, Logan.
I'm so Logan.
I'm sorry.
He's not secure yet.
He can't I think necrust give up.
I think that was yay I succeeded
Gate successfully kept
Yay!
Successfully.
That was the game.
That was the last straw.
I've done my job.
My O-sheet did it.
Yay!
Now I can rest happily.
Another play is stream destroyed.
All I'm saying is that this is what gives me...
I think this is why I can extremely long hours.
I think with this new mindset, like it makes me happy, like it makes me like less sad playing rivalries, knowing that I'm ruining other people's chances.
Like, uh, the, you know, terrorism arc is over for now.
I am just running on spite.
Hey guys, I hope you guys had a fun time watching.
Like I said, I'll be on vacation.
Not vacation.
Sorry, business trip.
I'm gonna treat it like a semi-vacation.
Um, um because i am traveling so i'm gonna you know still enjoy myself in my travels um but i do hope you guys like enjoyed the two very long streams i did today um um as a way to like you know as a way to um satisfy yourself before when before i come back because like i'll be gone for it till I'll be gone from Friday till,
uh, uh, Tuesday.
So, um, don't die.
Survive.
Um, anyway, guys, for those who don't know me, my name is Doki Bird.
And I usually stream on YouTube, but today I'm here.
Uh, because, like I said, I was doing guerrilla.
I like to do guerrilla stuff on here, like, like non-schedule streams here.
And my degenerate rank grinds.
I mean, I had a lot of fun.
I hope you guys had fun, too.
Um.
I hope you guys had a lot of fun watching.
I had a lot of fun playing.
It really does mean a lot to have you guys that hang out with me today during the climb.
It really makes rent climbing a lot more easier.
Also, like, if that guy that played me in another language,
if he, like, did that and I was off stream, I would have cried.
I would have actually cried
I would have been very sad But You guys You know, you guys helped me stabilize And kept me emotionally in check So I really appreciate it But yeah Please check me on YouTube I usually I usually stream over there But I do variety stuff If you want to know whenever I stream on Twitch,
please follow me on Twitter.
That's when I usually tweet out when I'm streaming on Twitch.
If you want to support me via other means, check out my merch.
It really does help a lot.
And I'll be having a sponsor stream later today with Cheapy-Doky on YouTube.
We're going to check out the launch of Little Night Mermaid 3.
So, yeah.
I hope you guys enjoyed the stream.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, pause, check it out, and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
also i'm just uh i'll read i'll read amali actually yeah i'll read amali because i just see you're live now all right guys i'll see you guys later everybody bye